wir überhaupt Zuhörer? Ich guck mal, nö, ich glaub noch nicht so richtig.
Eins, zwei, drei.
In welcher Sendung bin ich gerade? Ich mach ja so viel, ich weiß immer gar nicht.
Dennis, ich begrüße dich bei MOBAMAX, so heißt dieser Kanal. Und es ist nicht weniger als unsere 50.
Sendung, Leute.
Hab schon gehört.
Hab mir mein Agent gesagt.
Toll, oder?
Ich dachte bei 50 fällt jetzt hier was vom Himmel runter.
Ja, wo ist das Konfetti?
Ja, das ist genau das Richtige.
Just great wasn't just great.
Das ist incredible.
Super, ne? Hab ich aus diesem, ihr wisst sicherlich woher das ist? Nee, Soundboard hab ich da erst draus gebaut. Nee, das ist diese letzte Keynote.
Aus der Nokia-Developer Nokia.
Man versucht.
Nokia-Keynote sind auch inzwischen.
Auf jeden Fall nicht aus der Antennagate-Keynote.
Nee, aber ich glaube aus der letzten, die dann irgendwie zusammengefasst wurde. Die für die iPhone-Pods. Die, wo wir hier saßen und das Live uns angehört haben.
Wo 4.1 rauskam.
Da, wo du nicht da warst, oder?
Da, wo du nicht da warst. Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass es geschieht, aber es geschah. Hat jemand nur diese Teile, wo alles amazing und incredible ist, zusammengeschnitten, die ganze Keynote in 110 Sekunden. Das war natürlich super Futter. Dann hab ich das einzeln rausgeklambüsert. Jetzt liegt das hier auf meinem kleinen MIDI-Keyboard, sodass man nur noch draufklicken muss. Und wenn ihr der Meinung seid, ihr müsstet jetzt irgendwie...
Die Qualität könnte schon noch ein bisschen besser sein.
Manche sind ja so kurz abgehackt.
Ja, weil es halt auch nur so kurz war. Mehr musst du auch nicht wissen, Huckel. It's just great. Ja, und ich dachte, das passt.
Mein Vintoren muss ich ausmachen, ne?
Naja, du kannst ja zumindest ein bisschen den Zaum halten. Ja, super. Wir begrüßen ganz viele Hörer an den Hörgeräten da draußen. Ja, die Geräte, mit denen man hört. Und ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll. Wie lange machen wir das jetzt eigentlich schon?
50 Sendungen lang.
Bei einer durchschnittlichen Sendungsdauer von drei Stunden.
150 Stunden. Habt ihr jemand ausgerichtet, wie viel Content, die wir hier schon produziert haben?
Das sind vier Mann monatlich.
Vielleicht kann das ja irgendjemand im Chat ausrechnen.
All I got was this lousy Pizza.
Immerhin gibt es jetzt schon Pizza.
Ich hatte ja mal so einen Telefon-Podcast vor Jahrhunderten.
Stimmt, diesen 343 Max, da kam das auch her mit einem.
Genau, da kam das her. Ich muss jetzt noch mal kurz erzählen, das war so ein Anrufbeantworter, ich konnte draufquatschen und ich hatte die Nummer und ein paar Freunde. Und dann, was man auf den Anrufbeantworter draufgesprochen hat, das war dann direkt danach ein Podcast, den man, den ich bevorzugt betrunken eingesetzt habe, selbstverständlich. Und da hatte ich aber oben so ein Tool eingebaut, dass immer wenn man abgespielt hat, hat er gestoppt, wie viel Zeit das gehört worden ist. Und oben im Header stand dann drin Wasted so und so viel minutes of time on this planet. Und das war tatsächlich die realistische Zeit. Können wir hier nochmal grob einschätzen, wie viel Arbeitszeit wir eigentlich schon vernichtet haben?
Also ich weiß nicht, wir sind auch immer länger geworden. 50 Sendungen, ich glaube im Schnitt kommen wir schon auf zwei Stunden, also 100 Stunden.
Im Schnitt ist ja im Minimum schon lange.
Also mindestens sagt dich ja, ne?
Quatschen ja meistens danach, noch locker mal eine halbe Stunde und davor.
Vielleicht sind es auch 100, keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Sagen wir mal im Durchschnitt 1000 Hörer pro Sendung?
Also die das auch. Die Dauer steht im RSS-Feed, wenn sich jetzt so ein Kundiger-XML-Spezifikus den Feet schnappt. Aber da stehen glaube ich nicht alle Sendungen drin in dem Feed.
So 100.000 Stunden?
Und diese Imperfektion, ja, und das wie im Angesicht des Heiligen Steve.
Kann man es überhaupt leisten, um heute drum zu trödeln hier?
Smarter and smarter and smarter.
Das ist der ganze Tastierchen.
Das ist die 50.
Sendung, da kann man hier wohl mal ein bisschen...
Wir haben hier zu tun, glaube ich. Deine Liste von wollen, das hört sich an, als wenn wir hier noch eine Weile sitzen.
Also, lass mal los rocken.
Ja, ja, mach mal, mach mal. Wir müssen uns auch noch mal bedanken.
Fürs Flättern?
Fürs Flättern, überhaupt generell für den uneingeschränkten Zuspruch, den wir hier erfahren. Stimmt. Also so empfinde ich das. Und, naja, uneingeschränkt ist natürlich nicht. Es gibt auch Leute, die finden das total doof.
Ja, es gibt immer, ich sag jetzt mal, Trolle, aber es gibt es bei allem. Egal was du machst, egal wie gut. Es gibt immer die, die sagen, oh nee, geht dir gar nicht.
Ja, das sind wir.
Wobei, das ist der erste wirklich genuine Troll-Podcast von Trollen für Trolle.
Aber jetzt, auf der 50. muss man auch, langsam sind wir wirklich, früher waren sie besser reif, oder?
Wer war besser reif?
Wir.
Wir waren reif?
So zu dieser Aussage so, also früher waren sie noch gut, aber jetzt mittlerweile ist das ja echt scheiße geworden alles.
Ja.
Ja klar, wenn das alle cool finden, dann kann man es ja nicht mehr cool finden, weil es jetzt ja Mainstream ist. Es gibt ja mal Leute, die wollen ja immer so ein Stück voraus sein. Die suchen sich dann halt den nächsten neuen Scheiß.
So, das erste Thema ist eine Infrastruktur, ein Infrastrukturelement. Max habe ich da schon präsentiert, aber euch noch nicht. Es gibt nämlich jetzt ein neues Feature hier in der Metaebene. Und ihr habt jetzt irgendwie so eine tolle Wii-Mode in der Hand. Du da auch. Tatsache. Aber du hast die falsche. Ich glaube, du bist die 2 und du bist die 3. Genau. Die Rolls-Royce-Taste ist die A-Taste. Wenn du jetzt auf der Wii-Mode auf die A drückst, dann müsste eigentlich dein Mikrofon ausgeschaltet sein.
Okay, dann verrate ich euch mal jetzt ein totales Geheimnis. Gestern habe ich ja mit Steve telefoniert und er hat mir gesagt... Ja, und dann... Das war natürlich die totale Sensation. Das Problem ist mit dieser Rolls-Royce-Taste, ist ja, dass die anderen das natürlich dann über ihre Mikrofone immer noch behalten.
Nee, aber wenigstens, oder? Nee?
Nein, nein. Also du bist richtig off, es wird auch nicht aufgenommen.
Und ich sehe da rot im Display. Aber er meinte, dass...
Genau, da gibt es ja so rote Linien. Das kannst du dir hier auch live anschauen im Live.
Aber Hucke meint ja, dass das, was er sagt, über mein Mikrofon halt reinkommt. Stimmt schon.
Jaja, klar, das ist das Problem. Aber es ist halt so, wenn du wirklich mal... Äh, ne, also nochmal. Du warst jetzt mit oder ohne?
Mit oder ohne mit?
So, das zweite Feature ist die B-Taste, das ist die unten an der V-Mode. Wenn ihr die drückt, dann...
Die unten kann man mausen.
Die Nummer 1, die 2 oder was?
Nee, die hier, die Rückseitige.
A und B. Hast du keine V, Mann? Du hast keine Ahnung von der V-Mode, ne? Das ist B.
Verstehe.
Ah, da steht's. Okay.
Steht drauf? Ja stimmt.
Hast ja auch keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich bin professioneller Dilettant. Stehe. Als solcher. Muss man sich auch immer wieder dazu beweisen.
Ich mach mal das jetzt noch zu. Zur Feier des Tages.
Wenn du möchtest. So lautet es ja nicht, aber dann haben wir Luft.
Okay, wofür ist die B-Taste?
Die Luft ist super.
Die B-Taste, wenn du bitte mal die B-Taste drückst.
Ich drück mal und dreh jetzt mal weiter. Scheint zu klappen.
Siehst du mal? Und jetzt malst du hier... Genau, jetzt hast du so einen Strich reingemalt. Der ist sozusagen... Also die Idee, ob das funktioniert, das müssen wir jetzt mal sehen. Aber die Idee ist, dass wenn du der Meinung bist...
Das war spitze und dann drück ich.
Meine Idee war sowas wie, wir quatschen immer total durcheinander und irgendwann wechseln wir das Thema.
Und dann kann man immer eine Marke setzen.
Und wenn jemand von euch der Meinung ist, dass wir das Thema gewechselt haben, dann einfach mal B drücken eine Weile. Dann hinterlässt du eine Marke. Und wenn mehrere Leute gleichzeitig der Meinung sind, dass wir das Thema gewechselt haben, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass wir das Thema auch tatsächlich gewechselt haben. Und dann sehe ich das halt daran, hier in dieser Midi-Spur, dass eben 4 oder 3 oder 2 oder auch nur einer da eben was gedrückt haben.
Und wenn ihr der Meinung habt, dass wir das Thema wechseln sollten, dann so winken.
Und jetzt noch mehr Tasten?
Genau. Und dann gibt's noch die 1 und die 2. Die machen im Prinzip genau das gleiche. Also wir schreiben auch immer alle in dieselbe Spur, aber an einer unterschiedlichen Stelle. Also wir können ja mal zum Beispiel alle die 1 drücken irgendwie so. Alle die 1 drücken. So. Einer drückt nicht die 1.
Ich drück nicht die 1.
Drück mal die 1. Und die 1, dachte ich mir, wäre so die Taste, die man so drückt, wenn man irgendwie eine URL gesagt hat. Weil das ist immer so total anstrengend. Nach der Sendung 3 Stunden bist du total im Arsch.
www.apple.com Da wäre mal so eine Anleitung.
Sonst hätte ich jetzt hier gut, dass man sich so spät alles erinnern kann.
Genau, Mann.
Was? Wo ist der Screencast dazu?
Was soll ich in die Wand hängen?
Die Doku. Die Doku? Eine Taste zu drücken?
3 Tasten schon?
Ich hätte gerne so ein iPad-Programm dafür.
Kommt auch noch.
Genau, dann könntest du dich auf den Rechner machen.
Der Vorteil ist, du musst auf so eine Scheiß-Vimod nicht drauf gucken, sondern du hast sie einfach in der Hand und dann kannst du halt drücken. Ist ja auch erst mal nur so ein bisschen beta. Eigentlich möchte ich gerne so Geräte auf dem Tisch haben.
Kannst du alle gleichzeitig drücken? Ja, geht auch.
Nicht schlecht. Ich kann das sogar so machen, dass du da irgendwie mit Acceleration irgendwas steuerst.
Das hat er mir vorhin gezeigt, wie man mit Drehen lauter Blasen...
So sieht es nämlich aus. Genau, ich habe hier so per Drehen zum Beispiel meine Mixer-Fäder gedreht. Und jetzt die Frage.
Wer hat es erfunden?
Die Franzosen. Ja, wie habe ich es gemacht? Genau. Jetzt kommt The Beef, sozusagen in dieser Sendung. Wir schwatzen nicht einfach nur so, sondern hier gibt es auch einfach Hardcore. Ich habe lange nach so einer Lösung gesucht, war erst jüngst noch mal im Meta-Lab und habe mit tausenden Leuten geredet, wie man das machen könnte. Und dann kam der geile Tipp, eigentlich nicht im Meta-Lab, sondern hier. Es gibt eine Software für den Mac, und die heißt Osculator, und die ist einfach mal der Brüller. Das Ding ist so eine Art Event Hub für alle möglichen Steuergeräte, einschließlich alles, was MIDI spricht und alles, was OSC spricht. OSC heißt Open Sound Control und ist so in den letzten Jahren aus der Netzgemeinde heraus zu dem kommenden Standard Beyond MIDI gewachsen. Das heißt, wenn du all das, was du mit MIDI nicht machen kannst, weil MIDI hat ja zahlreiche Beschränkungen, geht nicht über IP, zumindest gibt es da keinen wirklichen Standard, wie man das macht, aber es gibt auch in MIDI einfach viele Beschränkungen, die früher, früher war das irgendwie luxuriös, dass du auf einem MIDI-Bus 16 Kanäle unterscheiden kannst. Heute brauchst du halt viel mehr, sodass man da mehrere Busse multiplexen muss und jeder, der mal so ein MIDI-Setup gemacht hat, weiß, das hat alles seine Grenzen oder sowas wie Kontrollwerte können halt von 0 bis 127 gehen. Das ist aber jetzt für so einen feinen Mixer-Fader, der einfach viel feiner auflöst. Genau, da müssen dann so zwei solche Werte kombiniert werden und so ein Scheiß. Also es ist halt alles irgendwie, jetzt könntest du deine Rolls-Ball-Taste drücken. Genau, super.
Ein bisschen zu spät noch.
Nochmal jetzt bitte. Hat man dich gar nicht popeln gehört.
Aber ich hab Popeln gemacht, das tut er jetzt gleich.
Das coole ist, das coole ist beim Oscillator, dass du hier sozusagen alle möglichen Events in so ein Dokument hineinsenden kannst. Das heißt, das Dokument steuert oder sagt welcher Event von welchem Gerät was irgendwie auslöst. Du kannst da irgendwie komplexe Routings in dieser OSC-Landschaft definieren. Da hab ich mich jetzt noch nicht so ganz eingearbeitet, aber du kannst halt auch einfach MIDI erzeugen. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt auf deine A-Taste drückst und dann dieser Event von diesem Oscillator über Bluetooth genommen wird, zugeordnet wird zu deiner Wiimote, der kann irgendwie bis zu sechs Wiimotes gleichzeitig steuern, dann macht der sozusagen aus diesem Tastendruck einen Ausschalten-Midi-Event, der hier direkt zu meinem Mixer geht und der den Kanal einfach ausschaltet. Also du kommunizierst quasi indirekt über den Computer mit dem Mixer, der dann wiederum das Ganze an Ableton weitergibt, sodass das eben auch parametrisch aufgezeichnet wird. Ich finde das total großartig.
Das klingt so, als wäre es total cool, aber es klingt auch so, als wäre in der Sendung gleich der Ableton geflasht.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Vorhin ist es so ein bisschen gehangen. Mal gucken. Vielleicht sollte ich nebenbei noch mal einen Recording-Job starten. Ich hab mal ein Backup-Recording noch gestartet. Unterstützt übrigens auch, nicht nur die V-Modes, sondern auch den Space Navigator. Das Teil, was ich hier habe. Was man eigentlich nur für 3D-Programme gut benutzen kann. Da hab ich jetzt noch so richtig keine Anwendung für, aber dieses 3D-Connection-Device leuchtet blau. Ist schwer.
Das ist schonmal eine wichtige Sache.
Und wenn man den Gummiring ab und zu auch mal unten so ein bisschen pflegt, dann haftet der auch richtig geil, hat auch noch zwei Buttons. Und damit kannst du halt Google Earth cool steuern. Also wenn ich irgendwas in Google Earth nachschlagen will, einmal 3D-Connection und dann Space Navigator und Fu und so. Und dann kannst du halt so richtig Hubschrauber-Flug-Style irgendwo lang fliegen und musst da nicht mit der Tastatur, mit der Maus da dich irgendwie einen abkrampfen und rumzuppeln. So. Und das macht das Ding halt auch and more. Und es ist total mega konfigurierbar.
Kann man damit eigentlich mehr machen, als nur Sounds steuern? Also gibt es irgendwie die schon...
Na du kannst halt alles damit steuern, was irgendwie über MIDI steuerbar ist. Es gibt Lampen, es gibt irgendwie Kunst, es gibt alles Mögliche, was du mit MIDI steuern kannst. Und vor allem es gibt auch zunehmende Maße Geräte, die du halt über OSC steuern kannst. Zum Beispiel kannst du dir OSC Software für dein iPhone oder dein iPad runterladen. Zum Beispiel Touch OSC, was leider bisher hier in Tests komischerweise nur mit dem iPad bisher, mit dem Oscillator sprechen wollte, aber eigentlich sollte das gehen. Ich hab noch keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt auch nicht so viel Zeit damit verbringen können. Touch OSC macht dir sozusagen eine beliebige, von dir konfigurierbare Oberfläche, wo du sozusagen diese ganzen Standard-Kontrolls wie Buttons, Fader und so weiter, Trigger, Schnickes, 2D-Touch-Teile, wo du einen Punkt auf so einem Feld anvisieren kannst, wo da so ein Fadenkreuz mitläuft, sowas. Und das wird halt alles in Open Sound-Control-Events umgewandelt und geht dann halt auch zu einem Oscillator und da kannst du dann halt genau bestimmen, was das tun soll. Das heißt, du kannst dir im Prinzip auch eine komplexe Steueroberfläche bauen für dein iPad oder iPhone halt und dann spricht das Ding eben über WLAN, OSC, mit dem Oscillator und alles wird gut.
Das wäre was schönes für das nächste Plinkenlight.
Kannst du damit Keynote steuern?
Damit kannst du auch Keynote steuern. Du kannst auch hier sagen, schicke dem Programm folgenden Key-Event.
Das heißt, wenn ich eine Taste drücke, wird einfach ein Ton einer gewissen Frequenz eingeblendet, wie alle vier haben eine verschiedene Frequenz, deswegen sind die Linien in deinen verschiedenen Löhnen, richtig?
Genau.
Ich hab dann sozusagen, also die A-Taste ist sozusagen immer derselbe MIDI-Kanal.
Und du machst die Spur nicht mit in den Stream, sonst würde man es nämlich hören.
Ich könnte da jetzt einen Synthesizer drauflegen, den müsste ich halt konfigurieren, dann könnte er ja auch Töne machen. Was jetzt so falsch auch nicht wäre, weil dann würde man das sozusagen auch sofort hören. Hab ich schon mal drüber nachgedacht, dann würde ich das aber so machen, dass wir das nur im Kopfhörer hören und dass es nicht auf den Stream geht und so. Aber das ist irgendwie alles Fummelei. Also es ist nicht unmöglich, aber jetzt erstmal bisschen rumtesten. Auf jeden Fall ist das generell einfach geil. Wer schon immer mal darüber nachgedacht hat, ein generisches Wireless-Tasten, Fernsteuer-Device für was auch immer auf deinem Computer läuft oder MIDI oder OSC-connectete Geräte, dann kann man das einfach nehmen. Die Software macht so jetzt erstmal einen guten Eindruck. Es hat irgendein Franzose geschrieben, Camille lalala und der will irgendwie zwischen 19 und 25 Euro haben oder 14. Also du kannst sozusagen selber wählen in einem Preisrahmen, was du haben willst und dann schickt er dir so einen License-Fallzug.
Also dieses Touch-OSC sieht so ein bisschen so aus, als ob es durchaus auch die Enterprise steuern könnte, oder?
Ja, es gibt ja hier auch einen Editor für den Mac, der ist dann sozusagen bei Tonnen oder so. Hier gibt es den Touch-OSC-Editor. Hier, gucke mal. So, dann hast du hier so einen Touch oder ein iPad. Und dann hast du ja einfach so einen Canvas und kannst sagen, hier will ich eine LED haben und hier will ich einen Push-Button haben und hier will ich irgendwie einen Fader haben. Und dann legst du die halt einfach irgendwo hin, kannst die resizen, wie du willst. Und dann hast du einfach die Oberfläche, speicherst das quasi als Template, überträgst es an deinen Touch-OSC auf dem iPad. Dann kriegt das Ding eine ID oder einen Namen und dann taucht das in dem Osculator auch auf. Also wenn du deinen, was weiß ich, Huckelpad nennst, dann ist das hier in dem Osculator, ist es dann irgendwie slash Huckelpad und dann slash was auch immer der Event. Das ist also so Pathnamen, die sozusagen von dem Gerät dann beschreiben, was du da hast. Du kannst dann jeden Event irgendwie invertieren, parametrisieren, minima, maxima setzen und so weiter. Also ist das irre. Ich bin begeistert.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn.
Das ist der Hammer.
Achso und dieses Download, also dieses iPhone-App ist auch von dem gleichen Typen.
Ja.
Ja, dieses Touch-OSC ist auch von dem gleichen Typi.
Ach wirklich? Ah, okay. Na gut, dann wundert es nicht, dass da...
Dass das so gut funktioniert.
Okay, aber dann wär's mal sehr angemessen, ihn zu fragen, warum die Kommunikation so schlecht läuft. Also die Autodescovery von dem Touch ist ein bisschen schlecht. Also man muss da halt irgendwas, die Portnummer eintragen. Ich weiß nicht, warum der nicht einfach Bonjour macht und dann die Devices automatisch findet. Das wäre sozusagen Raum für Verbesserungen.
Ja, aber das klingt auf jeden Fall nach was, was man mal haben will.
Ja, so geile Hacker-Scheiße ist das.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, weil man alles Mögliche dann mal an alles Mögliche heranstecken kann mit Klicken. Genau.
Und alles Mögliche, alles Mögliche heranstecken ist immer gut.
Max, du hast es auf den Punkt gebracht.
So, welche Taste müssen wir drücken, wenn wir das Thema wechseln?
Die B-Taste.
Ach, die da hinten.
Ja, aber du hast das falsch verstanden. Wir drücken die Taste, nachdem wir das Thema gewechselt haben.
Ja, ich warte ja schon, jetzt kommt ja ein neues Thema, oder?
Nächstes Mal kriegst du deinen Ton dazu. Okay. Naja, du findest es langweilig oder was?
Was willst du noch einsetzen?
Na, machen wir doch gerade.
Dann lass uns doch jetzt aufhören mit dem Podcast und lieber spielen.
Naja.
Später.
So, und habt ihr schon alle schön gepinkt?
Schlimm ist das.
Ist das lame oder was?
Das ist das Allerletzte.
Aber es hat nur zwei Tage gedauert, als mein Bild freigeschaltet war, mein Profilbild. Nur zwei Tage? Nee, so lange nicht.
Achso, ist das schön.
Man kriegt jetzt offiziell von Apple bestätigt, dass man kein Pimmelgesicht hat.
Du musst die Meter so drücken.
Also ich bin irgendwie überhaupt nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Das hat gar nichts.
Ich steig ja auch gerne auf irgendwas Neues ein und ich spiel auch gerne mal mit, aber der Fun-Faktor war einfach so schnell im Keller. Was soll das?
Er war nie vorhanden, oder?
Also das ist irgendwie, Apple und Internet ist leider, muss man sagen, immer noch so ne...
Ist ein bisschen Fail, oder?
Ja, ist ein bisschen Fail.
Sascha Lobe hat ja so schön getwittert, Ping ist das, nicht schonmal becken unter den Social Networks.
Ja, das stimmt, da ist was dran.
Ja, ne, also ich mein, es hat ja auch, es hat einfach wirklich null Features, die das irgendwie cool machen könnten. Also wenn du sagst, hier I like, ja, und dann kommt in deiner Timeline, dass du jetzt das und das gemocht hast, dann kommt dann irgendwie drunter dick und fett irgendwie, ja, und jetzt hier kaufen und...
Ja, und du kannst dann irgendwie mögen, dass jemand anderes was gemocht hat.
Ja, und du kannst nicht streamen, sondern du hast immer nur dieses Samples und...
Das kann man gar nicht beim Hören machen, sondern immer nur, wenn man seine Musik da irgendwie verwaltet.
Ja, und du kannst...
Doch, du kannst das auch beim Hören von etwas. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das auf dem iPhone integriert ist.
Also ich hab's mir ja nicht angeschaltet, weil...
Aber was das richtig peinlichste ist ja eigentlich auch, dass du, also zumindest hab ich jetzt beim Kollegen, das haben wir zusammen nicht rausgefunden, wenn du jetzt Musik hörst in deiner Playlist und dann Rating abgibst, ja, 5 Sterne oder so, um dann das auf dem Ping zu liken, musst du erstmal auf die Ping-Seite lad, lad, lad dich dann da irgendwie durchklicken und dann auf like sagen, äh klicken, also suchen oder was? Ja, also es ist halt nicht so, ich hör den Track gerade, I like, sondern muss dann erstmal ruckel, ruckel, store, lad, lad, such, lad, lad, also genau, wenn die Musik in Raitions läuft, will man noch direkt klicken können, Wir können like.
Mehr will man doch gar nicht machen.
Dann wird man möglichst viel gewertet.
Also es ist halt im iTunes drin, aber es ist halt irgendwie nicht so richtig integriert in den ganzen Kram. Du bist wie so eine eigene Welt trotzdem noch. Also irgendwie einfach uncool.
Axel gefällt die Vorbestellung.
Axel gefällt die Vorbestellung. Sagt mir Ping.
Wer ist Axel und wer ist die Vorbestellung?
Axel ist jemand auf Ping und ihm gefällt die Vorbestellung von einem Album.
Man kann Vorbestellungen liken?
Also ich verstehe auch echt nicht, warum die da so eine Probleme haben, mit dem Internet klarzukommen.
Das kriegen sie nicht so richtig auf die Reihe, oder? Dieses ganze...
Also auch, ich meine, Mobile Me, das wäre wahrscheinlich schon längst ein cooler Brüller gewesen, wenn sie das irgendwie gratis gemacht hätten und gesagt haben, hier jetzt kommt alle und wir fixen das irgendwie alles, was kommt.
Das werden sie nicht tun.
Ja, aber es ist halt... also wer bezahlt 99? Ich.
Ich hab's mir gekauft jetzt.
Und? Kaufst du es dir noch mal?
Ich sag dir auch warum.
Und es gibt noch einen zweiten Fanboy, der es gekauft hat.
Es gibt jetzt das erste Mal... Also es gab schon immer ein paar Features auf Mobile Me, die ich an sich ganz okay fand.
Stimmt.
Thema-Taste drücken.
Oh, das war Tims Kreuzer-Taste.
Andere auch noch drücken können. Wir haben noch hier so ein Steuerkreuz.
Ja, den Info-Rot-Sensor kannst du übrigens auch auslesen. Was war das Thema? Movami. Ich hatte das mal testweise, hab ich sogar mal gekauft. Das ist alles schon eine Weile her. Ich bin dann immer wieder abgesprungen, weil diese iDisk ist irgendwie lame. Also so wie sie funktioniert, ist sie lame. Wieder bietet sie jetzt besonders viel Platz. Also lächerliche 2 Gigabyte. Ich meine, hallo, geht's noch? Und dann ist das auch alles so. Ist das nicht so? Doch, das ist sowieso wenig. Du kannst dann natürlich noch mehr dazu kaufen. Aber ich meine, was ist das bitte für ein Einstieg? 2 Gigabyte. Aber was mich noch mehr stört, ist, dass es halt auch irgendwie nicht so... Das funktioniert nicht so, wie man will. Erst später haben sie ja dann dieses Local Syncing hinzugefügt, dass du dann quasi auch immer eine Kopie hast, so ein bisschen wie Dropbox, aber Dropbox funktioniert einfach mal tausendmal geiler. Und das ist auch ein generelles Problem, dass es eben sehr schwierig ist, Sharing-Benutzer übergreifend zu machen. Bei MobileMe.
So.
Dann allerdings, vor ein paar Monaten, haben sie diese Kalender-Beta vorgestellt. Und ich hab ja das Problem, dass ich mich gerne eben mit mehreren Leuten, insbesondere sozusagen Familie, einfach über Termine abstimmen will. Das ist ein echtes Familienproblem, was weiß ich so. Kindergarten, Abholzeiten, hier ein Termin, da ein Termin. Du musst dich permanent irgendwie über alles Mögliche abstimmen. Und da war das einfach die Pein. Und dann hab ich versucht, das mit diesen Google-Kalendern hinzubekommen. Und ich weiß, jetzt werden ganz viele irgendwie den Finger heben und sagen, ich benutze das, kein Problem. Ich hab das hinbekommen. Ich kenn auch Leute, die das... 20 GB?
Dropbox H2, sagen sie alle. Da wir ja noch Hörrahmen, die nicht live sind und überhaupt, weil wir Hörer haben, müssen wir das ja korrigieren.
Okay, 20 GB, aber du kannst das halt nicht so benutzen wie... Okay, dann... Okay, ich korrigiere mich. Ich bin auch zu müde. Was hab ich jetzt gerade gesagt? Ich bin total verpeilt. Ah ja, der Kalender, genau. Bei Google ist es ja so, wenn du diesen Google-Kalender benutzen willst, also du kannst das ja machen, kannst andere Leute einladen, dass sie dein Kalender schreiben können und so weiter. Das geht wunderbar so im Web und ist ja auch alles prima. Nur, wenn du dann eben versuchst, das auch in deine Mac-Infrastruktur so reinzukriegen, so iCal und so weiter, und dann auf dem iPhone, dann hast du erstmal so das Problem, dass es wirklich auf jedem, mit jedem Programm, mit jedem Gerät irgendwie anders geht. Also, Kaldav zum Beispiel benutzt du dann bei iCal und dann trägst du das irgendwie ein, aber dann hast du nicht für deinen Account alle deine Kalender, sondern hast du jeden einzelnen Kalender. Die Straße braucht auch nochmal eine A-Tasse.
Wir sind Street-Podcaster. Street-Predability. Wir machen das hier im Besetzten Haus, verstehst du?
Na ja, also ich hab's ernsthaft probiert. Ich hab's irgendwie mit Exchange probiert. Also alle Möglichkeiten, Shared-Kalender-Geschichten zu machen. Ich bin gescheitert. Das ist einfach nicht easy. Und ich weiß, jetzt gibt's wahrscheinlich tausend Links über die Tutorials, bitte posten. Aber dann kam irgendwie diese Kalender-Abenteuer raus bei Mobami, die genau dasselbe versprochen hat. Du kannst deinen Kalender mit jemand anderem sharen. Natürlich nicht mit irgendjemand anderem, sondern nur, wenn er auch ein Mobami-Account hat.
Kannst du dein iPhone schütteln, dann wird's mit irgendjemandem geshared.
Aber der Itch war jetzt einfach mal härter. Also zwei Accounts geschoppt und Family Packs. Und siehe da, jetzt geht das alles. Und jetzt geht das so richtig toll. Also es ist so richtig sexy. Ich muss irgendwie nichts einrichten, einmal irgendwo Mobami eintragen und es geht irgendwie überall. Auf dem iPhone, auf dem iPad, auf allen meinen Macs. Ist großartig. Und ich hab mich jetzt auch total an dieses Syncing gewöhnt. Das ist nämlich wirklich, Syncing macht süchtig.
Syncing, das sind die Kalender.
Aber es ist halt einfach, es funktioniert einfach gut.
Okay, naja, ist ja schonmal was für 99 Euro, Dollar.
Stimmt denn wenigstens die Kalenderfarben auf allen Geräten?
Aber da ist auch find my iPhone.
Gibt es es mittlerweile nicht von irgendeinem Drittanbieter? Also mittlerweile geht es doch.
Find my iPhone?
Wie soll denn das gehen?
Du machst ein App in App Store, das regelmäßig die Position hochfunkt und...
Na ja, das muss ja dann immer laufen.
Wie, was muss es laufen?
Na ja, es muss halt immer laufen, dieses Programm. Wieso?
Es gibt doch mittlerweile im Hintergrund.
Ja, aber es kann ja trotzdem sein, dass wenn du viele andere Apps startest, dass dieses Ding irgendwie gekillt wird. Also sicher ist es nicht. Außerdem hast du ja bei Pharma iPhone noch mehr Möglichkeiten. Du kannst ja dann das Ding auch piepen lassen, auch wenn der Soundbutton ausgeschaltet ist. Du kannst es remote löschen, du kannst es remote locken. Also wenn du weißt, oh, ich hab's bei Freunden liegen lassen, so nach dem Motto, es ist irgendwie nicht geklaut, es ist irgendwie halbwegs safe, aber wär jetzt trotzdem mal ganz gut, da mal die Pinze ändern, das Ding mal zu locken, dann kannst du es halt einfach machen. Und du kannst auch eine Piepen lassen und eine Nachricht anzeigen lassen. So nach dem Motto, hier ist mein Telefon, sicher das doch mal und so weiter.
Christen Euro.
Christen Euro. Genau. Also das finde ich schon ganz praktisch.
Schon mal benutzt?
Ja, um es in meiner Wohnung zu finden.
Hast du es klingeln lassen?
Wie lange war der Lag so, bis es dann geprägt ist?
Also Anrufen hat nicht geholfen, weil es halt auf Stumm geschaltet war. Aber mit Feinmal iPhone kannst du es halt trotzdem klingeln lassen.
Und wie lange war der Lag? Vom Klick bis zum Klingeln?
Ich weiß nicht mehr so genau.
Ein, zwei Minuten, ja. Dennis hat wieder seine Pitch-Niebe eingeschaltet. I-Pitch.
I-Pitch.
Smarter and smarter and smarter.
Ich hätte noch mehr Sounds drauf machen sollen. Aber es ist trotzdem schön.
Ich treffe immer nur die eine Taste, egal was ich mache.
Just amazing.
Übrigens, die Lautstärke-Taste, die ja hier immer so Klick, klick, klick macht, wenn man das Shift drückt, dann macht es nicht mehr Klick. Für alle, die es noch nicht kennen.
Du kannst es auch bei den Präferenzen ausschalten, dass es andersrum ist. Dann kannst du mit Shift klicken lassen.
Oh, echt krass.
Du kannst umdrehen.
Voll total un-Apple. Das ist ein Überfeature, das machen die doch nie.
Ist ja nicht viel spannender, welche Taste war es, die man drückt halten muss, damit man so halbe oder viertel Schritte machen kann?
Das gibt es auch irgendwie.
Man kann ja normalerweise nur so ein Kästchen immer voll machen und leer machen.
Mit Alt gehen die Präferenzen auf. Die Sound- oder Bildschirmpreferenzen, oder was auch immer du gerade drückst und ändern willst. Mit Alt kommen die entsprechenden Präferenzen hoch.
Du kannst auch bei iTunes und beim neuen Quicktime Player, wenn du Shift-Kursor hochmachst, dann kannst du auch noch über die Maximaleinstellung lauter machen.
Was ich echt mal gerne hätte bei den Rechnern mit Hintergrundbeleuchtung, dass die Hintergrundbeleuchtung in der Tastatur ausgeht, wenn man einen Film in Fullscreen abspielt. Ich find das mal total nervig. Sondern ich guck mir abends mal einen Film an und dann mach ich den auf Fullscreen. Dann leuchtet diese Tastatur-Hintergrundbeleuchtung da ewig vor sich hin.
Da musst du doch zwei Kalorien verbrennen, um diese Bewegungen auch vor uns zu machen.
Du kannst das mit so einem Detail auf das gute Apple-Ruhigball machen.
Ich kann es jetzt mit Osculator machen.
Shift-Alt-Lautstärke-Tasten, das macht diese zehntel-Schritte.
Für so super Couch-Potatoes kannst du ja alles mit deiner V-Mode steuern. Dann machst du dir eine Gestenerkennungssoftware dazwischen.
Ich hab mir einen Skript installiert auf dem iPad und auf dem iPhone, damit das XBMC, das Media Center, per Wake Online angeht, damit ich extra Überratchen brauche und die Taste drücken muss. Insofern wäre es für mich gar nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass ich das mache.
XBMC läuft auf was?
Wie heißt das?
Revo?
Wie heißt der? Acer, Aspire, Revo.
So.
Auf dem PC.
Mit Linux drauf.
Das kann man machen. Habe ich das nicht sogar schon mal erzählt?
Ist ja schon so lange her jetzt.
Kommt demnächst mal wieder neu.
Also abschließend zu Mobile Me, es ist teuer, aber...
Es gewinnt an Nutzen.
Also für mich lohnt sich das einfach. Also es spart einfach so viel Zeit und Stress über ein Jahr hinweg durch diese Kalender-Geschichte. Das macht es für mich halt einfach wertvoll. So, das muss nicht bei allen so sein.
Naja, vielleicht schaffen sie es ja in den nächsten Jahren noch, so ein paar Features draufzulegen.
Und was hast du damit, was du über Google nicht hast? Du kannst andere Leute Kalender bearbeiten.
Das funktioniert überhaupt erst mal. Na, das geht theoretisch halt bei Google auch, weil du kannst ja auf ein Google-Kalender-Account auch das sozusagen, du kannst ja auf deinem iPhone so ein Exchange-Account einrichten.
Das hab ich.
So.
Bin ich auch sehr glücklich mit.
Und das hat, wenn wir überlegen, glaub ich, hab ich nicht hinbekommen auf dem iPhone, dass es funktioniert hat. Also diese Kalender tauchten einfach nicht auf.
Ach so, dann hast du wahrscheinlich nie freigeschaltet.
Was hab ich nicht freigeschaltet?
Man muss, es gibt eine Seite, die muss dann, also nachdem du diesen Exchange-Account eingerichtet hast, bei Google musste auf m.google.com 6.5 oder so was gehen und da muss man die dann einschalten, die man haben möchte.
Genau, das war nämlich das Elend. Das war eine Kaskade von Wahnsinn. Also was da auf mich zu kam, diese Seite, die kam dann hoch, die loot sich dann irgendwie immer wieder selbst und dann hab ich auf irgendwelche Button drauf geklickt und dann looten sie sich wieder selbst und ich bin in so einer Endlosschleife gefahren gewesen.
Also was da ganz furchtbar ist, also wenn man auf der richtigen Seite ist, dann steht da erstmal, ich hab das bei mir im Blog vor ein paar Tagen beschrieben, dann steht da erstmal, dieses Angebot ist in ihrem Land nicht verfügbar oder irgendwie sowas und dann muss man, man kann so einen Link Sprache wechseln und dann muss man auf Englisch stellen und danach kann man die Einstellungen machen. Das ist total bescheuert, aber...
Ich finde ja, solche Dienste sollten, man sollte sozusagen bei Google in seinem Account so gleich seine Flatter-ID hinterlegen können und immer wenn man von so einem Feature so genervt ist, dann muss Google einen flattern. Also funktioniert nicht irgendwie...
Statt Hart 4 oder was?
Ja, einfach gleich so, I want my money back.
I want my identity back.
Dafür hatte ich auch gerade fünf Minuten lang deine Werbung irgendwie so in meinem rechten Augenwinkel kurz gesehen.
Wenn man keinen Flashblock hat.
Ja, so Textads und so weiter. Also das Google, das liegt ja überall rum. Naja, und dann hab ich halt irgendwie mit dem Exchange und dann weiß ich nicht mehr so ganz genau und dann, mir gefiel das halt auch nicht wie das bei iCal aussieht, dass sozusagen für jeden einzelnen Kalender meines Accounts muss ich dann in iCal einen Account einrichten, weil sie nicht in der Lage sind, für diesen einen Account einfach alle Kalenders zu machen. Ich meine, Apple macht das jetzt mit Mobile Me auch über CalDAF. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob sie da noch irgendwie die magische, aber wir sind ja, wir sind's ja, Passe drücken irgendwie übers Netz, weißt du so, dass es dann auf einmal funktioniert und Google hat irgendwie noch nicht den richtigen Wert gefunden, den sie da rüber schicken müssen. Aber für mich sieht das halt eher ein bisschen nach so einem Fail aus. Und so, das war einfach nicht benutzbar.
Also für dieses Google-Kalenderzeug nutze ich im Augenblick noch BusySync heißt das. Ja, probiert. Das funktioniert ganz gut eigentlich. Und ich glaube mittlerweile müsst ihr auch die Exchange unterstellt gehen, oder?
BusySync kann nur einen Account. Also ich kann mit BusySync nur einen einzigen Google-Account machen. Ich hätte für mein Setup sozusagen mehrere gebraucht.
Acht bis neun Accounts.
Naja, zumindest zwei oder drei. Ja, für andere Organisationen. Und BusySync ist an sich ganz cool. Und wer wirklich nur einen Account hat und wer sozusagen Syncing auf File-Basis haben will, also man muss ja auch diese Konzepte ein bisschen auseinanderhalten, BusySync nimmt deinen lokalen, auf deinem Computer gespeicherten Kalender und synkt den mit dem Google-Kalender, den du angibst. Das heißt, das funktioniert mit einem Computer. Hast du einen zweiten Computer, ist das nicht automatisch gesynkt. Es sei denn, du hast ja auch BusySync. Ach so, ja, ja. Ja, keine Ahnung, wie die es mit Multiplatten und Multiinstallationen halten, so. Aber dann weiß ich auch schon wieder nicht, ob das so gut funktionieren würde. Während CalDAV-basierte Dienste benutzen halt das Protokoll, was man dafür eben meiner Meinung nach nehmen sollte, nämlich einfach über WebDAV-Calendar-Management, um eben auf einem Server einen Kalenderserver anzusprechen, der halt weiß, dass er ein Server ist und nicht irgendwie so einen Austausch von Fragmenten von E-Kalender-Files betreibt.
So.
Was guckst du, bin ich Server oder was?
Ich dachte, das wäre deine, deine, deine Themawechseltasse, wie das...
Ja, so, das waren meine Erfahrungen. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr, ihr benutzt so Kalender nicht.
Ich setze das aus mit den Kalendern.
Ihr müsst euch mit niemanden synchronisieren.
Naja, doch, also ich hab schon den insgeheimen Wunschkalender zu benutzen, auch so gesyncht und so, aber bisher waren mir da auch alle möglichen...
Meinst du, du benutzt iCal auch gar nicht?
Selten. Also wenig, aber ich benutze es gelegentlich. Aber dann benutze ich es halt so, dass ich mir dann ein Event eintrage und dann einen Tag und zwei Tage vorher jeweils zwei Alarme mir mache, mit Message, also wenn es wirklich wichtig ist, damit ich halt diesen iCal auch nicht die ganze Zeit offen haben muss. Und ja, es klingt ja nicht einfach so, ne? Das ist halt auch doof.
Ja, aber das geht mit Google tatsächlich großartig.
Ich dachte, das soll jetzt kommen, dass ein paar Sachen hier Overseer oder per WLAN sinken, ohne dass man das Telefon immer extra mit Kabel anschließen muss. War das nicht mit 41 oder soll es mit 42 kommen?
Keine Ahnung, also ich wüsste von gar nichts.
Nein, nein, davon ist nicht die Rede.
Also ich glaube, die Notizen wollen jetzt auch was. Die wollen ja nur bei mir irgendwie verkloppen, das ist immer schade.
Naja, sie hatten ja dieses Sinking-Rover, WLAN gibt es ja. Das ist ja das, was Apple TV gemacht hat. Also Apple TV hat sich ja, also das alte, nicht jetzt das, was kommt, hat sich ja gegenüber einem Mac oder PC im Prinzip wie ein iPod verhalten. Das heißt, er hat sich gesehen über Bonjour, tauchte da auf und du konntest halt Sachen draufsinken, so wie du es auf dem iPod auch gemacht hast. Und es gab ja auch neulich diesen, diese App, die jemand angekündigt hat, wo er meinte, er hätte das herausgefunden, wie man das aktiviert. Kam natürlich im App Store nicht durch. Surprise, surprise. Aber das Video, was ich seinerzeit gesehen habe, das sah extrem nicht nach Fake aus. Also es machte den Eindruck, als hätte er quasi die in iOS vorhandene Funktionalität aktiviert. Vielleicht hat er sie auch nur so gut nachgebildet, aber er muss ja irgendwie Zugriff zu den internen Sync-Mechanismen irgendwie haben. Also ich hab, und ich kann es mir nicht anders vorstellen.
Was ich mir für per Jailbreak geholt habe, ist so ein Wi-Fi-Sync, weil ich das eigentlich fand, dass das ganz gut klang. Also man muss auf dem Mac ein Programm installieren und dann muss man hier noch auf dem entsprechenden Gerät so ein Programm installieren und sobald man das Programm startet, fängt er an zu synchronisieren über Wi-Fi. Das funktioniert auch so weit leiblich. Also ich glaube, das iPad hab ich hingekriegt. Mit dem iPhone hab ich es nie geschafft, dass er sich damit gesynkt hat. Und es ist sagenhaft langsam. Also es macht echt keinen Spaß. Es ist wirklich viel schneller mal eben rasch das Kabel rausgeholt, als es dauert wirklich keine Ahnung, eine halbe Stunde, was sonst drei Minuten dauert oder sowas. Also unerträglich lange.
Ja, Syncging ist ein echtes Dilemma. Ich benutze ja zum Beispiel auch Sinks, beziehungsweise ich möchte gerne Sinks benutzen und hab das mal eine Weile intensiv benutzt. Aber jetzt fädelt es auch schon wieder aus, weil ich einfach permanent die Rechner wechsle. Also ich hab, es war bei mir jetzt auch noch nicht so, aber kein Witz, ich wechsle am Tag bestimmt fünf, sechs, sieben Mal die Rechner. Und natürlich auch das iPhone. Ne, aber ich hab halt hier gegenüber auf der anderen Seite der Straße und irgendwie der eine Laptop und der andere Laptop und das iPhone und das iPad. Und mit Mobile Me, also alles, was Mobile Me unterstützt, alle Dienste, die darauf gehen und alles, was auf Dropbox setzt, das ist halt überall immer aktuell und gleich. Also One Password, ich hab einfach überall, zu allen Webseiten, auf allen Rechnern immer den Zugang.
Seitdem One Password hatte am Anfang ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Dropbox, zumindest wenn man die Sprache auf Deutsch eingestellt hatte.
Da war irgendwie so ein Bug, ja.
Genau, aber das haben sie mittlerweile gelöst. Das ist großartig.
Die da fixen die Jungs.
Das ist so toll, dass sie das nicht mehr aktualisieren müssen und es funktioniert unter Windows und es funktioniert auf dem Mac und es funktioniert überall.
Ach du benutzt das jetzt auch auf Windows, ne?
Ich benutze das auch auf Windows, genau. Und da leider bisher nur für Firefox und Internet Explorer. Internet Explorer nutze ich nie, aber ich hätte es gerne noch für Chrome, auch unter Windows. Auf dem Mac kam es ja in eine Chrome-Erweiterung und dann scheint es ja problemlos zu gehen. Aber das wird von Tag zu Tag besser, das ist echt toll.
Ich habe jetzt auch One Password. Hab es noch nicht so ganz gepilet, aber funktioniert erstmal, wenn man sich irgendwo einloggt, dass der gleich merkt, wenn du das nächste Mal eingibst, dann füllt er aus und drückt er auch anscheinend gleich Return, dass man nichts mehr machen muss. Blöd ist natürlich, wenn man schon ganz viele 100 Milliarden Logins hat, die alle natürlich viel zu einfach waren, müsste man jetzt ja alle erstmal da die Passworte ändern und ich denke mal, das ist eine Menge Fummelarbeit, der kann einem das ja nicht automatisieren, weil die Password-Änderfunktion kann ja irgendwie alle nicht kennen und so.
Doch, das macht er auch, wenn du irgendwo bei manchen Websites funktionierst, wenn du dein Passwort änderst, dann merkt er auch, wenn du das schon im One Password schon drin hast, dann fragt er dich, ob du es da auch ändern möchtest. In dem Moment, wo du es änderst. Und nicht erst, wo du dich einloggst, aber dann natürlich auch.
Da kommt dann das One Password auf, um wie ein Password generiert, dass ich mich überhaupt gar nichts um nichts kümmern muss, der das da ausfüllt und übernimmt. Also ich find's schon ganz cool eigentlich.
Das ist ja auch so ein Programm, ich setz ja gerne so hippe Sachen aus, wie Beatle zeigt zum Beispiel, er ist glaube ich mit 18 oder 19 das erste Mal gehört.
Oh Gott, und dann hast du die ganze Zeit O-R-Sys gehört.
Ja und andere Sachen. Aber One Password lese ich auch schon so lange, und ich bin ja so ein exzessiver Keychain-Benutzer.
Benutzte meinste?
Ja, ich seh das hier so in der Wolke immer alle, One Password, One Password, One Password. Und ich bin ja mit Keychain eigentlich ganz zufrieden, aber ich hab ja nur einen Rechner. Ist das so gut?
Das Problem ist, ich muss mich bei Apple anmelden, ich muss mich in welchen Foren anmelden, ich muss mich auf...
Überall muss man sie anmelden.
Im RD, du weißt, also so tausend Sachen anmelden und natürlich bin ich eine faule Sau. Passworte sind immer so ein El-Chipo-Dinger, weil ich denke mir, naja, ist ja nicht so schlimm. Aber, weißt du, so richtig wohlfühlen tut man sich ja doch nicht und mein Password nimmt einen diesen Stress irgendwie ab. Der generiert irgendwie wohl ein Password für neue Sachen, kloppt dir da rein, merkst es dir beim nächsten Mal, sagst du dir den One Password hier, füll mal für mich aus und lockt dich mal intakt fertig. Du musst dir die Passworte nicht mehr merken und die können trotzdem ultra kompliziert sein. Also du hast einfach ein höheres Sicherheitsfeature. Weil, mal ganz ehrlich, wie viele verschiedene Passworte hast du?
Du hast so die ganzen, so für die ganzen, für die ganzen kleinen Scheißeiten.
Pass auf, da gibt's halt so, da gibt's halt so einen Trick, den ich mal irgendwo gehört hab. Ich weiß nicht, ob sogar in einem Podcast oder so. Bei Mobamex vielleicht? Nee, ich glaub beim Chaos Radio Express sogar. Und es war halt so, das, oder, ne, ich weiß nicht mehr, wo ich's gelesen hab, aber es war halt so, irgendwie wie man sich so ein Schema macht, wo die Passworte halt immer so...
Ein bisschen von der Seite abhängig sind.
Von der Seite abhängig sind und so. Du hast halt irgendwie so...
Anfangsbuchstaben.
Und so Geschichten, genau. Und ich hab mir halt so ein Passwort-Schema gemacht und... oder erdacht. Und das benutze ich halt überall. Und deswegen hab ich überall so Passwörter, die so 12 oder 14 Zeichen lang sind.
Es gibt ja auch Passwörter, die muss man sich merken. Also einfach so. Also ich generiere mir zwar auch welche, aber ich generiere mir auch nur so bestimmte Arten von Passwörtern, die ich mir noch so im Notfall merken kann. Also die schon so lang genug sind, dass sie generell als sicher, je nachdem, was da gerade das bewertet, angesehen werden. Und die ich mir aber merken kann. Also was weiß ich so, mein Google-Account, mein Primera, mein äh, was, 3, 4, 5 habe ich mir irgendwie gemerkt. Den Dropbox muss ich mir noch merken. Weil man die halt immer irgendwo auch als erste eingibt, bevor man überhaupt an irgendwas nennt, wo das rankommt, wo man ohne Rechner ist.
Aber wie ist das eigentlich bei One Password? Wenn ich jetzt mir für so ein Forum irgendwie ein Password mache mit One Password, was ich auf meinem Rechner benutze, und dann will ich aber auf meinem Telefon mal mit Safari in dieses Forum gehen, müsste ich mir dieses komplizierte Passwort erstmal rauspupeln.
Ja, One Password gibt es auch fürs iPhone.
Und der öffnet dann die Seite aber mit einem eigenen Webview, oder wie?
Genau.
Das heißt, ich muss dann alles über One Password surfen.
Also diese Sachen zumindest. Das hab ich auch noch im Dunkeln. Also manchmal hab ich den Eindruck, dass dann sozusagen, wisst ihr das, ob die Cookies global sind? Auf dem iPhone?
Also ich hab mal die Erfahrung gemacht, da hatte ich so eine Trailbrake App, was mir dieses Log-Screen ersetzte durch ein Webview. Und in dem Webview konnte ich auf die Cookies zugreifen, die auch der Safari hatte. Was ich sehr lustig fand. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das eine generelle Sache ist, oder ob das nur in dem Fall so war.
Na wenn es überhaupt einmal der Fall war, dann muss es ja generell gehen.
Ja, weil die mal das Cookies global sind.
So hab ich das bisher verstanden. Wenn du aus One Password heraus im Webview dann sozusagen den Login machst, dass dann quasi der Cookie gesetzt wird, sodass du danach einen Safari wechseln kannst und dann bist du eingeloggt.
Das stimmt, man muss das nur einmal machen und dann ist es chugger drin.
Hat aber auch häufig schon nicht funktioniert und ich hab noch nie so richtig die Zeit gehabt, das jetzt mal so wirklich...
Und das geht ja auch nicht überall.
Hier sagt der nächste Cookie sind nicht global.
Also wie ich das immer mache, es gibt so ein Bookmarklet für One Password, mit dem man sagen kann, schlag diese Seite mal jetzt in One Password nach. Also dann drückst du den Safari auf das Bookmark-Alk, sagst schlag mal in One Password nach, dann startet da One Password, zeigt dir das Password, also zeigt dir das den entsprechenden Login an und dann brauch ich nur noch sagen Copy.
Genau.
Und geh wieder zurück und dann hab ich's pastig's dann rein. Das ist nicht die superschönste Neuheit.
Das ist nicht bequem, aber es geht.
One Password fürs iPhone ist natürlich, aber selbst wenn man das One Password jetzt hier auf dem Rechner gekauft hat, muss man die iPhone Version auch nochmal shoppen.
Es gibt eine freie Version und es gibt eine Pro-Version.
Aber für die Pro-Version, Dropbox Sync ist nur mit der Pro-Version, oder?
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Ich hab mir gleich die Pro-Version geholt, weil die Fahrt...
Achso, man muss ja die Pro-Version annehmen, weil ich muss ja die Daten von meinem Rechner auch aufs iPhone drüber kriegen, sonst geht's ja eh nicht, richtig?
Naja, sie haben jetzt Dropbox Sync eingeführt. Sie hatten schon immer den Wireless Sync, aber da hast du immer wieder das Problem, du musst halt auf dem Rechner und auf deinem iPhone und im selben Netz sein. Und das nervt halt. Du willst halt irgendwie Cloud haben. Jetzt gehen halt die Ups verschiedene Wege. Entweder hast du für die App einen eigenen Cloud-Dienst. SYNC arbeitet meines Wissens an sowas. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht wär's sinnvoller, das einfach über Dropbox zu machen. Das würde mir sehr entgegenkommen. Es gibt allerdings auch keinen anderen To-Do-Dienst, den ich kenne, der Cloud Syncing hat. Außer halt jetzt MobileMe. MobileMe, To-Do, das ist jetzt nicht der Level von To-Do-Management, den ich haben möchte, also im Kalender und so weiter. Nur so, du musst das tun, ja, nein. Und das hält mich halt derzeit davon ab, SYNCs zu benutzen, weil ich halt immer vergesse, wo ich jetzt sozusagen mein To-Do eingetragen hab. Und ich müsste ja, wenn ich auf dem iPhone eins eintrage, dann müsste ich daran denken, das da zu starten, mit meinem Rechner zu syncen, damit ich dann auf dem Rechner auch den aktuellen Stand habe. Permanent tauchen irgendwelche To-Do-Items auf, die hier schon To-Dos sind, da nicht, oder die hier überhaupt erst mal eingetragen sind. Da wird es einfach total nutzlos. Also ohne Cloud Syncing sind solche Dienste eigentlich Quatsch. Und jetzt gibt es den interessanten Trend, dass immer mehr Apps Dropbox sich als Backend nehmen.
Ich glaube, die haben auch eine gute API für das iPhone und so. Ich glaube, die machen das schon einfach.
Also One Password, Good Reader. Dann gibt es dieses Elements, das so ein reiner Texteditor ist. Du hast mir vorhin noch eins gezeigt.
Genau, Nebulous.
Die legen dann halt einfach Files ab. Und dann gibt es noch irgendeinen, oder war das Good, ne, das ist noch so ein anderer, der auch so Wordfiles editieren kann, etc. Wie hieß denn das Teil nochmal gleich? Ja, kann sein.
Aber Office HD fand ich leider...
Office? Ich weiß es nicht.
Gibt auf jeden Fall da...
Ich benutze keine Docs.
Ich wollte auch das gerade sagen.
Ich wollte es wie Google Docs haben.
Wenn man auf einmal, wenn du dir anschaust, wie Apple das jetzt hier mit Numbers und so weiter macht, wieder mit durch iTunes durch, mit diesen komischen Gefricke, das benutzt man einfach nicht. Das ist einfach mal totaler Quatsch.
Ich mache das ja mittlerweile für, wenn ich so ein PDF-Dokument habe, das ist total praktisch. Und zwar, wenn ich hier, also man kann, auf dem iPad kann man wirklich hervorragend PDF-Dokumente lesen. Wie kommt man, wie kriegt man aber diese PDF-Dokumente fertig? Man wählt drucken aus in einem Browser seiner Wahl auf der entsprechenden Seite.
Ich meinte, das ist auf Mac.
Auf Mac? Naja, unter Windows kann man sich halt so einen PDF-Drucker besorgen. Sagt, als PDF-Speichern speichert das auf die Dropbox. Und dann kann man in Dropbox die Datei aufmachen und sagt, mach jetzt mal das PDF mit iBooks auf.
Du meinst, wenn du im Browser einen PDF hast?
Naja, oder du hast halt eine Webseite.
Dann brauchst du doch nicht drucken, du musst einfach sagen, speichern.
Nee, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich irgendeine Seite habe oder wenn ich ein Dokument habe, was ich jetzt dringend irgendwie lesen muss auf dem Rechner, auf dem iPad oder lesen will.
Achso, was noch kein PDF ist?
Was noch kein PDF ist. Einfach als PDF drucken, auf Dropbox speichern, mit Dropbox auf dem iPad aufmachen und dann den iBooks öffnen und dann hat man es drauf, ohne dass man da irgendwie mit USB-Kabeln rumhandtieren muss. Das ist wesentlich angenehmer. Dropbox ist großartig. So war der Satz.
Ja, das funktioniert einfach. Das ist das, was man immer so gerne sagen möchte über alles so. Es funktioniert einfach. Vor allem ist es so sagenhaft schnell.
Hacker, die sich Dropbox mal so angeguckt haben, die sagen aber, dass die Authentifizierung verschlüsselt ist, aber leider die Daten nicht. Das wäre nochmal ganz schick, wenn das auch so wäre. Ach je.
Na ja. Ja, da gibt es auch bei One-Password-Bedenken, weil die auch nicht alles verschlüsseln, sondern nur deine Passwörter. Aber die Informationen, wo du dich da einloggst, die ist gut verschlüsselt.
Das heißt, meine ganzen Porn-Forums würden in einem Cleartext stehen, das ist aber nicht gut.
Ja, das ist sehr schlecht. Es gibt jetzt, also in dem Zuge möchte ich hier auch gleich nochmal erwähnen, dieses Sparkle-Share, wo ich kürzlich drüber gestolpert bin. Ach so, die 1 war UL.
Genau, das drücke ich jetzt gerade.
Ach, die jetzt auch noch.
Das ist halt, ich soll sagen, die wollen Dropbox mit Git und so weiter, mit Git-Backend machen, das heißt, man hatte auch so ein schickes Widget halt.
Und Open Source oder was?
Und Open Source. Und du kannst dir aber aussuchen, wo das hinkommt. Also du kannst das bei GitHub hosten oder sonst wo oder auf deinem eigenen Server. Und dann hast du halt auch so ein kleines Widget. Die haben jetzt irgendwie ihre Seite gerade neu gemacht. Da sehe ich gerade, das ist irgendwie weniger zu sehen als vorher. Es gibt halt erstmal nur einen Linux-Client gerade, aber sie arbeiten schon an Mac OS und Windows-Clients. Also das sollte man mal so auf dem Radar haben, weil prinzipiell klingt das halt auch extrem schick so.
Linux First.
Ja, es sind halt...
Kann auch dann bestimmt wieder nicht, was auch Dropbox OS auch nicht kann. Das ist nämlich...
Aber guck mal, hast du auf die Seite da die Screenshots? Also für Linux da haben sie es schon ganz schick hinbekommen, muss man mal sagen.
Das ist ja echt ganz okay.
Mir fehlt nur eine Limitierung von Dropbox, eine über die ich neulich gestolpert bin, weil ich wollte mal eine iTunes-Library sharen. Ich wollte hier so am Rechner so eine Library auf Dropbox, da kannst du ja bei iTunes starten mit Alt gedrückt, dann fragt er dich ja nach anderer Library, dann wähle ich halt das aus. Das ist nicht komfortabel, aber es geht. Dann Fotos rein und dann wollte ich auf dem anderen Rechner einfach so rüberziehen und fertig. Ja, denkste. Also mit den Fotos an sich hat das funktioniert. Das Problem ist aber, dass unser Geiles, auch iTunes 10 im Übrigen... Nichts, weil es gibt ja diese Datei, die heißt... Die heißt iTunes Library. Das ist sozusagen die wichtige Datei. Und was einen schon skeptisch machen sollte, ist, dass diese Datei keine Endung hat. Punkt irgendwas. Es ist einfach nur iTunes Library. Und es ist natürlich eine gute, alte Mac OS Resource Fork-Datei, wie Donnemals bei Tralala. Und da Dropbox halt derzeit noch keinerlei Resource Forks oder Extended Attributes überhaupt unterstützt. Das wird also alles nicht gesyncht. Es kommt halt zwar ein File iTunes Library an, aber das ist halt irgendwie 0 bytes groß und ihr könnt euch schon etwa vorstellen.
Die müssen mal echt ihren Legacy mülllos werden.
So, das ist nur gerade meine Bedenken. Gut, ich meine, auch bei Linux-Filesystemen gibt es halt Metadata und das gehört halt eigentlich zum guten Tun, dass man das unterstützt. Aber das muss eben dann auch gut cross-Plattform unterstützt werden. Und da wird es halt knifflig.
Also, ich meine, die sind halt auch echt noch früh dran. Ich sehe das nur bei dem Kollegen, der das jetzt so ganz early adoptermäßig die Beta benutzt und das eigentlich ganz cool daherkommt. Nur leider gibt es eben noch keinen OSX-Client von daher.
Und soll das im Prinzip genauso funktionieren wie Dropbox? Also ist das sozusagen dasselbe Modell?
So im Prinzip schon. Und es ist halt in dem Fall auch noch versioniert natürlich. Das heißt, du hast dann auch noch sozusagen Revisions deiner Dropbox.
Was aber schon heißt, dass es eventuell reichlich mehr Storage benötigt und für die dann als Service, weil die wollen es ja, also irgendwer will es ja anbieten, dann mehr Platz braucht.
Du kannst es ja auch selber hosten. Also man muss halt mal sehen, ob das wirklich der der Weisheit letzter Schluss ist. Aber ich finde halt so die Entwicklung, weißt du, da gibt es ja das Dropbox, das ist cool. Hey, aber im Moment, wir haben ja auch noch Technologie, um das mal schnell irgendwie in Open Source und trotzdem distributed und nicht wieder mit Single Point of Failure und Wissen schon zu bauen.
Also es ist genauso der Unterschied zwischen AOL Instant Messaging und dann Java. Weil Java war ja dann auch so ein bisschen das Ähnliche, aber verteilt auf viele Systeme, so dass jeder sein eigenes Server machen kann. Und das System aber trotzdem miteinander klarkommt und sowas machen die auch. Ist doch immer gut.
Wir haben einen Flatter-Button. Soll ich den mal klicken?
Ich hab das schon mal drauf geklickt. Vielleicht geht's dann schneller. Ja, genau. Macht mal, Jungs.
Klick.
Gerade ist er noch bei 122, hoffentlich schon bei 123.
Ja, ich hör die 123.
Und jetzt hier Hörer, machen die nicht mit?
Doch, bestimmt auch.
Im Chat hat gerade einer geschrieben, wo denn die Open Source Variante von Dropbox bleibt. Da ist sie.
Wir hören uns doch versetzt, du musst da ein paar Sekunden warten.
Keine Ahnung, ob es was taugt. Vielleicht ist es ja auch das Diaspora unter dem Sync-System. Wobei, das ist ja jetzt rausgekommen.
Vorsichtig, mit leisen Schritten.
Hat sich das mal jemand angeguckt?
Nein. Also bestimmt hat sich das irgendjemand angeschaut, aber ich hab's mir nicht angeschaut.
100.000 Dollar? Und dann nach drei Monaten, oder wie lang haben sie jetzt gebraucht?
200.000 Dollar haben sie gesammelt und naja, die haben sich dann als Zeug gelegt und jetzt ist wohl auch irgendwas fertig und die ersten Leute haben das installiert und jetzt kamen sie auf Twitter, ja, jetzt hab ich meinen Diaspora-Server, aber ich bin hier so allein. Wie verbinde ich mich denn mit anderen? Also gut, ich meine, das sind jetzt so die Adopter-Probleme. Mal schauen, ich meine, ein Social-Network voll mit Nerds. Kann man sich was Schöneres vorstellen?
Hat was von Identica, oder?
Ja, das gibt's noch, klar.
Das ist auch sehr nerd, sehr nördlich, ja.
Aber da wird dann nur bis nicht über Tatort und über Britney Spears diskutiert.
Ach, wer hätte das gedacht?
In meiner Timeline wird nicht über Tatort und Britney Spears telefoniert.
Also früher war ich noch auf Identica, wenn Twitter mal wieder dauernd war, aber selbst das Problem hat sich ja erledigt.
Fast, ja.
Das sieht echt schick aus hier, dieses Sparkle-Share.
Wie gesagt, für so Linux-Open Source-Leute ist das also ein echt guter Webzeitwurf für einen Anfang.
Ich glaub, ich probier das mal nachher zu Hause aus. Ah, mein VNC-Klein geht ja gerade nicht.
Mist.
Zum Thema Syncing lässt sich eigentlich eine Menge sagen.
Ja, ich bin ja hier gerade auch voll, also Time Machine betrachte ich ja auch so. Also das ist ja auch so ein bisschen...
Syncing.
Zum langsamen Festkasten.
Ich glaube, ich drücke mal die Übernehmungstaste.
Wir brauchen noch eine Fail-Taste.
Habt ihr festgestellt, also ich hab letztens festgestellt, das ging früher nicht, wenn du File Vault benutzt, da war es ja früher so, wenn du irgendwie Restored hast, dann hat er irgendwie das File Vault-Image nicht automatisch dir gleich hingepackt, oder Dennis? Du hast ein System Backup und du benutzt File Vault.
Hab ich gemacht. Also ich hab mir eine neue Platte gekauft, hab die eingebaut.
Wovon redet ihr?
Also, ich hatte den Eindruck, aus ganz frühen Time Machine-Erfahrungen, also wenn du File Vault benutzt, und du machst ein Backup, dann macht er das ja nicht so mit, sondern...
Also Verschlüsselung deines Home Directorys für die Leute, die noch nicht wissen, was File Vault ist.
Genau, ich verschlüssel mein Home Directorys. Wenn du jetzt ein Time Machine Backup machst, dann nimmt er das Home Directory nicht mit ins Backup auf, sondern du musst dich erst ausloggen, dann macht er nämlich schön das Image zu, und dann macht er das sozusagen danach noch mal hinten mit rein. Und ich hatte irgendwie so die...
Was man natürlich nie macht, und deswegen hat man nie ein Backup.
Selten, selten.
Ist schon ein bisschen fies, ja.
Aber ich mach's schon.
Also es hätte mir nie geholfen in den Fällen, wo es mir bisher geholfen hat.
Immer wenn ich Backup mache, mache ich dann noch das. Aber ich mach nicht so...
Ja, aber dann muss man wieder explizit Backup machen, so. Ich meine, wenn man eine Festplatte benutzt, die man eh ranstecken muss, dann ist es vielleicht okay. Aber ich mach ja Time-Capsule und...
Genau, mach halt aber trotzdem auch nichts.
Okay, aber was ist jetzt anders?
Genau, ich hatte halt den Eindruck, dass wenn du dann restores, dass du dann halt auch irgendwie dieses Krypto-Image da wieder von Hand hinpulen musst. Das ging schon immer?
Ich hab nicht restores, also doch, ich hab ne neue Platte gekauft, hab die eingebaut, hab installiert. Und dann hat er gefragt, naja, hier hast du denn deine alten Daten, damit sich das gleich alles rausspinken kann. Ich hab's überlegt, ja doch, die Platte, die alte liegt ja hier, wieder angeschlossen, per Fireware dran. Hab gesagt, hier nimm mal alles und drüb drüb, hat er gemacht. Und ein Passo drüb drüb, ja, hat so ein bisschen gedauert und dann war er fertig.
Also ich muss auch sagen, also das war, ich hab mir auch ne neue Platte gekauft, und dann hatte ich irgendwie ein Backup gemacht von meiner alten 320 Gigabyte mit Time Machine, alles schön weg und so. Und dann hab ich Restored und es ging einfach, es war total toll. Und dann dachte ich, mann, dieses Time Machine, das taugt ja doch ein bisschen was. Und vor allen Dingen die Erkenntnis dabei war, Firewire 800 ist toll, mit USB, irgendwie Estimated Time of Delivery, irgendwie drei Tage und vier Stunden, Firewire...
Das war echt...
Also nicht nur war ich begeistert von der Time Machine-Performance, die funktioniert hat. Manchmal rödelte sich ja auch einer ab, aber in dem Fall einfach alles super.
Die haben dabei Snowlapp, hat wirklich am Time Machine gemacht und getan. Und alles, die gesamte OS-Fahrt, die APDs haben, also alle Calls, die von Time Machine benutzt werden, haben sie sich angeguckt und schneller gemacht.
Und dann eben diese Firewire 800 Experience. Ich hab ja nicht viel Gelegenheit, so richtig mal Firewire 800 irgendwie wertschätzen zu können. Aber bei so einer Sache, wenn du 320 Gigabyte mal eben von A nach B pusten musst. Und dann Toolnummer, hier machen wir gleich mal die B-Taste. Ich hab ja auch bei dieser Gelegenheit mal wieder Carbon Copycloner benutzt.
Da hat wer die falsche gedrückt.
Carbon Copycloner habe ich ja mal wieder benutzt auch.
Hab ich letztens auch benutzt, war nicht so toll.
Doch bei mir ist voll gering. Wieso nicht? Aber es benutzt jetzt eher Sync, ne?
Carbon Copycloner hat mich noch nie hängen lassen.
Ja, mich auch noch nicht.
Nee, das ist cool, das Tool.
Das gibt's halt auch schon immer, ne? Also Carbon Copycloner.
Ja, ist ganz schön alt.
Aber irgendwie, ich hab's mir runtergeladen und hab mir dann noch so eine andere Partition und eine andere Platte mit auf die neue gesynced und es ging auch fluff fluff und hurra.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr wo, irgendwer hat es letztens benutzt mit. Ich hab's glaube ich sogar selber vorgeschlagen, aber da gab's dann doch noch irgendwelche Probleme so richtig.
Früher hatte das, es gab mal so ein paar Versionen, die irgendwie so ein bisschen komisch waren, aber...
Nee, es musste vor letzten Monat irgendwann. Ich weiß aber gar nicht mehr wo es ist.
Aber früher hat das halt Ditto benutzt, irgendwie hat das ja immer alles mit Ditto kopiert und jetzt war es R-Sync. Ich frag mich, ob er Ditto nur für die Systemplatte nimmt und für alles andere R-Sync aber...
Ditto war lange Zeit das einzige Tool, was auch die Resource Forks und die Extended Attributes korrekt...
Das ist ja ein native Apple-Tool, was mit dabei ist.
Genau, das hat Apple beigelegt und R-Sync konnte das nicht. Und irgendwann, seit 10.05 ist das R-Sync auch...
Seitdem sie ihr eigenes R-Sync mitliefern, genau.
Na, sie haben schon eigentlich immer ihr eigenes R-Sync, aber...
Ja, mit ihren Extended Attributes-Teaches.
Das kam halt ihren eigenen Standorts nicht entgegen.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, als ich irgendwie per R-Sync ein Backup unter 10.4 gemacht habe und dann alle Quark-Express-Dateien kaputt waren. Daraufhin hab ich dann auch dieses Binär-Resource-Fork-Safe-R-Sync installiert. Gibt's irgendwo einen R-Sync?
Na, jetzt ist es mit dabei.
Ah, jetzt ist es sogar mit dabei, ok.
Ja, nee, also da muss ich sagen, war ich schon auch wieder froh, dass so eine Tools dann doch mal auch echt performen.
Ja, was ich noch benutze zum Synken, was eigentlich auch mich nicht vollständig glücklich macht, aber zumindest ganz gut funktioniert soweit, ist Evernote. Das hatte ich schon länger auf der Platte, hab das immer als zu umfangreich und zu multimedial so ein bisschen verachtet.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht so richtig, was ich damit machen soll.
Na, es ist halt ein Cloud-Based Note-Taking-Tool. Wobei es halt mehr als nur Text kann. Das ganze Beispiel auch Rich Text. Leider, das ist mein erster Minuspunkt bei vielen Pluspunkten, kann es nur Rich Text. Ich kann nicht sagen, dass das bitte mal jetzt hier einfach unformatiert zu sein hat. Weil ich will nicht formatieren manchmal. Okay, kann man trotzdem benutzen. Hat natürlich auch keinen Outliner. Wie alles, keinen Outliner hat. Das ist so zum Kotzen. Und das muss sich ändern. Falls uns ein Programmierer zuhört, der so für Macintosh und vielleicht auch für das iPhone und für das Web programmiert, macht einen geklauteten, gesunken, auf Dropbox basierenden, auf Drogen basiert. Ich meine, das ist einfach. Du nimmst Dropbox, du nimmst so was wie OPML, was einfach ein XML-basiertes Outliner-Format ist. Mehr braucht man nicht. Und baust einfach ein OPML-Editor mit Dropbox-Syncing auf dem Mac und auf iPhone.
Ich bin ja so ein bisschen auf der Suche nach einem Dropbox-Client in JavaScript geschrieben. Das wäre nochmal so eine schöne Sache.
Ach so, sollte ja auch kein Problem sein eigentlich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es geht.
Die API geht doch über das Web, oder nicht?
Ja, aber somit mit...
Ist doch bestimmt so eine Rest-API, oder nicht?
Ich hab's mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt. Es scheitert Bändern eher an Cross-Site-Script-Domains-Zeug, weil du ja nicht einfach...
Eye-Frame.
Muss man als Skript bei dem installieren.
Also sollte nicht so das Problem sein.
Dann wär da noch viel mehr drinne.
Da geht's sowieso noch viel mehr. Da können wir uns noch warm anziehen für die nächsten Monate. Da wird noch...
Vielleicht noch mal ein Satz zu Evernote. Evernote ist cool. Es ist dann cool, wenn man wirklich viele Notizen hat. Also wenn man wirklich viel in so einzelnen Sachen notieren will. Und ich mach das jetzt zum Beispiel so, dass ich für jede Podcastsendung und auch für ein paar andere Dinge mir einfach eine eigene Notiz mache. Und du kannst halt in Evernote Gruppen machen, sogenannte Notebooks, sodass du sozusagen nach deinen einzelnen Projekten deine Notizen unterscheiden kannst. Und es gibt halt einen hervorragenden Client für das iPhone und ich glaube auch für das iPad-Nativ, ich bin gerade nicht so ganz so sicher. Und auf dem Mac halt auch. Du kannst halt auch Fotos da reinziehen und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich ein guter Scratch-Space. Und es synkt ordentlich und schnell.
Ist es denn auch kollaborativ?
Das ist es nicht. Und das ist genau das Problem. Sonst hätte ich das hier schon längst gepitcht. Abgesehen, dass es eben kein Outliner ist, aber nichts ist derzeit ein Outliner. Aber das funktioniert zumindest soweit schon mal ganz gut.
Warum haben wir hier keinen IPv6?
Na dann hast du das ausgeschaltet bei dir.
Weil heute, das muss man kurz mal anwähnen, also erwähnen, weil heute ist Quatsch bei Heise IPv6-Tag. Und irgendwie, da wir im Pub gerade so ein bisschen verunfallt sind, habe ich zu Hause gerade keinen IPv6.
Also keine Airport Extreme?
Also ich hab das heute schon...
Was machen die denn am IPv6-Tag?
Na, die haben einen Test gefahren. Heute haben sie, also sie hatten schon länger dieses 6 www.6...
Brauchen wir noch ein Kabel für?...
.heise.de Ich hab kein, ich hab's an und das geht hier nicht.
Ich brauch mal ein Kabel hier.
Müssen wir eigentlich auch über WLAN gehen.
Geht nicht.
Ist kaputt.
Ja, okay, sie hatten so eine www.6.heise.de und...
Und heute haben sie einen Tag lang auch mal heise.de sozusagen im Live-Test auf IPv6 gefahren.
Die haben keine spezielle Adresse für IPv6, sondern www.heise.de löst heute auch IPv6-Abfragen.
Was dann zu diesem berühmten Problem führt, wenn man gleichzeitig IPv6 und IPv4 hier hat, dass man eventuell gar nichts passiert.
Wenn du ein defektes IPv6 hast, also wenn du zwar eine IPv6-Adresse hast, aber die nicht richtig geroutet wird, dann kriegst du zwar deren IPv6-Adresse, aber du kommst ja nicht hin und dann klappt's nicht. Und da wollten sie mal sehen, bei wie vielen Leuten das ein Problem ist.
Und? Haben sie schon irgendwelche Aussagen getroffen?
Nee, die Aktion geht ja jetzt noch bis 10 Uhr. Ab 10 Uhr scheiden sie das DNS ab, was dann bis 12 Uhr, 2 Stunden hat, auszulaufen. Und die Auswertung davon wird es die nächsten Tage geben. Aber es ist noch mal vielleicht für alle, die hier live zuhören, vielleicht, weil die anderen Hörer sind ja zu spät, dass die alle noch mal irgendwie auch heise klicken und mal gucken und tun und ja, sich mal ein bisschen damit beschäftigen.
Ist jetzt endlich mal wieder ein Grund, auf Heise zu klicken.
Ja, es ist total polzle. Du siehst ja nichts, was du nicht sonst auch sehen würdest, aber es ist mal ein schöner Anlass, mal so ein bisschen vor sechs Testing zu machen.
Ja, und manchmal gibt es auch, dass Leute gar nicht so viel machen müssen, um es zu aktivieren. Also wenn die Jungs hier alle auch so eine Express haben oder was, ne, Express, da geht es ja nicht. Die müssen schon...
Bei der neuen geht es, glaube ich. Also wenn du dir jetzt eine aktuelle kaufst...
Extreme meinst du oder Express?
Nein, nein, die Express, die aktuelle, kann das meines Wissens auch. Und die Extreme und die Time Capsule, die können das schon immer.
Also irgendwann kam noch die Express raus, die enden kann. Danach kam noch gar keine neue mehr.
Wir können einfach mal gucken. Das muss doch irgendwo bei apple.com stehen, oder?
Jetzt kannst du mich so ein bisschen inskrutieren. Ich meine mich an ein Update zu erinnern.
Aber die Extreme macht das doch nur, wenn du an dem Warnport Internet dran hast. Die macht das ja nicht, wenn du die irgendwo ins Netzwerk stellst.
Die muss schon irgendwie vorne dran sein.
Und die Express hat doch keinen Warnport, oder? Hat sie?
Du kannst den Ethernet-Port als Warnport benutzen. Aber der hat halt nur einen Port. Entweder hast du LAN oder Warn. Also du kannst so eine Express auch als DSL-Ppp-Zugang benutzen.
Du kannst als Ppp-Zugang benutzen.
Aber dann halt nur über WLAN. Cool wäre, oder das muss ich gleich mal ausprobieren. Es gibt ja diesen geilen USB-Ethernet-Adapter. Der funktioniert hervorragend an Macs, falls du mal einen zweiten Ethernet-Port brauchst. Einfach das Teil heranschlinken, keine Installation, nichts. Einfach hast du einen zweiten Ethernet-Port.
Wie von USB nach Ethernet, das Ding, was du für das MacBook Air gibt.
Genau, das funktioniert auch am Mac ganz wunderbar. Aber ich hab noch nie das an der AirPod Express angeschlossen. Da ist ja auch USB dran. Das wäre natürlich cool, wenn er darüber noch einen zweiten Ethernet-Port aufmachen könnte.
Glaub ich ja nicht.
Aber wäre natürlich ein cooler Trick, könnten so eine Menge Adapter verkaufen, verdienen sie auch dumm und dem nicht.
Ja, dann wär das eine richtige schöne Light White.
Ja, aber die wollen ja Extremes verkaufen.
Naja, aber vielleicht geht's ja und keiner hat's ausprobiert. Los Leute, rennt.
Das kriegen wir doch noch während der Sendung raus, könnte ich schwören.
Funktioniert dieser USB-Anschluss denn von der Express schon mit AirPrint?
Da kommen wir gleich zu.
Ja, wie viele Themen haben wir denn jetzt noch von unseren? 1.200.
50. Wir sind ja immer noch in dieser Sinking-Wales und ich finde das ganz interessant, mal diese ganzen Varianten auch mal so durchzukabeln, was es da alles so gibt, weil da tut sich einfach extrem viel.
Naja, ich finde, da tut sich irgendwie nichts. Also, aus meiner Sicht.
Also, seit ich Mobile-Me verwende, passiert da was. Ist einfach, ja, es ist einfach dieser Traum von, ich kann jederzeit den Rechner wechseln, ist weitgehend erfüllt. Also, solange ich die wichtigen Dateien auch noch über Dropbox sinke. Weil iDisc würde ich nicht nehmen. Das ist mir zu viel mit Conflicted Copy und so'n Scheiß. Das gibt's manchmal auch bei Dropbox. Da muss ich sagen, so dieses Sparkle Share mit Git und so, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das noch mal eine ganz andere Solidität an den Tag legt.
So, da bin ich ja, was so Syncing angeht, bin ich ja sehr glücklicher Chrome-Nutzer.
Ich nutze ja nur noch Chrome, zum Duschen, zum Zähneputzen.
Und da kann man sogar...
War es für dich auch so schön wie für mich?
Gesynkt.
Mit dem Browser im Bett erwischt. Die haben so einen Google-Syncing.
Die können alles synken. Also die können Bookmarks synken. Die können alles synken. Die können Bookmarks synken. Die können, ich glaube, sogar auf einer Tab synken. Das habe ich allerdings noch nicht hingekriegt. Und die können Erweiterungen synken.
Tabs kann man synken.
Tabs kann man synken und Erweiterungen. Und diese Tabs sind?
Da arbeite ich ja noch bei Movami für Safari drauf.
Ja, ich weiß.
Du wirst nichts tun.
Und bei Firefox 4 kann man glaube ich auch offene Tabs. Doch es gibt auch einen Reader für Chrome. Das ist eine Erweiterung.
Ja, so mit Taster und dann hat man das genauso.
Das sieht echt schick aus. Also ich bin großer Freund von Chrome. Ich finde das Interface sehr aufgeräumt. Ich weiß, ihr seid da nicht so leicht von zu überzeugen. Ich finde deutlich schneller als Safari. Zumindest auf meinem Rechner. Wirklich? Ja, wirklich um ein Vielfaches schneller. Und man kann Extensions sinken und so was. Das können die halt alles. Das geht halt alles super. Und das macht schon Spaß. Und ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt wesentlich mehr Erweiterungen als für Safari dafür.
Vielleicht braucht er ja auch mehr.
Safari kann ja von Haus aus auch so ziemlich ja nüscht.
Also wer einen Browser will, der nichts kann. Also ich benutze auch mal Chrome. Er ist bloß nicht mein Default, aber er liegt hier in meinem Doc direkt neben Safari.
Und was ich seitdem ich das iPad so regelmäßig nutze, nutze ich am Rechner auch sehr, sehr gerne, also am MacBook, die Fullscreen-Funktion. Also Chrome kann Fullscreen. Dann hat man wirklich so nichts mehr drum rum, sondern einfach nur die Seite. Und das ist so jetzt...
Nur das Web.
Nur das Web. Und das so ganz aufs Wesentliche reduziert. Und das macht schon so einen schön großen Google-Reader und so, das macht schon Laune. Abfillshift-F muss man drücken.
Abfillshift-F?
Ich weiß nicht, welcher Menübefehl das ist.
Ist das nicht der sogenannte... Ist das nicht der sogenannte Kiosk-Mode?
Was hast du jetzt gemacht?
Ja, aha, wenn man nach oben geht, kommt dann auch noch dieser Chrome-Test.
Aber dafür hast du doch die Reader-Test, oder nicht?
Was? Nee, das hat ja damit nichts zu tun.
Das kann man ja noch zusätzlich machen.
Man kann noch in diesen Reader-Modus gehen.
Genau, dann müsste hier aber noch die passende Extension hier...
Genau.
Wie kommen wir da wieder raus?
Noch mal Abfillshift-F.
Abfillshift-F.
Schon wieder durchgefallen hier.
Das sind wirklich genau diese Sachen. Natürlich drückt man da Escape.
Bist du PC Nutzer?
Es-Cape.
Es-Flocht.
Ge-Bäck.
Abfillshift-F ist es immer.
Abfillshift-F.
Oh Mann, das ist wie diese bekloppte Kinder-Screensaver-Teil, was ich mir irgendwann mal exzellent nicht installiert habe.
Wenn man da aus Versehen reinfällt.
Und dann muss man wie Quid irgendwie eintippen, um das Ding loszuwerden, weil das so Kinder-Safe ist. Und das hab ich dann irgendwie vergessen.
Und ich hab meinen Computer nicht mehr unter Kontrolle bekommen.
Was ich geschafft hab, es gibt hier dieses YouTube Fullscreen-Dingsbums. Dieses Interface, was die haben, sodass das für Fernseher gedacht ist. Was so ein komplettes Flash-Interface ist. Und das hab ich dann auch mal so im Fullscreen-Modus von Chrome benutzt und hab dann da rumgeklickt, bis mir dann irgendwann aufgefallen ist, dass Flash dann alle Tasteneingaben abfängt. Und auch der Fullscreen-Taste. Und dann kam ich aus diesem Scheiß-Fullscreen-Modus nicht mehr raus. Das war ätzend. Also Endeffekt hab ich dann mit Apfel-Tab gewechselt und Chrome abgeschossen, aber das war...
Du hast meine Mater geklaut.
Ich glaube, meine Oma wäre daran schon gescheitert gewesen.
Hoffentlich ist das bald vorbei.
Achso, Flash auf Android ist jetzt angreifbar, ne? Habt ihr ja mitbekommen, oder?
Angreifbar wie?
Warum sollte es auch auf Android nicht angreifbar sein?
Ja, aber das ist jetzt erstmal so richtig eine schöne Security-Lücke. Ja, betroffen sind Acrobat und Flash auf Mac und PC und Android.
Du hast nicht vor ein paar Wochen schon ein Flash-Exploit, mit dem man dann den Jailbreak gemacht hat auf irgendeinem Android?
Achso, das denke ich nicht.
Aber es gibt doch kaum bisher......die Killer-Applikation für Flash. Übrigens Hinweis an die Hörer, falls ihr tolle, aber wirklich tolle, tolle Sachen für unser Soundboard habt, sodass wir nicht die ganze Zeit......wirklich just amazing spielen müssen......spielen müssen, dann schickt sie mir.
Ein Wort auf der Rolle Um-Year-Button von Bill Lamberg.
Hab ich das ja nicht sogar auch?
Die Hörer wissen jetzt nicht, wovon wir sprechen. Ich verrat's mal nur, Jörg.
Nee, ich hab hier nur noch so ein paar andere Sachen wie... Die Heilig-Sprechung des Kapitalismus.
Eine soziale Obszönität.
Das hab ich aber eigentlich für North Sail for Work gedacht.
Natürlich besteht bei komplizierten Geräten, deren Genauigkeit zu schwer zu steuern, ist die Gefahr von Fehlfunktionen. Das muss bedacht werden.
Das muss bedacht werden, das ist wichtig.
Hab ich jetzt gar nicht erkannt, die Stimme.
Was hast du hier?
Was hast du jetzt? Oh, jetzt bist du beim Bill Langberg. Hast du die in guter Qualität?
Es ist ja auch so ein Flash-Soundboard gerade.
Ich kann dir den Movie in Dick geben.
Aber das ist halt nur Flash. Ich bräuchte das halt mal so als...
Den ganzen Movie in Dick haben.
Den Movie in Dick? Ich hab, glaube ich, hab ich den hier gerade? Weiß ich nicht. Du kannst mir den Movie auch mal in Dick geben.
Später.
In welchem Format ist der in dem Movie in Dick?
Bestimmt nicht, was du toll findest. Ich muss gucken.
Du kannst auch transkoden jetzt.
Ich bin bereit.
In deinem Lieblingsformat. Dot MKV.
Ja, und weißt du, warum mich das nicht mehr schockt? Letztes Mal.
Weil es dann Transcoder gibt jetzt.
Genau, und zwar letztes Mal habe ich davon schon berichtet und ich habe genannt, das Tool... Ich habe letztes Mal genannt, das Tool MKV Tools und ich ziehe meinen Pick, wie das bei Bits und so immer so schön heißt, zurück. Denn MKV Tools... Ja, so heißt das da.
Wir sind aber hier nicht bei Bits und so.
Du musst es mir erklären, ich höre es nicht.
Das Tool der Wahl. You are free to come up with something interesting, aber die haben schon, das muss man anerkennend feststellen, die haben ein paar echte Begriffe geprägt, die wirklich verfangen.
Ja, für Leute, die das hören, jetzt erklärst du mal, was das ist.
Ein Pick? Ein Pick ist sozusagen Software, die du dir notiert hast, oder auch Hardware.
Die ich gepickt habe, ja.
Die du dann in diesem Podcast erwähnst. Was ein Pick. So wie...
Und dann gibt es noch...
Ich würde es noch Wines und Blizz nennen.
Wobei der Blizz findet in letzter Zeit selten statt, muss ich sagen. Na wie auch immer. Wir sind ja hier nicht bei Bits und so.
Richtig.
Wir sind doch hier nicht bei Bits und so.
Also, MKV-Tools. Ich hatte dann doch Probleme. Am Anfang sah es so aus, als ob das ganz gut funktioniert. Es war ja auch so ein bisschen Neckware mit irgendwie Kaufmich und dann so Registrierungen mit Seriennummern und so. Und dann wurde ich freundlicherweise von einem kundigen Menschen aus dem Internet belehrt, dass es noch eine viel tollere Variante gibt. Nämlich Sapler. S-U-B-L-E-R. Ist frei, ist auf Google-Code.
Ich drücke hier die 1 und dann sagst du nochmal?
Ich finde es schön, dass ihr so viel Spaß habt an dieser Appliance. Das finde ich toll.
Aber macht halt nicht bling, bling und bunt, bunt. Das fehlt noch ein bisschen.
Okay, ich arbeite an bling, bling und bum, bum.
Dann können wir es vielleicht sogar wieder Kapitelmarken machen, ob es so ein Spaß ist.
Sapler ist insofern sehr cool. Also leider unterstützt es auch nur MKV, in Anführungsstrichen. Und immer noch nicht AVI. Also man kriegt jetzt sozusagen das MPEG-4 immer noch nicht aus dem AVI raus, aber man kriegt es aus dem KV raus. Und das funktioniert auch wie so eine Macintosh-Applikation.
Aber AVI sind eh nur noch die El Chippo Billigmovi.
Ja, aber ich hab halt da Archive, wo ich es einfach gerne mal ein bisschen befreien würde, ohne Re-Encoding. Aber ist auch egal. Sublab funktioniert auf jeden Fall so, wie man das so von so einer Mac-Document-Centric-Applikation erwartet. Du startest das, sagst Apfel N, dann geht ein Dokument auf, was quasi dein neues MP4-File ist, und dann importierst du da halt Zeug rein, also das MKV, direkt so dann irgendwie rein, oder über Import. Und dann sagst du einfach Save, und dann hast du dein MP4-File. Und das hat besser funktioniert, als ein MKV-Tools.
Und der macht wirklich so ein, also nicht mal ein Transcoding, sondern einfach nur so einen Container wechseln. Du musst da nix rechnen, sondern du musst nur einlesen und neu abspeichern.
In Instant. Also viel schneller als MKV. Also MKV-Tools hat immer noch irgendwie Zeit gebraucht. Und Subladen brechst du rein, save, fertig.
Und hast du dir auch angeschaut, ob es auch wirklich in Ordnung ist?
Ja, ich hatte nämlich ein paar Fälle, wo MKV-Tools mir einfach dann doch, wo ich dann sozusagen dieses, diese Sync-Scheiße, die ich bei MKV-Abspielen immer hatte, so Ton, Bild, Fu, das mir auch in das MP5, MP4-Fail mit übertragen hat. Und dann hab ich das mit demselben File nochmal mit Zappler ausprobiert und sehe da alles wunderbar und schön und die Vögleinschatten und die Sonne schienen.
Weil innen drin ist eh alles H264. Und in der Regel ja.
Wobei das glaub ich auch mit normalem MP4-Normal-Codec auch gehen würde.
Ja, 264 auch, MP4 nur irgendwie ein bisschen weiter.
Das ist halt AVC und das andere ist halt der normale VC.
MP4 Part 10 oder so heißt das dann, glaube ich.
Das ist AVC. Ja, viele Namen und Zappler ist toll und frei und open source und überhaupt all das, was ihr alle so schätzt.
Ich spiele hier die ganze Zeit so ein bisschen mit diesem iPod-Nano rum.
Der Puppe war nämlich so lieb, hier einfach mal seinen frischen kaufen.
Der Puppe.
Der Puppe ist der Puppe.
Ist der auch im Chat?
Ich glaube, der war krank. Hat er keine Entschuldigung?
Hatten wir den schon mal getroffen irgendwo?
Das kann gut sein.
Waren wir auf dieser Apple-Veranstaltung, haben wir den da nicht mal getroffen? Oder war es auf unserem Hörer-Dings? Wann machen wir übrigens mal wieder einen? Entschuldigung, das jetzt mal kurz.
Auf der Apple-Veranstaltung haben wir den nicht getroffen. Du meinst den Flash? Der Flash.
Ach so, das war der.
Und den Phil Darf oder wie heißt er? Haben wir auf der Apple-Veranstaltung getroffen.
Den haben wir, glaube ich, auf dem Hörer-Treffen getroffen. Oder auf der Apple-Veranstaltung oder beides. Wir grüßen Phil Darf. Und wir grüßen den Flash.
Aber machen wir mal wieder ein Hörer-Treffen eigentlich.
B-Taste, B-Taste!
Wollen wir das jetzt vorziehen oder wollen wir erst über den iPod Nano reden?
Also, weil es mir so ein kleines Detail ist, was mir gerade aufgefallen ist, man kann ja das Display drehen, was übrigens wesentlich leichter geht, als ich gedacht hätte.
Also beschreib doch erstmal, was du da in der Hand hast.
Das ist ein iPod Nano. Das ist der Neue, genau. Der Apfel auf der Rückseite ist extrem schick.
Ich finde die Rückseite auch schöner.
Jetzt beschreib den Hörer mal, was du da siehst.
Das ist so fast quadratischer, kleiner iPod Nano halt.
Und der jetzt kein Video mehr abspielen kann?
Der jetzt kein Video mehr abspielen kann, was wahrscheinlich...
Kein Mensch benutzt hat?
Niemand vermisst und er hat keine Kamera mehr, was wahrscheinlich noch weniger jemand vermisst.
Ich bin nicht so sicher, aber die werden schon einen Grund gehabt haben, das wegzulassen.
Und man kann, während man hier das Display dreht, also wenn man das so auf halb acht hat, dann kann man zum Beispiel bei der Uhr, geht der Sekundenzeiger weiter, während man es gerade dreht.
Nein! Doch!
Und alle Animationen gehen weiter.
Kannst du das nochmal kurz sagen?
Nein!
Kannst du das nochmal sagen?
Was ist jetzt? Dann animiert es weiter?
Wenn man es dreht, dann läuft der Sekundenzeiger weiter.
Wenn man es dreht, dann läuft der Sekundenzeiger weiter. Was haben die da für einen Prozessor drin, dass der so eine Echtzeitrotation schafft und dann das Bild skaniert und alles?
Ja, das ist die Future.
Das werden sich viele Leute über unser Sound beobachten. Das ist jetzt der neue iPod Nano, der hat keine Kamera mehr, kann keine Movies mehr abstuhlen, der ist cooler als vorher. Ich weiß, aber was hat er denn Neues, sowas, das er setzt?
Er ist kleiner.
Noch kleiner?
Man kann ihn direkt anklippen.
Und der Touch.
Also weil er so ein bisschen die Größe von einem Shuffle hat, oder wie?
Der ist so die Größe von einem alten Shuffle.
Also ich dachte mir als Erstes, man könnte das Ding so auf so Konferenzen einfach als Badge benutzen, wenn man da irgendwie sein Name anzeigt.
Und da im Display sein Name anzeigen.
Mein Name ist Bob, ne Tim, ne Herr.
Ja, einfach so eine Visitenkarte durchlaufen lassen oder so. Oder keine Ahnung, aber es gibt ja keine Ups dafür. Ich hatte ja letztes Mal gemutmaßt, dass es sich hierbei auch um ein iOS-Device handelt, war ein großer Griff ins Klo, diese Einschätzung. Aber wenn man sich das Ding mal so anfasst, ist es ein bisschen anders, ne? Vom Anfassen her.
Findest du das? Ich find's erstaunlich nah dran, muss ich sagen. Also ich find, ähm...
Nah an was?
Ich vermisse am iOS-Gefühl. Also ich vermisse Spotlights ein bisschen.
Gib mir mal.
Bitte.
Das Display ist so klein, dass man mit zwei Fingern kaum drehen kann, oder?
Also es geht nicht gut, aber es geht okay, finde ich.
Ich habe ja schmale Finger, da geht es gut.
Mit meinen riesigen Kranken ist natürlich ein Problem.
Ja, brauchst du zwei Nanos. Kaufe einfach zwei iPod-Nanos, drehst du beides.
Keine Podcasts, siehst du hier drauf. Ich müsste mal das Podcast-Interface ausprobieren. Aber mit diesem lange Draufdrücken, das finde ich irgendwie doof.
Man kann auch die meisten Sachen nach rechts rüber swipen, dann bist du auch wieder auf dem Springboard. Also ich finde das schon, ich finde den nicht verkehrt. Macht Spaß.
Die Uhr ist cool. Oh, der Sekundenzeiger, der geht ja so ganz smooth.
Hat er doch gesagt, das kannst du dir nicht hassen.
Seeing is believing.
Spule noch mal zurück. Du kannst, während du es drehst, geht der Sekundenzeiger weiter. Also die lassen tatsächlich so Animationen weiterlaufen, während man diese Animation macht. Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz spannend. Ich hätte gedacht, dass die ja so einen Screenshot machen in dem Moment und dann halt den so ein bisschen drehen.
Naja, die haben auch glaube ich in diesen kleinen Teilen schon so ein bisschen GPU drin.
Wahrscheinlich.
Die können da einfach mal so eine Pain rotieren. Ich meine, das sind ja nicht viele Pixel.
Ja klar, aber ist das schon?
Naja, schon recht, passt schon.
So, dann hat Apple ja noch andere Software rausgebracht. Wollen wir mal über dieses Betriebssystem, was hier drauf ist, so?
Es ist schneller geworden. Ich wollte es nicht glauben. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass es fliegt wie Sau, aber es ist zumindest, ich hab so ein paar der Sachen getestet, die bisher unerträglich waren und sie waren nicht mehr unerträglich.
Wahrscheinlich ist das das Data Center, was Apple benutzt.
So was wie Film laufen lassen und dann ein iPhone anschließen. Das startet schneller und wenn du einen iPod anschließt oder ein iPhone anschließt und der so mit dem Syncing anfängt, dann ruckelt es nur noch ein bisschen.
Vorher hat es so wie so 5 Sekunden.
Du letztes Mal hast es 5 bis 10 Sekunden lang irgendwie gebremst und es war gar nicht mehr zu benutzen. Also sie haben irgendwas getan, aber es ist immer noch scheiße. Und jetzt haben sie diese ganzen Icons alles so auf so grau. Ich kotze. Da erkennt man nichts mehr wieder.
Aber das mit diesen kleinen Bubbles, dass sie die an die Seite gemacht haben, finde ich ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht, weil eigentlich ist das ja voll die Platzverschwendung oben.
Ja, das finde ich auch gar nicht so verkehrt.
Hat hier auch ein Kollege von mir, der Robert, den muss ich mal hier kurz erwähnen, falls er das doch hört. Er ist nämlich ein ganz aufgeweigtes Kerlchen. Der hat den Vorteil, dass dieser Platz da oben, vor allen Dingen ist da ja nichts. Der Nachteil ist, aber der Nachteil ist, dass man dann weniger Platz hat zum Greifen bei den Fenstern. Wenn du das jetzt überall durchziehen würdest.
Naja, wobei das ist doch, bei so einem iTunes-Fenster kann man doch sowieso überall anfassen.
Aber bei Safari, wenn du da jetzt oben die 10 Pixel weglässt.
Bei Safari kannst du doch hier unten auch anfassen.
Ja, da unten.
Aber du hast mehr Platz nach oben, dann im Toolbar, weil da ist ja oben alles irgendwie, da muss ja noch der Titel rein.
Ich hab ja iTunes 10 noch nicht installiert. Ich hab Angst.
Ungläubiger.
Nee, sowas warte ich immer ab, bis dann die ersten Exploits und...
Hast du das denn gelöscht?
iTunes 10, da läuft das Original Firefly, funktioniert ja nicht mehr. Da muss man nur über das Firefly patchen. Hab ich schon gemacht und geht dann aber auch wieder.
Steht da nicht in den App Store Review Guide, dass hier jeder zu Steinigen ist, der noch kein iTunes 10 installiert hat?
Also wirklich dieses iTunes. Ich hab ja, nachdem wir letztes Mal gerantet haben, dachte ich ja, ist wieder gut, ne? Aber dann haben wir irgendwie wieder Filme ausgeliehen. Und das ist so schlecht. Also es ist nicht nur langsam. Also du hast zum Beispiel keine Movie-Controls. Im DVD-Player kannst du ja mit Movie-Controls Gamma korrigieren, was ja immer bei Beamer gucken und so ganz gut ist, um mal die dunklen Stellen nochmal hoch zu holen und so ein Kram. Also du hast keine Audio-Controls, die du beim DVD-Player, bei QuickTime, bei allen anderen hast. Audio-Controls hast du auch nicht so richtig. Ah doch, Audio-Controls hast du in Equalizer. Genau, stimmt. Doch, den Hasen. Aber dann halt irgendwie dieses... Da gibt's keine Chapters, da gibt's keine Subtitles, da gibt's irgendwie nix. Das ist einfach nur...
Nein, es gibt...
Nicht bei Filmen.
Das stimmt.
Und du kannst halt nicht sagen, ich will den Film jetzt in QuickTime gucken. Du kannst diesen fucking Film nur in diesem...
Das müssen wir uns mal notieren hier irgendwie.
Und die Qualität von den Filmen ist da schlecht. Also ich frage mich, was ist so schwer?
Was haben die da geraucht in Kalifornien?
Ich will Geld ausgeben für Filme gucken. Ich leih mir die, ich lad mir die runter. Ist alles cool, aber mach doch wenigstens, dass es Spaß macht. Aber was es gibt seit letztem Mal, ich hab mich beschwert, man kann jetzt im Store sich die Filme in Originalversion angucken. Also es gibt extra einen Bereich, jetzt hier Originalversion, wobei Originalversion heißt in englischer Sprache und wenn du einen französischen Film guckst, Ist der in Französisch? Nee, dann ist er halt nur in Originalsprache, wenn er auf Englisch auch übersetzt ist.
Also Originalsprache heißt, ich will das gucken, was sie in Amerika zeigen.
Ja, so in etwa. Also ich muss nochmal Steve so ein Feedback-Formular ausführen, oder eine Mail schreiben, aber... Aber gut, das zu einem...
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, was ich sagen soll. Dann dieser neue View, ja, mit diesem Album und Tralala.
Aber ich muss sagen, der Tabellen-View, der ist schon slick, der sieht jetzt schon irgendwie schicker aus.
Ja, aber sie haben dafür in dem normalen Listen-View die Albumspalte rausgelassen.
Aber kannst du nicht wieder rein konfigurieren?
Nein, die ist jetzt weg, weil sie sagen, dafür gibt es noch den anderen View.
Meinst du die?
So? Nein, das Album Cover Art.
Und die gibt es nicht in den Spalten? Du kannst doch bei View Spalten, ne? Kannst ja oben im Menü konfigurieren.
Ja, wovon spricht hier?
Ich verstehe auch nicht, was er meint.
Habe für Glaub und dann Album anwählen.
Da gibt es kein Album mehr. Also, doch es gibt Album, also es gibt es gab drei Views, jetzt gibt es vier. Was vorher der List View war, ist jetzt der List View und der List View mit Cover Art. Wobei sie halt diesen Algorithmus haben, dass wenn mehr als drei Items, dann zeigt er das an und sonst nicht. Ich habe allerdings...
Ich habe bestimmte Sachen.
Einfach, was weiß ich, ich habe immer das Cover Art angezeigt, auch wenn es nur einer ist. Weil das ist die einzige Möglichkeit in diesem scheiß verfickten Wix-Programm überhaupt irgendwas zu finden, in dem du nichts ordentlich sortieren kannst und das kotzt mich an.
Und das in der 50.
Sendung. Bei Podcasts.
Das, wo wir noch keine Flucht hast.
Podcasts kannst du nicht sortieren, nix. Und jetzt haben sie mir auch noch...
It's Horrible.
Cover Art weggenommen, es ist Schluss.
Jetzt reicht's.
Es ist Schluss. Es platzt der Mond.
Und das Schlimmste an allem, dieses Icon ist doch wie 0 Beta.
Habt ihr das auf Twitter mitbekommen, was dann abgegangen ist mit dem Icon?
Das alte Icon hat getwittert.
Ne, das neue hat angefangen.
Mit dem alten, ja.
iTunes 10. Genau. Und dann haben sich die iTunes Icon-Versionen untereinander auf Twitter unterhalten.
So iTunes II Icon irgendwie so.
So iTunes 10. Ja, I'm the real Icon. Und so weiter. Halt's Maul.
Dann kam irgendwie das Windows-Icon auch noch auf. Und alle möglichen Icon-Versionen, wirklich ein Programm. Reden auf Twitter miteinander, das ist total großartig.
Das hab ich mir beide für voll gar nicht hinbekommen.
Echt unfassbar. Programm, das fängt auf einmal an, wie ein Icon II zu reden.
Ja, aber das ist auch wirklich das einzig Positive, was man diesem iTunes 10 abgewinnt hat.
Ich fand ja, diese alternativen Vorschläge, die es da gab, also gab's mehrere, aber gab's einen, der so besonders schick war.
Ich kann nicht wissen, welchen.
Warte mal, hier, Alternative.
Na ja, aber echt.
iTunes 10 Icons. Was kann man da machen, Jungs?
Na, man kann sich das da so rein...
Nee, was kann man machen gegen dieses iTunes?
Ja, wenig.
Pizzi's kaufen. Wenn das neue iTunes Icon so schick wäre, wie das QuickTime Icon, ja?
Dieses rosa Dingsbums, das ist sehr hübsch, sehr gelungen, weil es halt hier auch noch so durchschimmernd zur Kamera war. Ja, ja, das ist schon total fancy. Und das sieht auch irgendwie so aus wie eins, was jetzt Apple mal rausbringen würde.
Das sieht so ein bisschen angelehnt an das QuickTime Icon aus, ne?
Ich frage mich nur, was sie geritten hat bei diesem neuen Icon.
Ja, es ist total unklar.
Das war ein Praktikant.
Ja, was haben sie sich dabei gedacht?
Deren Designer muss verstorben sein.
Na komm, sie denken sich irgendwas dabei. Sie denken sich nicht immer das Richtige, aber irgendwas...
Ja, aber die Sache ist ja schonmal die, sie sagen, die CD ist tot, ja, aber in iTunes hast du ja nicht nur Musik, du hast ja alles mögliche, du hast iTunes University, du hast Filme, du hast Serien, Bücher, weil dann machen die da eine Note drauf.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man einfach was...
Warum heißt das überhaupt noch iTunes?
Ja, keiner weiß es, weil der Name so eingeführt ist.
Ja, der Name.
Stimmt, du hast recht, eigentlich müsste es so ein Messie-Zimmer. So ein Foto von so einem Messie-Zimmer.
Oder so ein Getronen-Store.
Kleiderkommode, wo so die ganzen Socken, die stinkenden Socken aus der Schublade rausquillen.
Hier gibt es jetzt für jedes Icon einen Twitter-Account. Sogar für Cyber-Doc-Icon.
Kann sich noch jemand als Cyber-Doc erinnern?
Wirklich? Cyber-Doc-Icon? Der Cyber-Doc-Icon hab ich geliebt. Das war eines der coolsten Icons.
Ich hatte noch keinen Webbrowser, als Cyber-Doc noch aktuell war. Ich hab das irgendwann mal ausprobiert, jahrelang nach dem...
Cyber-Doc-Icon, echt? Wie geil!
Und es gibt sogar Cyber-Doc-Complot. Das ist das alte Cyber-Doc, das erste.
Es gab da noch ein zweites?
Ja, es gibt noch das mit dem...
Ach, da hat der Hund dann so einen Jack-Pack auf dem Rücken.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch The Real Cyber-Doc-Icon. Mal gucken, mit wem der sich so unterhalten hat.
Dennis, was ist denn dein Lieblings-Icon?
Na ja, Cyber-Doc gab es ja auch nicht so lange.
Ist mir eine Schnuppe.
Für alle, die sich nicht mehr erinnern können, Cyber-Doc war ein Webbrowser von Apple.
Der war cool.
Der war Open-Doc-basiert und war, glaube ich, unerträglich langsam, oder?
Der war ganz schön...
Ey, jetzt haben wir die Themen-Taste hier schon wieder völlig aus acht gelassen.
Also, ich weiß schon, warum er sich durchgesetzt hat, aber es gab so eine Sache, die gefiel mir gut, bei Cyber-Doc, wenn du irgendwie ein neues Dokument aufgemacht hast, ging nicht gleich so eine ganze weiße Seite auf, die den ganzen Bildschirm belegt hat, sondern nur so eine URL-Zeile und erst, wenn du da Return gedrückt hast und wirklich eine Seite kam, dann ging diese Seite auf. Das fand ich immer ganz sexy aus, hat sich irgendwie nicht durchgesetzt.
Warum wohl? Jetzt mit Core-Animation könnte man das doch richtig so fancy, swooshy, swooshy, but floor-Effekt, hast du nicht gesehen?
War doch nicht bei Cyber-Doc auch so, dass man so mehrere Dokumente kombinieren konnte in einem, also so ein bisschen so der Sport-Style.
Open-Doc war das.
Cyber-Doc war doch da auch so ein bisschen basierend drauf.
Cyber-Doc war sozusagen die Browser-Komponente von Open-Doc. Und Open-Doc war halt so diese Idee, Applikationen auf so einem Komponenten-Modell zu machen. Und das war ein mega Fail. Hat sich einfach nicht...
Es war dieses Zusammenarbeitsthing mit IBM, ne?
Da wäre Rectime fast dran pleite gegangen, das ihr gesamtes System. Rectime, könnt ihr euch daran noch erinnern?
Die gibt es bis heute noch.
Gibt es immer noch.
Kostet ein Schweinegeld. Lotus Notes gibt es auch noch.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, wer das benutzt, aber irgendwie leben die.
Rectime war früher super. Damals so Tabellenkalkulationen und so in einem und die haben eine neue Version rausgebracht, die komplett auf OpenDoc basiert hat. Es waren draußen irgendwie drei Tage lang und dann hat Apple OpenDoc eingestellt. Und die wären fast dran pleite gegangen.
Das waren noch Zeit und dann kam aber Mac OS X und die Sonne ging auf.
Das hat aber noch lange gedauert, bis das kam. Das waren die dunklen Jahre.
Die dunkelgrauen Jahre.
Von 95 bis 2000 circa.
Ja, ich wurde gehänselt von Windows-Benutzern.
Die dunkelgrauen Jahre.
Das ging aber noch mit Mac OS X auch noch ein paar Jahre weiter.
Ja, aber da hat es mich nicht mehr gekratzt. Aber Mac OS 753 R2, das war schon eine Beleidigung.
75 war echt schlimm.
Zu schlechtestem Zeitpunkt.
Also ich muss sagen, ich hab mir dann einen Mac gekauft. Meine Eltern haben mich gefragt, willst du einen Computer nehmen? Was soll ich damit? Fand ich alles scheiße. Amiga, C64, Windows, alles hässlich. Und dann hat ein Kumpel von mir den ersten Power Mac, den 6100, gekriegt. Und dann dachte ich, boah, so macht das ja einigermaßen Sinn. Und dann fand ich, also ich muss sagen, retrospektiv gesehen, fand ich ja diese reduzierte Interface auch ja von 7.5 doch echt immer noch. Also es hat schon geräumt, es kam halt auf die Bombe, ja gut und irgendwie war halt nicht so das Stabilste, aber irgendwie...
Das war mit Abschluss das instabilste System überhaupt, oder?
Ja, ja, der legendäre Fehler.
Weißt du, wer schön sein will, muss leiden.
Als ich meinen Mac gekriegt hatte, da gab es da nicht noch Windows 3.11 so richtig auf breiter Basis, oder?
Ja, da kam Windows 95 da raus. Richtig, richtig abgelust.
Also ich kann mich auch erinnern, als ich gehänselt wurde, ja. Aber trotzdem war mein Photoshop schneller und mein Command & Conquer lief in 1024, ja.
Das Windows 95 toll war, woran man das erkennen kann, dass das nächste Windows 98 hieß. War immerhin Scheiße, oder haben sie ihren Namen gewechselt?
Aber wenn's gut war und von Gut nach Scheiße haben sie auch gewechselt, von Windows 98 zu ME.
Heißt ja immer noch Windows.
Aber XP haben sie ja aus der Microsoft-Perspektive als Erfolg. Oder als gutes OS. Das kriegen sie ja bis heute nicht so richtig tot.
Ja, also 95 und XP waren schon so ihre Hit-Releases. Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Ich glaube, das 75 von Windows, das war Windows ME.
Aber wir wollen ja hier nicht über Windows reden, nicht wahr? Sondern über wichtige Sachen, wie Icons. Von welchem Thema werden wir jetzt mal nachgefangen?
iTunes 10 waren wir.
Wir haben doch so um iTunes wieder in den Boden gerantet.
Genau, waren aber eigentlich auch fertig damit.
Ja, iTunes 10 trägt irgendwie nicht das Thema.
Also Drucken auf ein iPad, wie wär's denn da mit mal?
Du willst gerne das iPad-Thema...
Willst du über ungelegte Eier quatschen? Gackern.
Ungelegt? So ungelegt sind die gar nicht. Das Update ist hier gerade durch.
Installiert?
Ich hab da mir so Vögelchen...
Du weißt, dass du nicht mehr downgraden kannst, ja?
Ach Gott. Ich hab's ja seit gestern drauf, das ist halbwegs stabil.
Aber musstest du jetzt schon...
Aber seid ihr denn Developers, Jungs?
Was denn überhaupt? Ich hab hier Zahnpasta auf mein iPad drauf gemacht.
Okay, also jetzt mal klicken, oder?
Welche Zahnpasta-Marke denn?
Oh, ich hab keine Einladung. Keine Einladung. Im Kalender. Da kann man jetzt auch Einladungen sich hier oben anzeigen lassen, als siehst du, ah, keine Einladung.
Ja, die gehen ja jetzt auch so voll auf Collaboration-Street, ne? Oder? Ja, aber mit den Einladungen hab ich nur gerade mich an Collaboration...
Kamen in der letzten Sendung überhaupt schon 4.1 vor?
Ja.
Ja, weil ich weiß nicht, wann die rauskamen.
Hörst du unsere Podcasts nicht?
Lädst du wenigstens runter?
Das heißt, er geht auch die ganzen Witze über ihn auch gar nicht.
Tja, Dennis.
Wir haben dich hier immer im Schrank. So, der Gimp.
Jetzt printet doch jemand.
Ja.
Also, wir hatten ja letztes Mal schon drüber geredet, dass diese Print-Funktion irgendwie magisch ohne Druckertreiber wahrscheinlich auskommen wird. Das scheint sich jetzt zu bestätigen. Und das ist das ganze auch noch ein Braunen Namen. AirPrint ist wie HP das dann bei sich nennt. Warum auch immer.
So wie iLink und FireWire.
Konnten sich wahrscheinlich irgendwie die Lizenzierung von AirPrint nicht leisten. AirPrint ist sozusagen die Architektur von Apple und ePrint ist, was weiß ich, die Next Generation Tra-La-La Software für die HP Drucker.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wie hier Multicast DNS und Bonjour. Das eine ist so das Technische unten drunter und das andere ist halt der Werbeslogan von Apple.
Klar.
Aber ePrint klingt jetzt auch nicht gerade nach einem technischen Fachbegriff.
Das klingt doch scheiße. Aber wie auch immer. Also auf jeden Fall, sie haben da irgendwie mit HP angebandelt und die werden sozusagen da vorne sein. Das ist ja schon mal keine schlechte Basis. Was sie auch gesagt haben, ist, dass es aber auch mit jedem Drucker geht, der an dein Mac angeschlossen ist oder an dein PC angeschlossen ist.
Weil man dann über den Mac druckt?
Weil man dann über den Mac druckt.
Sofern man sich 10.6.5 Beta installiert.
Es wird da halt ein Update geben zum richtigen Zeitpunkt für Mac OS X und dann kann der Drucker-Service, das Printer-Sharing von Mac OS X und OS X all das, was erforderlich ist, um den Drucker zu machen. Ich meine, es ist ja heute schon so, dass wenn du von einem Mac, der keinen spezifischen Drucker-Treiber hat, für einen Drucker, der einen braucht, über Printer-Sharing, über einen anderen Mac druckst, der diesen Treiber halt hat, das eben auf dem Ursprungs-Mac, von dem du aus druckst, braucht man keinen Drucker-Treiber. Keinen Drucker-Treiber brauchst. Das heißt, wir haben da eh schon irgendwie eine Abstation. Ich hab mir das ehrlich gesagt noch nicht angeschaut, was da eigentlich gerade wirklich am Werkeln ist, aber in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass sie halt viel mit PDF und dem ganzen Klimbim machen und im Prinzip eigentlich ja nichts anderes machen müssten, als ein PDF zu übertragen, um zu drucken, heutzutage. Und ich vermute mal, das wird irgendwie die Lösung sein bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Kann man zumindest nur hoffen. Dass man noch irgendwas rasterbasiertes anbieten könnte, wäre schon, obwohl PDF ist eigentlich gut genug, oder? So auch für Bildchen und sowas.
PDF kann man halt auch Raster reinmachen.
Stimmt schon.
Sie können es ja komplett rastern, aber das glaube ich gar nicht mal, dass sie das tun, weil irgendwie so Fonts und sowas, das kennen ja diese Druckertreiber auch und das wäre dann ein bisschen schwergewichtig, wenn du irgendwie jede Seite komplett erst mal rennst.
Ich dachte, er sollte mehr Fotos drucken.
Das seinerzeit gemacht.
Also der Cube, Steve Jobs, anderes Baby, kam ja mit einem geilen schwarzen Drucker. Genau, und das Next Step, also das OS, funktionierte auf Basis von Display Postscript, was im Prinzip sehr ähnlich dem heutigen Konzept ist, nur dass sie halt jetzt quasi Display PDF machen, wenn man das mal übersetzt. Und damals war es halt Display Postscript. Und das heißt, sie hatten quasi hier im OS für die Anzeige im Bildschirm ohnehin den ganzen Renderer, wo sie mit Postscript beliebige Dinge formulieren konnten und dann haben sie es halt einfach in den Bildschirm gerendert. Und der Drucker hatte quasi keine Intelligenz, außer Netzwerkkommunikation. Und die Next-Step-Büchse, die Workstation, hat das Bild für den Drucker gerendert und dann eben einfach das fertig gerenderte Image in der benötigten Auflösung, so wie der Drucker es wirklich braucht, ausgedruckt. So hat das funktioniert. Wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass Airprint so funktioniert. Nein, weil das wären zu große Dateien, aber das war halt deren...
Also eine Option für Fotos wär's auf jeden Fall.
Genau. Damals war es halt das erste Mal wirklich Visivic. Also Quickdraw und dieser ganze andere Kram hat das alles nicht geleistet, weil du ja auf dem Mac hast du ja ein anderes Display-Model als auch ein Postscript-Drucker. Also so fing's ja an. Dein Programm hat's halt, ein Quickdraw, was weiß ich, dein Quakexpress hat halt Quickdraw benutzt, um es auf dem Bildschirm anzuzeigen. Musste es aber in Postscript formulieren, um es zu drucken. Und bei Next-Step hast du halt Postscript benutzt, um es auf dem Bildschirm anzuzeigen. Und du hast dieselbe Formulierung benutzt, um es für den Drucker zu rendern. Deswegen war das einfach exakt dasselbe. Und das will man natürlich auch heute haben. Und du hast immer noch diese Probleme mit PCL und diesen ganzen anderen Sprachen. Mittlerweile hat sich das so weit angeglichen, dass man meistens schon so das Richtige bekommt. Also drucken funktioniert ja mittlerweile so ein bisschen. Aber jetzt kann es halt sein, dass auch der Begriff Druckertreiber irgendwann etwas ist, was man seinen Kindern erklären muss, dass es so was mal gab.
Also ich bin ja mal sehr gespannt, ob das klappt. Wann wird dann eigentlich Meccos Airprint unterstützen? Auch schon mit 1065? Also dass man dann irgendwie in einen Raum rein kommt.
Also mach erst mal einen Ausdruck auf einen Teil der Agentur.
Wenn das Printersharing von Meccos Tenders kann, dann wird das ja auch...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen nur als Airprint Server dienen kann oder ob das dann auch als client funktioniert. Also so ist es nämlich ganz schick, weil das funktioniert offensichtlich über Bonjour. Bonjour heißt das, oder?
Also wenn ein iOS das kann, dann wird ein Meccos Tenders das dann auch können, weil da ist letzten Endes dieselbe Printarchitektur am Werk.
Ja, würde ich jetzt auch mal von ausgehen, aber...
Bauen sie das in Coups ein?
Stimmt, eigentlich ist es nicht dieselbe Printarchitektur. Ist Quatsch. Die haben unter Garantie keinen Coups auf iOS.
Unter Garantie?
Naja, die werden jetzt nicht so Spooler-Management und diesen ganzen Fu auf so ein iPad drauf machen, sondern da hast du einfach nur, du druckst, schickst das rüber und du hast nur die Jobübermittlung. Mehr wird das nicht sein. Und du auf Mac halt auch noch das ganze Spooler-Management hast, was du eben auch fürs Sharing brauchst. Beziehungsweise was man halt auch von so einem Computer erwartet.
Vielleicht haben sie aber einfach ein bisschen abgespeckt. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist das jetzt auf dem... Kann man nicht verstehen? Ich kling so extrem dumm für mich selber.
Ach so, ich halt die ganze Zeit deine Reusspartaste.
Nö, ich kann mal verstehen. Ich kann es so ein bisschen lauter machen, wenn es jetzt zu leise ist.
Also diese Druckfunktion ist halt einfach schick, weil du gehst in den Safari, sagst drucken und dann sagst du dir, welchen Drucker hättest du denn gerne? Dann sagt dir, wie alle Drucker an dir zur Verfügung stehen, was jetzt im Allgemeinen noch nicht so viele sind.
Du redest jetzt davon, wie du es gesehen hast.
Wie es auf iOS aussieht, genau. Und dann drückt man da auf drucken und dann druckt er den ganzen Scheißdreck. Das ist jetzt nichts, was ich ab sofort jeden Tag machen werde, aber es ist so grob, wie man sich das vorstellt. Also ich bin da sehr angetan von. Also ich hab mir dann auf dem Mac so einen PDF-Printer-Driver installiert, den hab ich dann über Druckerscharing freigegeben, genau mit dieser Funktion, und hab da fröhlich PDFs gedruckt aus Safari heraus.
Aber da fällt mir ein, Tim, du hattest doch angekündigt, du wolltest mit deiner Zunge irgendwas tun.
Was?
Du wolltest doch. Er hat doch gesagt, heute wirst du sie aber abschlecken.
Ach stimmt, ja das hast du vorhin gesagt.
Also als es um das Drucken ging, da hörst du dich das so an, als ob du jetzt eine Lobrede, also ein...
Naja, hab ich das schon gemacht, ich meine der Druckertreiber wird abgeschafft.
Das war aber noch nicht so enthusiastisch, wie wir das von dir gewohnt sind.
Ich kann mich steigern noch.
Hebst du dir das noch alles auf, wenn wir dann über deine Ping-Affahrung... Okay, was kommt denn da jetzt noch?
Wir müssen sie in die Ecke treiben.
Aber was ist eigentlich, was ist in sie gefahren, dass sie diese App Store Reviewer Prozess plötzlich entschlacken, besser machen?
Weil es jetzt so viele coole Apps gibt, dass irgendwie denen es jetzt auch egal ist, ob die Leute jetzt mit ihren Saki-Flash-Apps kommen. Die mussten uns dann erstmal die...
Ah, auf 50.000 bei scharf.
Wieso ist jetzt doch nicht der Untergang von iOS ist, wenn Flash-Apps plötzlich drauflaufen?
Das steht dann einfach, wir brauchen nicht die 75.000 zur Flash-App und...
Keine Ahnung. Also entweder weil sie wirklich zu viel Ärger bekommen haben, natürlich von oben.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie von FCC Stress bekommen haben.
Ja, glaube ich, aber eigentlich gesagt auch nicht so richtig. Ich glaube, das hätten die schon noch eine Weile ausgehalten mit denen. Also den Stress so. Weiß ich nicht.
Vielleicht sind sie ja wirklich lieb.
Vielleicht sind sie gar nicht so evil.
Oder um Google noch ein bisschen eviler wirken zu lassen.
Ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass jede Flash-App erst mal ein halbes Jahr im Review hängen bleibt.
also ich meine, sie haben die...
Können wir erstmal zusammenfassen, was überhaupt passiert ist?
Genau.
Für die Unkundigen? Ich darf keine Fart-Apps mehr bauen.
Also, ich muss zu dir geben, ich habe diese Guidelines nicht gelesen, sondern ich habe nur gelesen, was andere Leute daraus heraus zitiert haben.
Also ich habe sie mir auch nicht komplett durchgelesen, aber ich habe es so schon teilweise gelesen.
Und im Wesentlichen haben sie eine Reihe der umstrittenen Klauseln, besonders die mit vielen Dreien dran, ja, zusammen geschrumpft. Im Kern lässt es sich zusammenfassen mit richtig evil bist du nur, wenn dein Programm zur Laufzeit Binärcode aus dem Netz runterlädt.
Genau. Also was sie ja vorher gesagt haben, dass man nur die Apple Tools zum Kompilieren benutzen darf oder JavaScript, also wo sie ja die Sprachen festgelegt haben, der Teil ist rausgeflogen aus dem Agreement. Man darf jetzt jede Sprache nutzen, solange man keinen Code runterlädt.
Und solange man, wie war das, war da nicht auch noch was mit Dynamic Libraries?
Aber auf jeden Fall, dass dieses Flash-Tool, was Adobe da angefangen hat zu entwickeln, mit dem man Flash-Apps auf dem iPhone zum Laufen bringen kann, dass das jetzt wieder legale sozusagen, aber auch diverse andere Tools, wie zum Beispiel, was ich mir überlegt hätte, dieses Epic, also dieses Spiel, was sie beim letzten Mal gezeigt haben, diese Unreal Engine, wäre die denn überhaupt nach den alten App Store-Regeln legal gewesen?
Ja, sie haben ja auf jeden Fall schon vorher Lua-Spiele, Lua-geskriptete Spiele und so zugelassen.
Ja, bloß weil sie die nicht so hardcore ausgelegt haben, die Regeln heißt das ja nicht.
Da hatten wir ja auch drüber gesprochen ja schon.
Da gibt es aber auch noch kleine, feine Unterschiede.
Das ist halt etwas, was sie irgendwie klären müssen. Und ich schätze mal, sie haben eine Menge Gegenwind bekommen aus dieser Gamer-Community. Nicht nur, aber vor allem, die alle so ein bisschen Angst hatten, dass wenn die jetzt mit ihren Engines daherkommen, die halt einfach auf Scripting basieren, dass dann irgendwie...
Ja, aber die basieren doch nicht auf Scripting, sondern die nutzen Scripting so ein bisschen, um dann da drin rumzusteuern oder welche Sachen zu platzieren.
Die basieren so weit, dass wenn du es rausnimmst, dass das Spiel nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also es ist reicher.
Ich sag nicht, dass jetzt alles da drin geschrieben wird.
Das ist nicht so der riesengroße Teil an irgendwie dieser Engine.
Ja, aber es ist essentiell. Du kannst es nicht weglassen.
Ja, aber es ist schon noch was anderes.
Es ist auch ein moderner Programmierstil, bestimmte Dinge in deinem Programm einfach intern skriptfähig zu machen und dann eben mit irgendeiner scriptigen Lösung und wenn du sozusagen nur gegen deine eigenen Apis programmierst, das dann sozusagen in Bewegung zu kriegen. Weil es ja cool ist, weil du kannst ja auch separieren. Dann kannst du Lua-Hacker engagieren, die einfach auf so einer Metaebene programmieren und andere Hardcore, C++-Menschen hacken halt die kernigen Engines, die bis aufs letzte Bit voll durchoptimiert sind und mit Hardware und was weiß ich nicht alles sich synchronisieren. Das macht ja auch total Sinn. Und ich schätze mal, das wird ein Grund sein, warum sie das zurückgenommen haben. Warum sie allerdings tatsächlich jetzt auch dieses Flash-Teil wieder erlauben, habe ich so recht keine Erklärung für. Also ich weiß nicht, ich meine, die Einschränkung, die jetzt noch existiert, du darfst keinen Binärcode runterladen, beschränkt ja das Ganze zumindest insofern, als das Flash, das Plugin, wie es sozusagen im Web ist, nach wie vor nicht statthaft ist.
Sondern Adobe macht jetzt dieses Tool, dass Leute ein Flash schreiben und dann kommt es in den Konversor und macht eine App draus. Das ist das, was sie jetzt erlauben.
Genau, du hast in dieser Creative Suite mit drin.
Ich glaube, das kann man sich im Augenblick einfach so nach runterladen. Das ist noch nicht ganz fertig.
Und dann ist das Top-Tower-Defense für...
In dem Flash von der Creative Suite, also dem Flash-Authoring-Tool, kannst du halt auch deine Flash-Anwendung aufs iPhone targeten. Und dabei stellt halt dieses Environment sicher, dass dein Subsystem, was du eben benutzt, eben die iPhone-API ist oder die iOS-API. Und die Bedenken, die ja meiner Meinung nach völlig zurecht vorgetragen wurden, ist, dass wenn man eben auf dieser Basis arbeitet, wo du ja gar keine Chance hast, irgendetwas zu benutzen, was dir Adobe nicht bereitstellt. Also, das weiß ich hier, wenn so ein neues Feature kommt, wie jetzt mit iOS 4, Background, tralala.
Drucken. Kannst du auf seinem Flash... plötzlich nicht drucken.
Genau, drucken ist ein gutes Beispiel. Das kommt jetzt irgendwie noch dazu. Das willst du irgendwie machen. Und jetzt musst du sozusagen darauf warten, dass Adobe in deinem Flash-Generator-Teil diesen Zugang zu diesem Druck-API einbaut. Und bevor die das nicht releasen, kann keiner, der damit arbeitet, das machen. Gut, kann sein, dass Apple sich jetzt einfach sagt, na dann habt ihr halt Pech gehabt, was benutzt ihr so einen Scheiß auch? Aber es schadet uns zumindest nicht.
Und Apple hat natürlich Angst, dass die Leute irgendwie einmal gegen dieses Flash-Teug bauen und dann natürlich auch gleich auf Android noch irgendwie deployen können. Weil dann fehlt ja ja Alleinstellungsmerkmal.
Naja, ein Android-Deployment ist aber nicht drin, oder?
Na ja, dann kommt's irgendwann.
Aber du musst ja ganz anders programmieren unter Android. Du hast ja einfach eine ganz andere Abstraktionslogik als in der iPhone.
Das gleiche Spiel in Flash kannst du doch auch auf Android rausschmeißen. Dann ist das doch eigentlich kein Problem.
Ja gut, bei Spielen mag das hinhauen.
Darum geht's doch. Man ist da für es vorteil.
Ich dachte jetzt, wer so in Services, Architekturen usw.
quatscht hat.
Der in Flash geschriebenes Service für...
In Flash geschriebenes iTunes.
Das erklärt warum es ja so schnell ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es schon so. Deswegen haben wir den ganzen Stress.
Vielleicht wollten sie sich auch einfach ein bisschen aus der Defensive rausbringen. So ein bisschen wie mit ihrem iPhone 4 Antennagate Bumper.
Ich hab den ja, der ist toll.
Ja, ich hab den wieder abgemacht, nachdem ich gesehen habe, was das Ding meinem iPhone antut. Ja, ja, hast du den mal abgemacht? Mache mal ab und guck dir mal deine Antenne an. Wie meine Antenne, du meinst hier...
Da kommt Dreck hinter und das wird dann schön zerkratzt.
Das schmürgelt sich dann da so rein, ja.
Ach, das ist nicht schön.
Das heißt, mein Bumper, der so ein bisschen flexibel, der so starr ist und sich nicht so an der... Wow, das ist aber echt böse.
Das sieht nicht gut aus, oder?
Nein.
Also dieser Apple-Bumper ist irgendwie keine gute Idee. Na, was ich so normalerweise in meiner Hose...
Feenstaub.
Goldstaub.
Das Übliche halt.
Feenstaub.
So, dann haben sie noch irgendwie den Ad-Mob, das Anti-Google, den Paragraphen haben sie noch entschärft.
Ja, es ist das totale PPP. Wir haben uns alle liebprogramm, was sie da irgendwie gestartet haben.
Und sie haben die Review-Regeln freigelassen. Das finde ich ganz...
Gut, ich meine, das wurde auch Zeit.
Das wurde definitiv Zeit.
Was haben sie gemacht? Na, sie haben die Guidelines, die, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, auch so für die Leute, die im Upstore...
Steve-Language.
Genau. Haben sie halt einfach Released. Wobei da steht halt irgendwie tausend Gründe drin, warum dein Programm auf jeden Fall durchfallen kann und dann, wie es doch auch noch vielleicht durchfallen könnte und dann steht drin, wenn irgendwas hier nicht zutrifft, dann heißt es noch lange nicht, dass dein Programm nicht dafür sorgt, dass wir uns eine neue Regel ausdenken.
Also sie sagen so in etwa, dass das ein wachsendes Dokument und dein App kann der Grund sein, warum dieses Dokument um einen Punkt erweitert wird.
Ich denke, dass das Dokument so ein bisschen den Ton trifft. Also man weiß jetzt zumindest, auf welcher Ebene man da irgendwie...
Es ist plötzlich nicht mehr... Ich glaube, es ist für viele Entwickler einfach nicht mehr diese Wand, in die man so rennen muss, sondern die sagen halt... Ich meine, da kann man jetzt geteilter Meinung drüber sein, aber...
Wand mit einer Matratze.
Naja, sie erläutert es zumindest. Ist kein Gel mehr, es ist genau so. Und schön soft wieder von der Wand wegbauen. Und sie haben irgendwie so eine Schlichtungskommission eingerätet. War das? Täusche ich mich.
Genau. Wenn du abgelehnt wirst, dann kannst du da eben auch so richtig schön um Gnade winzeln.
Aber die Sprache war halt irgendwie eigentlich das Highlight von diesen Guidelines, oder? Also irgendwie... Ja, und wenn du uns hier in der Öffentlichkeit disternst, kannst du gleich nach Hause gehen. Also es war ja schon echt auch in Steve's Peak, ne?
Also ich finde, das Problem ist, was du da mit deinem Bumper hast. Ich hab hier keinen Sand in meinem Bumper bekommen. Wahrscheinlich warst du mit deinem Kit auf dem Spielplatz.
Hast du gesehen, wie das bei mir aussieht?
Ja, bei mir ist das überhaupt gar nicht so.
Naja, also auch rundherum bist du richtig ätzig.
Ja, du hast bestimmt was im Sandkasten, könnte ich schwören.
Na Sandbox heißt das. Tja, hätte ich mal einen Jailbreak gemacht.
So, jetzt ist das Thema mäßig. Was geht ab jetzt?
Developer Guidelines. Was hatten wir vorher?
Bei Airprint waren wir. Da müsste jetzt auch Airplay kommen. Du hast doch jetzt hier auf deinem Device installiert.
Bei Airplay, da geh ich echt ab. Ich hab versucht, ich war noch nicht wieder im Apple Store. Ich musste ja wieder mein Current-Batch von iPhone-Headphones aus Headset austauschen. Die Dinger gehen ja schneller kaputt, als man Pap sagen kann.
Wie die weißen Kabel hier, oder was? Die gehen ja dauernd kaputt.
Ja, aber wirklich per......ma nennt. Das waren drei. Ich hab dieses Jahr schon vier durchgebracht. Vier. Drei davon.
Ja, aber so ist es halt.
Ja, aber ich bitte, warum fangen die an zu scheppern?
Warst du halt im Sandkasten?
Ja.
Du hättest deine Headphones beim Bass rummachen müssen.
Ich bin so unausgeschlafen. Was wollten wir jetzt gerade sehen? Ich war im Apple Store, ich hab die Dinger ausgetauscht und das ist toll, dass das so unproblematisch geht.
Ja klar, kostet ja auch nichts.
Und dann dachte ich mir, wenn ich eh schon da bin, nehm ich doch gleich so ein Apple TV mit. Und dann wurde mir erst gewahrt, dass das ja noch gar nicht im Verkauf ist.
Hat das so einen da gehabt oder nicht? Hat das da gehabt oder nicht?
Das ist ja schlecht.
Da wollte ich so einen kleinen schwarzen Apple TV mitnehmen.
Mir wurde gerade gesagt, Apple tauscht das iPhone aus, wenn aufgrund des Bumpers Kratzer entstehen. Ernsthaft? Na schön.
Schau mal, ich hab ein neues iPhone.
Was muss ich da reinmachen, damit ich Kratzer kriege?
Ist deins wieder kaputt?
Nö, aber ein neues kommt doch mal gut. Ich hab die Antenne jetzt mal gefixt.
Mhm, bestimmt.
Was denn an der Antenne kaputt, die funktioniert? Die ist anwandfrei, da gibt es überhaupt keine Probleme mit.
Ja, aber nur wenn du neben der Basisstation stehst.
Ich hab mit der Antenne keine Probleme.
Max bewirbt sich bei Apple TV.
Ja klar, hier in der Stadt nicht, aber mach mal ne Motorradtour. Ich hab immer no service.
Wo ich jetzt gerade Apple TV erwähne, was es leider nicht gibt, aber was ich bestellt habe, erstmal, dass ich was vorbestellt habe bei Apple, weil sie das unbedingt haben, ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht.
Hast du das schon geliked im Ping?
Ich like dann, wenn du das likst. Das ist auch schön. Ein Lick. So ein Lick-Button wäre doch mal ganz hübsch.
Das kommt niemals durch den Röhrgeprüf.
Ein Lick.
Hier wieder Web-Developer-Opportunity.
Weiter, weiter, weiter.
Apple TV bestellt und dann Kopfhörer gewechselt und weiter.
Und dann habe ich viel darüber nachgedacht, wie sie sich das gerade so gedacht hat, mit diesem Airplay und dem Apple TV und so. Und es ist ja viel darüber geredet worden, was dieses Apple TV wieder alles nicht hat und so, was verloren hat an Features, bzw. diese ganze Klappdase mit dem Verleihen und so weiter. Ist wieder weniger geworden. Aber irgendwie ist das Ding ja was ganz anderes. Eigentlich ist das neue Apple TV mehr denn je.
Ist eine Express-Station, dass du Video auch noch können.
Es ist einfach ein Wireless-Doc für dein iPad, um auf dein Fernseher was anzuzeigen. So sehe ich das so ein bisschen.
Also eine aufgebohrte Express mit Videofunktionalität.
Genau. Und das führt ja dazu, dass du jetzt mit dem iPhone und mit dem iPhone also alles, was du an Video-Content und an Audio-Content hast, kannst du, wenn das alles funktioniert, auf deinen Fernseher schicken sofort.
Finally!
Du singst dir so eine HD-Movie auf dein iPhone.
Hast du gehört, ja, welchen Fernseher?
Ich habe gar keine Fernseher.
Man müsste das an sein Cinema Display streamen können.
Oder dein Beamer.
Also dein HDMI-großer Bildschirm-Device. Was auch immer das ist, die Kino-Installation zu Hause. Wo du aber immer nicht so richtig rankommst mit Kabel und so weiter. Ich habe auch so ein 10 Meter HDMI-Kabel da bei mir liegen, nur damit ich da mal meinen Laptop anschließen kann. Irgendwie kommt mir das total awkward vor. Eigentlich würde ich lieber mein iPhone aus der Tasche nehmen und einfach sagen, schick, dahin. Genau das wird dann gehen im November.
Richtig geil würde ich das ja finden, wenn das dann auch Third-Party-Content kann.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wenn der Beamer das gleich, das Feature kann. Du stellst den Beamer hin und der...
Naja, das haben sie ja angekündigt.
Das wird ja auch kommen.
Denon will Receiver rausbringen.
Das waren die mit dem 500 Euro Ethernet-Kabel. Für Audio viele Jungs.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich Monster, oder?
Ich hoffe, dass sie nicht die einzigen bleiben. Es gab häufiger schon Programme, wo Apple versucht hat, Party mit einzubinden. Das hat mal geklappt und mal nicht.
Früher und so, aber inzwischen klappt es.
Inzwischen klappt es ganz gut. Ich denke, dass hinter dem iPad genug Power ist.
Und gerade, wenn man sich so iEdgy anguckt, das läuft ja auch ganz brillant, offensichtlich.
So, jetzt mal Spaß dabei. Jetzt mal Spaß bei Seite.
Wo ist die Spaß bei Seite-Taste? Das ist der Home-Ball.
Also wir haben noch drei Tasten frei und wir haben auch noch hier dieses Fadenkreuz da oben. Also können die Hörer sich ja auch noch mal ein paar Ideen einfallen lassen.
Das hackt man schon in der Sendung, dass die Hörer sich was einfallen lassen können.
Nee, welche Tasten man hier noch belegen könnte. Mit was?
Man kann auch noch Kombinationen, dass du so zwei Sachen gleichzeitig triffst.
Auf dem Fadenkreuz könnte man ein Soundboard machen, also sozusagen deine Lieblings vier...
Kontroll Alt A.
Deine Lieblings vier Sounds kannst du einstellen. Genau. Und dann hast du die da so auf dem Fadenkreuz. Aber so Plus und Minus und Home ist noch offen.
Ich glaube, so ein Soundboard ist nur für Leute lustig, die vor Ort sind und nicht für Leute, die sich das anhören.
Die Hörer sind total genervt. Aber ist ja auch unsere Jubiläums-Sendung. Ja, wir feiern jetzt.
Für euch gibt es heute nichts zu feiern.
Unser Kuchen, der hier nicht ist. Ich muss ja sagen, wir hatten ja fairerweise von den Jungs von Mc Einsteiger, hatten wir ja noch Schuki geschickt bekommen, die dann allerdings meine Kids aufgefressen haben.
Das ist jetzt echt ein Dauner. Ich hab schon...
Lass uns mal lieber weiter über den Appair reden.
Ich hab schon den Laden ausfindig gemacht, wo man diese Schuki bestellen kann. Ich wollte sie eigentlich kaufen, aber die haben halt eine Bestellzeit von mehreren Wochen, weil das halt handgeschützt ist. So ist ganz cool. Ich guck dir mal so einen ganzen Tipp nebenbei. chokri.de Das ist total cool.
Jetzt muss man hier die 1 drücken.
Hab's schon.
Genau. Da kannst du dir deine eigene Schokolade zusammenklicken und dann bestellen.
Das sind hier diese Prenzlberg-Fangirls, die ihren Kindern Handgeschöpft sind.
4 Wochen vorbestellt, als Schokolade so...
meinen Mitpodcastern.
Ach so, für uns jetzt.
Für dich hatte ich die Chili-Wasabi-Doppel-Plus-Variante rausgesucht.
Das klingt nach Tränen.
Die war auch in dem Paket und ich kann dir sagen, das ging schon ganz schön ans Eigenmachte.
Bei den Kindern bestimmt.
King Kong died for your sins, man.
Ich will eine 4,5 Kilo Toblerone haben.
Airplay.
Wenn wir hier so viel Schokolade essen, während der Sendung, das ist nicht gut. Das hatten wir schon mal. Das war ein einziges Geschmatz hier. Ach so, die Schmatztaste, die wird das etwas verhindern. Aber wenn du dann anfängst zu reden, dann zieht das ja alles, das ist ja widerlich.
Und dann staubt sie wieder alles voll.
Ja, das zieht Fäden.
Aber sag mal, Airplay ist das etwas komplett Neues?
Oder ist es wirklich kompatibel auch mit den alten Express-Stationen?
Ich denke mal, dass sie die Kompatibilität mit den alten Express-Stationen sofern waren, als dass sie sie weiterhin unterstützen, zumindest den Items.
Also der Zeuge beruft sich hier auf Hörensagen?
Auf meine Intuition.
Also ich würde mal sagen, man kann für 149 Euro ein Upgrade machen auf eine neue Airport-Express-Station.
Ich rechne nicht mit einem Upgrade.
Aber ist es dann auch eine Basis-Station? Weil das wär's nämlich. Warum machen die nicht mal so ein bisschen was? Ich will nicht 20 Geräte haben. Ich hab ja nicht dagegen, mal so ein bisschen ein teureres Gerät zu haben. Aber dann will ich meine alte Express auch irgendwie weghaben.
Das ist so ein reoccurring-Thema. Das Ding, über die wir uns schon so oft bestellt haben. Zum Beispiel eine Airport Extreme, die wirklich extrem ist und einfach alles drin hat.
Ja genau, weil da ist überhaupt gar nichts extrem bei denen.
Was heißt extrem? Heißt ja nicht, dass es alles hat. Was du haben willst, ist die Airport Ultra.
Ich merk schon, Airport wird langsam zu dem Windows 7.
Es ist doch jetzt alles Air.
Was?
Man braucht eine Time Capsule und man braucht irgendwie ein Ding, was Express irgendwie kann.
Und Mac Mini, der das alles ansteuert.
Ja, aber das ist doch alles absolut okay, weil ich meine, dahinten kommt der Telefonkabel aus der Wand. Du willst doch nicht den Fernseher neben dir das Telefonkabel stellen, bloß damit da deine Airport Ultra dran geht.
Über die du dann Schoki bestellen kannst.
Ich würde das machen.
Also ich würde auch gerne eines in einem haben. Haben wir auch schon oft genug zu Protokoll gegeben, aber scheinen wir halt bei Apple immer noch keiner zu.
Es gibt ja jetzt zumindest die Möglichkeit, ich weiß ja nicht, wie ihr Lizenzierungsprogramm aussieht, aber offensichtlich hat Third Party die Möglichkeit, in diese Airplay- Infrastruktur einzuklinken.
Die können den Chip kaufen.
Genau, wenn du da einmal hingehst, die Hosen runterlässt, 23 Verträge unterschreibst und noch 79 Dollar pro Monat überweist, bestimmt.
Nee, die können den Chip kaufen. Das ist irgendwie das wichtige. Also die können von dieser Bude, von dieser Bude, die den Namen ich jetzt vergessen habe, diesen Krypto-Chip, der dafür zuständig ist. Ist das nicht ein Krypto? Ist das nicht auch Krypto?
Also ich hatte letztes Mal schon meine Vermutung geäußert und ich bleibe dabei, dass das Ganze im wesentlichen HTTP-Streaming ist, plus irgendwie metadata-foo, damit dieser ganze Klimpim wie Trick, Schnas, Fernbedienung und so weiter alles...
Da sage ich, da kommt nochmal DRM drauf.
Ist doch schon. Also die machen auch da schon Krypto. Die holen sich den Key von der Express, schicken den zurück, verschlüsseln es damit und schicken es dann wieder hin.
Bei der Express machen sie das. Meinst du, die machen es bei Airplay auch?
Bestimmt. Wenn es doch kompassibel ist, muss es doch so gehen. Hast du keine Express hier oder was?
Ja, sonst müsste man es ja gar nicht groß lizenzieren. Stimmt.
Hast du eine Express?
Könnte durchaus sein. Ich habe eine Express.
Hier?
Ja, unterm Tisch.
Na, dann müsstest du jetzt mit deinem iPad gehen, oder nicht?
Achso.
Womit? Achso, ich meine...
Wo ist das?
Mit iTunes. Aber ich sehe in iTunes hier nix.
Oh nein, da haben sie jetzt auch im iTunes fürs iPad diesen... Ist das schon immer so? Echt, im iPad?
Gut, dass jetzt alle wissen, worüber wir reden. Das ist der Lautstärkeregler. Der muss ja so ein bisschen dicker sein. Der sieht doch eher so bei... Ich dachte, der sieht bei iTunes eher so ein bisschen aus.
Achso, du hast jetzt auch schon die neue Version.
Genau, das ist jetzt auch ein 42er drauf.
Ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Was jetzt sehr lustig ist, das jetzt der... Aber das könnte man jetzt auch schon wissen.
Hast du schon mal Airplay gemacht mit dem Ding jetzt?
Nee, ich hab ja nicht schon mit... Ich hab Airprint gemacht.
Also ich sehe hier in diesem iTunes, also in dieser iPod Up auf dem iPad, das ist aber auch wirklich mittlerweile ein Foo. Da ist keine Auswahl für Air......Tunes.
Airsterne.
Airplay meinst du?
Ich habe ja nur AirTunes-Devices. Also die AirPod X.
Irgendwo habe ich da mal einen Screenshot gesehen, wie das aussehen sollte, theoretisch.
Da blickt doch keiner mehr durch.
Vielleicht ist das hier einfach noch gar nicht so drin.
Langsam gehen hier die Buchstaben aus.
Und fürs iPhone kommt das dann auch her? Also ich hab's mir jetzt nicht installiert, weil das ist mir zu danger für mein Productiv-Telefon, weil ich sie ganz wichtig brauche immer.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich drucken kann.
Und haben sie dir denn 4 iPhone-Headsets replaced?
Hat er doch schon gesagt.
Ja, haben sie dir den Sack einfach gegeben.
Jaja, ne, da reden die gar nicht drüber. Wenn du da irgendwie Apple Care hast oder Gewährleistung normale noch, dann kriegst du einfach neu.
Ja, wann kriegen wir jetzt endlich in Berlin mal so ein fucking Apple Store?
Wir sind ja hier in Ostdeutschland und...
Ne, also du jetzt hier schon und ich wohne da auch, aber der wohnt in Westdeutschland.
Echt?
Na bitte dich, West-Berlin ist ja wohl in Westdeutschland.
Auf jeden.
Ihr wart die Eingemauerten, jawoll.
Ja nicht, der kommt da gar nicht von hier.
Den gab's doch gar nicht.
Lass mich da raus, wir haben Spaß, Max ist unser Quotenzoni, der kann das beantworten.
Quotenzoni, der ist auch ein Quotenzoni.
Also ich zeige es dir.
Das stimmt.
Das sind beides Quotenzonis.
Quotenzonis, der aber jetzt im Westen geflohen ist.
Na, aber Kreuzberg ist ja eigentlich auch ganz schön Osten.
Gut, das interessiert jetzt bestimmt keinen hier, unsere lokalen Berliner Stadtteilfäden. Jetzt bin ich zum Wiederholten mal ein bisschen aus der Spur. Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen? Ich wollte, also wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, ich könnte mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen, dass mit diesen 99 Euro, ne stimmt ja gar nicht, 119 Euro Device Apple TV, hat man einfach sozusagen ein universelles iPod Touch, iPhone, gute Gute, iPad zu HDMI, großer Bildschirm Device, Interface mit ohne Kabel. Das ist sozusagen das, was jetzt kommt. Ja, aber für nur 120 Euro kannst du mit all deinen iDevices mal eben beliebigen Content auf den Big Screen bringen. Ich meine, das Elend im Club, ja? Chaos Computer Club. Seit wieviel Jahren versuchen die da irgendwie einen Computer hinzustellen, der in der Lage ist, einfach mal ein Bild auf dem Beamer abzuspielen, diese ganzen Linux-Experimente, diese fortwährende Dauer Fail.
Aber das hab ich mir vielleicht weg. Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, als ich das mir gewünscht habe von Apple, da hatte ich dieses XBMC auf diesem Revo drauf und dann die entsprechende Fernbedienung für Android dafür. Und damit konnte man nämlich genau das schon damals machen, dass man im Browser irgendwie ein Video angeklickt hat und dann hat er gefragt, willst du es nicht mit XBMC aufmachen, dann hast du es auf dem Fernseher gesehen. Und jetzt kann er es endlich erklären.
Aber das Video ist nicht auf dem Android-Phone, sondern das muss da halt auf dem Device liegen.
Nee, er hat die URL rübergegeben.
Also passen, dann zieht er sich das übers Netz per...
Also im Browser nehme ich mal an, dass er es einfach per HTTP gemacht hat. Ich weiß nicht, was passiert wäre mit Content, obwohl ich hab auch so, ich hab das TED-Programm, mit dem hab ich es auch ausprobiert. Ich weiß nicht, ob das das runterlädt oder so. Auf jeden Fall konnte ich dann, also direkt war der, ich hab ein Video angeklickt und ich konnte es auf dem Fernseher sehen und hab gesagt, ey, ich hab hier ein Apple-TV und ich hab hier ein iPhone und ich hab hier ein iPad und ich hab hier ein Alles-iPad, alles scheiß Dreck, warum geht das eigentlich nicht? Und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt sieht es so aus, als ob es langsam gehen könnte.
Ja, aber es gibt, bei Apple gab es schon so oft irgendwie so die Momente, wo man dachte, ja, endlich und dann kam es raus und dann war das irgendwie so, nur so, so halber so ping oder so, so Fail-Time-mäßig.
Endlich ein Social-Network von Apple und dann wird es wieder erwartend.
Wobei, also Fail-Time funktioniert für mich meistens noch ganz okay.
Das hatten wir ja letztens schon festgestellt.
Für mich funktioniert es auch super, ich habe es noch nie probiert.
Also ich hoffe ja auch, dass du dann irgendwie so Dinge löst und so, aber naja.
So, ja auf jeden Fall mit dem Print haben sie alles richtig gemacht. Also da kann man sogar aus dem Web-Browser, es gibt ja so diese Window-JavaScript-Funktion, window.print. Also ich habe ein Projekt, was sehr gut auf dem iPad laufen könnte und was aber zwingend fast eine Druckfunktion braucht. Und darum habe ich das als allererstes getestet. Und man kann direkt aus der Seite window.print aufrufen und dann kommt dieser Druckendialog und alles ist schön. Das haben sie wirklich schee gemacht. Und CSS-Unterstützung für Print auch, also dass man Media-Paketen geben kann.
Was mir gerade einfällt bei dem iOS 4.2, die geilste Änderung, dieser Schalter, der Schalter am iPad ist wieder ein Mute-Schalter, wie er ursprünglich mal gedacht war.
Das ist echt ganz praktisch.
Und der Screen-Log ist jetzt in Software so wie auf dem iPhone. Bloß, dass du halt auch in Landscape locken kannst. Da bin ich ein ganz, ganz großer Freund von dieser Änderung, weil das...
Mute-Schalter, Mute-Schalter.
Na, du hast beim iPad an der Seite so einen Hardware-Schalter. Das ist derzeit das Rotation-Log.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Und jetzt ist es halt nicht mehr. Jetzt ist es halt ein Mute.
Genauso wie auf dem iPhone.
Genauso wie auf dem iPhone. Weil es gab nämlich vorher überhaupt gar keine Mute-Funktion, was echt nervt. Weil dieses Ding hat hier lieber so rumgeklippert, irgendwelche Pushs. Ja, aber leise machen und Mute ist einfach was anderes. Jetzt kannst du das Ding einfach ausschalten, gibt es keine Töne mehr von sich.
Doch, das ist schon eine Mute-Funktion.
Und wenn du halt locken willst, dann machst du halt hier irgendwie Doppel-Click und dann kannst du eben hier per einem Touch das irgendwie...
So wie beim iPhone.
Und bloß, dass du jetzt eben auch in Landscape locken kannst, was ich hoffe, dass sie das auch bitte, bitte, bitte auf dem iPhone auch machen. Weil ich will den in Landscape locken.
Achso, da kann man ein bisschen nur ein Portrait locken, ne?
Ja. Das nervt einfach, weil man will halt mal Videos, einfach das Bettproblem einfach. Dass sie das nach drei Jahren irgendwie immer noch nicht gelöst bekommen haben, das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Und wann kann man jetzt endlich mal telefonieren mit dem iPad?
Haha. Na, mit Skype.
FaceTime geht nicht mit dem Ding. Ne, er geht keine Kamera, verstehe.
Das wird aber bestimmt kommen.
Ich will ja mal hoffen, dass mal langsam FaceTime Audio Only kommt. Braucht gar kein Video, so unbedingt.
Gibt es da nicht irgendeinen Trick, mit dem man das machen kann, wenn man dann irgendwie...
Mit J-Break bestimmt.
Na, du kannst auch... Wenn du den Call aufgebaut hast, kannst du einfach aus der App, die kannst du nun rausgehen, dann hast du nur noch das Audio.
Aber wird dann dein Video-Bild noch übertragen, oder ist das...
Weiß ich nicht.
Aber...
Nee, ich dachte, es gibt irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass wenn man dann die Tastensperre aktiviert und ein Headset aufhat, dass es dann tatsächlich die Video-Verbindung abgebrochen wird und man nur noch eine Audio-Verbindung hat.
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ob der noch das Video überträgt.
Bestimmt. Schwarz übertragen ist immer noch was, aber fast nichts. Aber trotzdem, ich will so ein Audio-Only.
Das muss ich nur mal ausprobieren.
Und dann natürlich auch über UMTS natürlich. Also nicht nur mit WLAN, sondern dass es eigentlich immer geht.
Und über GSM.
Ist ein bisschen dünn dann.
Du möchtest einfach bloß kostenlos telefonieren.
Und das wird doch kommen, die werden. Apple wird dann irgendwann dem AT&T-Jungs und allen anderen einfach denen den Finger zeigen und sagen, wir machen jetzt ja unser eigenes Network.
Hoffen wir's mal. Ich hab ja im Augenblick eher die Befürchtung, dass es in die andere Richtung geht, dass AT&T uns so sagen, und jetzt nehmen wir nochmal für YouTube extra Geld und jetzt nehmen wir dafür nochmal extra Geld und jetzt nehmen wir Telekom macht dann freundlich mit und dann...
Kann schon sein, dass sie es auch so wollen, aber das wird dann natürlich auch, Apple wird das richtig teuer bezahlen lassen.
Ja, das ist mir scheißegal, ob Apple sich das teuer bezahlen lässt.
Für mich ist es scheiße.
Jetzt brauchen wir nochmal ein richtiges Knallerthema, um die Stimmung wieder richtig hochzuziehen, oder?
Die neuen Nokia-Telefone.
Ich will kurz mal Spam machen, wenn wir hier gerade so eine kreative Pause haben.
Und zwar meine Kumpels haben schon wieder ein neues Spiel programmiert, diesmal fürs iPad Only. Heißt Bugs Invasion. Ich poste mal den Link in den Chat. Und da geht es darum, dass da so Roboter-Bugs kommen, die man mit seinem eigenen irgendwie abschießen muss und mehrere Level und Achievements und Features und...
Game Center?
Bugs Upgrade. Ich weiß nicht, ob es schon Game Center Support hat. Ich find Game Center gar nicht so schlecht.
Ach jetzt darf er.
Die benutzen eher Open Faint natürlich noch. Aber Open Faint will ja Game Center integrieren.
Haben sie gesagt, aber nicht wie?
Nee.
Aber könnt ihr euch mal angucken. Bugs Invasion mit Bugs mit Z.
Ich hab noch keine Freunde auf Fail Center.
Echt? Na komm her, komm, ich mach dich.
Mein Nickname sag ich dir nicht, ich muss es selber rauskriegen. Aber du kannst dich nicht über meine E-Mail-Adresse nennen.
Hast du dir wieder eine total geheime E-Mail-Adresse angegeben?
Also, wer mein Freund sein will in Fail Center, probier's mit dimitbrittler auf.org.
Das war gar keine Freundin, das kann aber nicht wahr sein.
Na, jetzt kannst du dich nicht mehr retten.
Menschenskinder hier.
Es gibt 6.000 Dinger.
Ich hab schon 20 oder irgendwie sowas. Obwohl ich noch nicht einmal was gespielt hab.
Was hast du für ein Nick, die du registriert hast?
Mein Gamer-Nick.
Echt? Warum war der denn dein Alten hier? Wie war das? The Commander? Nee, das war irgendwas anderes.
Aber wir haben über Game Center schon geredet. Habt ihr in der letzten Sendung bestimmt gemacht, oder? Aber das Interface ist ja auch mal irgendwie grottenschlecht, oder?
Über Game Center haben wir glaube ich nicht geredet. Findest du? Ich hab nicht so viel Erfahrung mit solchen Spielevermittlungsdiensten. Aber dieses Open Find fand ich immer ganz furchtbar. Open Find ist wirklich genau der richtige Name dafür. Ein offener Feind.
Ich mag halt, also wie wenn ich mit dem One Password Pro bin, diese tausend von Passwörtern für jedes Spiel, die irgendwie Cloud Sell, Open Find und was weiß ich nicht, alles haben immer diese ganzen Passwörter mir merken zu müssen, habe ich immer keinen Bock. Und Game Center ist wenigstens integriert mit meiner Apple ID, die hab ich eh, dann das ist irgendwie cool.
Die werden uns noch alle ownen mit dieser Apple ID.
Ist doch schon, bin doch eh schon ein Opfer.
Über mein Ping-Profil kriegen sie auch Tage noch aus, was ich die ganze Zeit mache.
Muss ich hier nicht eine Notification bekommen? Pusht allen das nicht irgendwie zur Tode?
Org? Ich hab die eh...
Und er könnte mir ja auch mal meine Open Friend Request anzeigen. Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich es schon richtig gemacht hab.
Ich dachte, der haut einen dann so push...
Ja, macht er. Hier, Max hat es gerade geschafft bei mir, aber du hast mit einem Nick gesucht, oder wie?
Und jetzt...
Dennis2342. Das ist...
Könnt ihr voll vergessen. Huckel ist übrigens als Huckel drin, ne?
Hab ich schon gesagt.
Ich hab mir schon gestellt.
Ich glaub, wir müssen gleich alle auf Silent schalten.
Das wird nicht so schlimm.
Ich bin schon auf Silent, aber ich krieg hier trotzdem keine Request.
Ich find Tim auch nicht mit der...
Jetzt geht's los.
Bei Flight Control mach ich euch sowieso alle.
Ich bin so ein Loser.
Jetzt kommen sie alle.
Ich hab's gewusst.
Also an dich ging einer.
Von mir müsste jetzt was kommen, langsam.
Kann das sein, dass du dich einfach unter einer anderen E-Mail-Adresse angehört hast?
Ach da, bei Plus war der hier.
Man, jetzt aber hier ein Sturm ab, bei Apples sind gerade die Server überlastet. Die kamen hier gerade fünf Stück hintereinander.
Dann kann ich gleich mal im Soundboard auch gleich mal sammeln, das Teil.
Das Teil ist eine alte Sau.
Jetzt hast du mal was zu tun.
Und wir können jetzt alle dennächst wissen, wann die Sendung gepusht wurde von Timme, weil dann klingelt es gleich nochmal wie Sau.
Genau, weil die in...
Ich mach mal silent hier. Lass die mal in die Ecke legen jetzt.
Aber bei mir, also Fail Center, es wird bei mir alle Anforderungen und es fehlt total. Ich kann gerade gar nichts tun.
Ich hab dir geschickt.
Jungs, ihr braucht mich gerade nicht erdieren. Ich hab eh nur ein Spiel erst mal bisher.
Ich hab nur einen Friend und der wird noch nicht mal angezeigt.
Also Jungs, ihr habt ja gehört, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, was los ist.
Also hier kommen genug Friends rein.
Ich bin allein mit meinen drei Spielen.
Oh, jetzt kommen hier nochmal drei.
Mit denen ich der totale Loser bin, ja.
Dann füg mich doch einfach mal hinzu.
Ich bin sehr geil, man kann jetzt hier...
Ich bin Friends, ihr braucht mich überhaupt gar nicht zu frienden, weil ich bin so ein Loser. Ach so, wenn man jemand braucht zum Besiegen, wa? Na geil.
Ich hab selber erst... Mein Status ist, spiele nicht. Spiele nicht? Also dass ich nicht spiele.
Aber bist du wirklich timatpritzler.org?
Ja, bist du sicher?
Bist du nicht timatpritzler.com?
Vielleicht.
Also, weil kommt da nichts an anscheinend.
Das steht hier auf dem Bildschirm.
So, was? Huckel deinen Job!
Bad Pritt, ich wiederhole. Lass mich doch mal tippen hier kurz, Jungs.
Oh, jetzt gehts hier aber auch los gerade.
Mal so ein bisschen...
Send.
So, dann jetzt mal alle hier Bad Pritt.
Sehr unterhaltsam. Und krass, wie wir unsere sozialen Desknerkommunikation betreiben hier.
Beim nächsten Mal könnt ihr gucken, wie wir Twittern.
Ich hab noch zwei Freunde. Und ich kann mir noch nicht mal anzeigen, dass es welche sind. Weiß ich nicht, ich bin einfach durch.
Du bist raus.
Du bist echt raus.
Dennis darf jetzt hier irgendwie...
Ich bin jetzt schon bei 14 Leuten. Also bei 14 Leuten, die auch Flight-Controller haben. Wahrscheinlich sind es noch viel mehr.
Angeber.
Hucke ist so ein Arsch.
Also ich bin jetzt bei 20.
Angeber ihr. Mit euren vielen Freunden. Und sind da irgendwelche Frauen dabei, Dennis?
Alles. Nur Frauen. Die haben mich gar nicht durchgelassen.
22.
Blackhole85 ist auch eine Frau.
86.
Aber bis auf hier der Brody, der hier der Hardcore-Gamer ist und auch schon hier Chirp Chirp gezockt hat, wie einfach der Klop da, der ist auch da auf dem ersten, sind alle hier weit ab von irgendwie gut.
Kannst du mir nochmal sagen, wie dieses Game, was du da geplackt hast, wie das heißt? Mach mal den Ton aus.
Ich wollte nur zeigen, wie cool ich bin.
Der, der Kraft macht, ist immer der Coolste.
Bugs Invasion. B-U-G-Z.
Ach so, mit Z. Dann kann man das ja nie finden.
Das Soundboard ist kaputt.
Ist das nur toll, weil es von deinen Freunden ist?
Das ist nur toll, weil es von meinen Freunden ist. Die haben sich Mühe gegeben, da gibt es Cutscenes mit 3D-Videos und so weiter. Logisch, abzocken kommt später beim Nachkaufen.
Das ist die alte Hacker-Ethik.
Der ist ja ganz fleißig.
Die machen auch schon gerade wieder ein neues Spiel. Ich hab doch gesagt, nennt doch euer Company ein App pro Monat.
Warum haut der das kostenlos raus?
Weil anders hast du keine Chance mehr in dem vollen Markt.
Die sind gerade auf dem iPad.
Du hast zwei Levels for free und wenn du das dann haben willst, musst du das kaufen. In-App-Purchase.
In-App-Purchase.
Katze im Sack.
Als ehemaliger Drogen-Gelad. Erst anfixen und dann abkassieren.
Wieso ist HP ja auch groß geworden?
Nobody has sent me an invitation.
Was ist das, das Soundboard ist gestorben? Funktioniert nicht mehr?
Achso, wahrscheinlich hast du das hier umgeschaltet. Ich dachte, das kann sein.
In der nächsten Sendung lese ich hier alle Game-Sender typisch vor. Dann kriegen die das auch alle.
Das ist gut, ja.
Max, wie war deine Blackwell 86?
Ah, hier Skyhawk hat Google verklagt.
Stimmt, warum das eigentlich? Das hab ich nicht verstanden.
Na ja, weil Google jetzt auch sowas macht wie Skyhawk und das finden sie nicht lustig.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt relativ wenig Grund für eine Klage, oder?
Auf Basis von was verklagt?
Na, Google macht ja jetzt auch so Geo-Service. Erfunden Gesetzen. Und die, warte, was steht hier bei Gruber? Skyhawk claims Google costs tens of millions of dollars by trying to cut in on its contract with Motorola.
So, ich suche jetzt mal hier in der Heise-Seite. Das ist nämlich für mich tatsächlich eines der wirklich praktischen neuen Features im iOS 4.2.
Kann sein, dass du erst mal ein Spiel starten musst, was Game Center benutzt, sonst geht das nämlich nicht.
Hab ich schon.
Echt?
Du meinst jetzt in diesem Moment, um Freunde anzunehmen?
Na, damit auch das Spiel in deinem Game Center gelöstet wird. Das hast du schon mal gemacht, ja?
Ja.
Zumindest die, von denen ich jetzt weiß.
Welches hast du denn? Hast du Flight Control mit drin? Ich hab ja erst mal nur Flight Control, ich wundere mich, warum du nicht kommst.
Mach mal einen Neustart. Und dann klingelt's richtig.
Fail Center.
Volles Mett.
Das eben lief's und dann kamen wir.
Was echt komisch ist, was Dennis mir auch erst sagen musste, dass diese Banner hier, dass das Buttons sind. Ehrlich? Interessant. Aber auch nicht alle.
Ich find ja diesen Gold-Effekt da unten ganz knuffig. Hier unten diese, diese, in der Leiste.
Also, was haben wir denn hier noch auf der Themenliste?
Eine Menge.
Ich wollt ja auch noch Werbung für ein Programm machen, ne?
Dann mal los.
Hier, Hocker, ne?
Schon wieder?
Hab ich noch nie auf der Sendung gemacht, hab ich immer danach gemacht.
Bestimmt. Ja, aber mach trotzdem.
Kann man so witzig, so schamlos.
Wir haben jetzt sogar Affiliate-Links.
Oh, nobody, der Typ hat einen Eiken, warum hab ich keinen Eiken hier?
Was, man kann einen Eiken setzen?
Jetzt hab ich ihn ausgemacht.
Alle aus dem Chat müssen sich dieses Hocker mal installieren und ausprobieren.
Das ist ein Smiley.
Ist doch ein Eiken. Das sind einfach so...
Das ist sein Status. Das ist sein Status. Und da hat er so einen, wie heißt es noch, diese Kuschelbilder, diese Emojis, diese japanischen Emojis.
Habt ihr das installiert eigentlich? Mir hat das ja auch, also hier der Robert, mein Kollege, hat mir ja gezeigt.
Wie ist dein Game Center, Nick? Den machen wir fertig.
Tatsache, nach dem Neustart geht es los hier mit Fail Center.
Ich mach das auch mal hier von Fahrer an. Der hat nämlich mir erzählt, dass es eine App gibt, mit der man die Icons freischalten kann, die es nur im asiatischen Raum gibt. Und wenn du diese abinstallierst, dann hast du International Keyboards, in denen nur Smilies und Emoticons drin sind. Ja, das sind diese Emoji-Taserturen. Und du kannst sie auch anzeigen, ohne die abinstalliert zu haben. Also du kriegst Mails, also wenn dir jemand einen Mail oder sonst was mit diesen Emoticons schickt, die kann er schon anzeigen, du kannst sie nur noch nicht selber verwenden.
Was muss man dann noch mal für einschalten, damit man das hat?
Du musst dann abinstallieren.
Emoticon ist eine kostenlose.
Und wer das installiert, der abschaltet das frei sozusagen.
Das sind ja die Metadaten, ich brauche Emoji und ich bin ein japanisches Programm.
Dann hast du international Keyboards und kannst hier die geilsten Icons...
Es gibt einen Haufen Apps, die kassieren dich dafür ab, dass sie diese Funktion freischalten, aber das macht nichts.
Welche heißt die kostenlose?
Emoticon. Emoticon.
Du musst ein bisschen zocken, du bist bei mir auf Platz 10.
Uiuiui, er hat jetzt hier viele chinesische Saturtouren mit 4.1.
Ich hasse ja eigentlich Emoticons, ne?
Das ist das einzige, was ich bei Skype gut finde.
Bist du sicher? Benutze Emoticons in deinen SMS und Mails? Nein, das meinst du nicht. Na, was denkst du, wie das aussieht?
Da sieht so ein Smiley drauf. Zeig doch mal, zeig mal.
Also, die war ja ganz wie kostenlos, ist halt.
Eine, die free heißt. Emoji, nee, das kostet noch nicht Geld. Emoji-Enabler sehe ich hier gerade. Das sieht doch gut aus.
Genau.
Ihr wolltet ja vorhin mit Nokia anfangen.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so spannend, oder?
Android-Bashing hat auch so ein bisschen...
Hat Farbe verloren irgendwie, ne?
Macht jetzt jeder.
Ich würde ganz gerne noch ein bisschen hier Werbung machen für Hardware, die ich mir gekauft habe, die ich euch nur empfehlen kann.
So ein Beispiel?
Dieses kleine Stück Lautsprecher-Hardware, was ich hier auf meinem Tisch hab. Sieht aus so ein bisschen aus wie die alte Apple Airport.
Sieht aus wie Dr. Simon aus Captain Future.
Genau, so ein bisschen UFO-mäßig. Ist so ein rundum... Na, ist nicht wirklich rundum Lautsprecher. Ist halt einfach so ein Lautsprecher. Der ist aber extrem kompakt und super zum Mitnehmen. Kommt in der Tasche mit allen möglichen Kabel- und Anschlussteilen. Hat Audio in und out. Kann man also auch durchschleifen. Hat USB.
Batterie versorgt.
Das heißt, agiert auch als iPhone-Doc. Hat oben sozusagen einen entsprechenden iPod-Stecker, nicht weiter überraschend, aber halt auch normal Audio in. Das heißt, kann es auch mal eben an Laptop anschließen.
Mit Batterieversorgung, oder?
Mit Batterieversorgung. Da kannst du dann so vier, genau, vier AAA Batterien reinhauen. Und kannst aber auch mit dem Netzteil betreiben. Und die machen ganz schön Wumms und klingen ganz ordentlich. Sie sind einfach mega kompakt, sodass man die halt auch nochmal so mit dabei hat. Also wenn ich jetzt so auf Reisen gehe, hab ich die dabei, auch wenn immer so eben so eine kleine Instanz.
Würden die als Ladestation auch irgendwie fungieren, wenn er Strom hat?
Ich glaub nicht, wenn die nur auf Batterien sind.
Ja, das ist klar.
Aber ich glaub, wenn du den Netzteil hast, dann ja.
Und da oben ist so ein Adapter drin, dass man für alle möglichen Geräte, für alle möglichen iPhones, dann irgendwie sich den Adapter reinsteckt.
Ja, wobei da jetzt keine Adapter dabei waren, aber meistens...
Nee, da gibt's doch von Apple diese Adapter halt. Die für das Universum doch irgendwie existiert. Ja klar, kosten 5 Euro.
Ernsthaft? Okay, weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, ob das...
Dann passt dein iPhone 4 da rein?
Weiß ich nicht, ob das kompatibel ist.
Oder dein altes?
Das iPhone 4, das passt da rein. Ja, das kann man da so draufstecken einfach.
Das geht schon.
Und das alte auch, oder was?
Das alte ist 3GS meinste.
Ich hab meins ja heute verkauft.
Ja, echt?
Für wie viel?
Würde ich ja nicht tun.
Für 400.
Ja, korrekter Preis eigentlich.
Ich hab gesagt 400 ohne alle Kabel. Dafür mit so einem zerkratzten Dock, was ich noch hatte.
So, noch mal einer. Apple-Produkte sind teuer.
Dann krieg ich die Kohle nach einem Jahr.
Einfach wieder zurück. Die Hälfte?
Na ja, die Hälfte fast. Bisschen mehr als die Hälfte.
Die Hälfte?
Du kannst 800 Euro dafür bezahlen.
Ne, 700. So wie du.
Aber deine Friend-Requests, die stagnieren trotzdem, ne? Also mach nicht so richtig Alarm.
Also ja, Bad Fred muss die alle noch mal machen.
Ich hab auch gerade noch mal gemacht, aber...
Stimmt, ich hab in letzter Zeit immer so Videofehler in meinem Ding.
Ah, jetzt geht's wieder los, ja.
Ja. Alle vertiefen sich ins Klicken.
Äh, jetzt ist hier gerade ein bisschen viel Halsmaul. Okay, also, dieses Teil hier heißt JBL Onstage Micro. Kostet irgendeine übliche Strafgebühr, ist nicht zu teuer und ist einfach extrem portabel. Kommt halt leicht mit so einem Transportschlüpfer und ist total super. Also vor allem was Geiles, wenn du irgendwo mit dem Laptop bist und willst irgendwie so ein bisschen präsentieren mit Sound und der Sound aus den Lautsprechern rockt einfach nicht. Aber dieses Teil einfach daneben gestellt mit Akku, weißt du nicht groß, noch Steckdose suchen und so einfach hinstellen und du hast da irgendwie Wumms. Auch wenn du so im Hotelzimmer bist oder so, brauchst einfach mal ein bisschen Amplifikation. Toll.
Kann man per USB laden?
Ich bin begeistert. Es gibt wahrscheinlich noch 1000 andere Sachen, aber das war das erste.
Lädt der über Batterie?
Lädt der über USB?
Also er lädt glaube ich nicht über Batterie. Das kann ich ja nochmal kurz testen, aber das würde mich doch extrem überraschen. Nein, das tut er nicht.
Aber was ich ein bisschen... Hey, es geht wieder! Dass da unbedingt diese Warnung kommt, hey, möchtest du dein Gerät in Flugmodus schalten? Also beim iPhone, wenn man es ansteckt?
Wenn man es reinsteckt? Ja, das ist...
Warum gibt es da eigentlich noch nichts für, was dann so darüber nicht in Flugmodus möchte? Wahrscheinlich dann mit Airplay, damit wird das dann alles gehen.
Oh, 42 Friend-Requests.
Das ist eine ordentliche Zahl.
Was? So viel? Ich hab nur 17 hier oder was?
Ernsthaft? Nee, die zählt nicht so ein cooler Gamer.
Ich glaube, die Zahl zählt hier auch viel langsamer hoch.
Ich bin der totale Loser, was diese Games betrifft. Ich sag's dir.
Ja, das fand ich ehrlich gesagt auch bei Ping. Bei Ping hatte ich dann innerhalb von zwei Tagen 200 Friends oder Follower oder wie auch immer das heißt. Und ich werde da wirklich niemals was machen.
Du wirst niemals Freund sein können.
Ich werde niemals euer Freund sein können.
Das muss man ja auch nicht. Du bist ja auch ein Follower-Modell, mein Freund.
Jetzt hier, nächstes Thema.
Ich hab mir Software gekauft.
Was denn für Software?
Software, die ich schon länger eigentlich immer so ein bisschen dabei benutzt hab. Aber diesmal hat es mich einfach total überzeugt wieder. Und zwar Omni-Group. Omni-Graphel. Das muss mal wieder erwähnt werden.
Ich kann das ja zuletzt einfach zu überladen, ehrlich gesagt.
Na ja, kommt drauf an, was man macht. Also ich hatte, ich hab also schon längere Zeit, also ich hab früher so einen Freehand-Guy. Und dann wurde Freehand uns genommen, von Adobe.
Wir Sucker.
Verbrennt. Im Höllenfeuer. Genau, das brauchen wir auch als Soundport.
Allein dafür gehören sie wirklich schon, also das war, erst haben sie mir Framemaker genommen, dann haben sie mir Freehand genommen und dann nerven sie mich die ganze Zeit mit diesem Flash. Wenn sie PDF nicht erfunden hätten.
Na Photoshop noch.
Da bin ich neutral.
Ja, ist okay, aber das war dann auch irgendwann, ich meine heute kann man Photoshop nicht mehr, aber genau, Illustrator, also ging nicht irgendwie als Replacement für Freehand, geht heute noch nicht, wird auch immer schlimmer. Und Photoshop wird eigentlich auch immer schlimmer. Ich kann das ganz gut, aber ich habe davon 0,0001% der Features benutzt im Wesentlichen Resizing. Das Resizing bei Photoshop ist auch super und ich verstehe nicht, warum das noch keiner mal genau so kopiert hat. Verstehe ich nicht. Bilderresizing, das funktioniert einfach so, wie man es erwartet. Es macht die richtigen Defaults und wenn du da irgendwas einträgst, rechnest du das andere aus und es tut einfach das Richtige. Und alle anderen, ich habe mir dann irgendwann mal Archon gekauft.
Ich habe Pixelmater getestet und es geht auch nicht.
Pixelmater ist besser geworden.
Ja, aber das Resizing geht auch noch nicht. Du weißt, was ich meine, das ist gut.
Das geht nicht.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, das musst du mal tun.
Dafür starte ich Photoshop nur zum Resizing.
Ich habe wirklich jahrelang Photoshop wirklich nur zum Resizing von Fotos verwendet und zum Croppen. Und da ist es super.
Also was Photoshop tatsächlich hat, was kein anderes Tool hat, ist, dass man sagen kann Trim, also dass man sagt, auf den Pixel ran, also auf die Pixelfarbe, also alles, was die gleiche Farbe hat wie der linke obere Pixel, wegschneiden, weil das ist so für Webzeug ganz gut, wenn man da was wegschneiden möchte. Das ist eine Funktion, die leider kein anderes Programm hat, aber ansonsten hab ich Photoshop die letzten Jahre wahrscheinlich gestartet, so wenn ich meine Webseite umsetzen musste von irgendjemand anders. Und dann hab ich da die Pipette benutzt. Bestimmt Resize Funktion, Trim und ein bisschen was Ausschneiden. Und bis auf das Trim hat Pixelmater alles mittlerweile.
Ja, nur das Resizen ist scheiße. Und der Color Picker. Color Picker kennen auch die wenigsten komischerweise.
Na, Color Picker hat er mittlerweile einen ganz guten. Was halt bei Photoshop das bessere ist, ist nach wie vor das Messwerkzeug. Also das, wenn man einfach eine Selektion aufzieht, ein Rechteck, dass er dann anzeigt, wie viele Pixel ist die breit und wie viele Pixel ist die hoch. Und das braucht man auch alle drei Minuten.
So total basic Tools, aber die sind da schon immer. Ja, auch schon wahrscheinlich in 2.5 schon drin gewesen. Und das bei Pixelmater nicht.
Die sehen immer noch genauso aus.
Das beruhigt mich ja, dass das bei Acorn auch nicht ist, weil ich dachte dann schon zeitweise, scheiße ich mir jetzt doch das falsche Tool gekauft.
Ne, beide braun. So, und jetzt hatte ich aber das eigentliche Problem war Vector. Ich bin da auch so eher so ein, also nicht so ein richtiger Grafiker, aber ich mach schon mal so meine eigenen Logos. Und ich hab jetzt gerade meinen Metaebene-Logo neu gemacht.
Boah, kann man hier irgendwie die anderen blocken? Hallo.
Ich hab meinen Metaebene-Logo neu gemacht. Und hatte dann einen spezifischen Bedarf, was übrigens mit Illustrator halt geht, als einzigen Programm, so richtig. Das ist das einzige Tool, was PDFs öffnen kann.
Ja, weil dir auch intern ziemlich viel PDFs gibt.
Weil das einfach PDF ist und so weiter. Und wenn du einen PDF hast und du willst an die Elemente da drin ran, dann ist das einfach das Tool of Choice. Und ich hab lange Zeit nichts anderes gefunden, was überhaupt in der Lage war, PDF in seine Elemente zu zerlegen. Omni Graffle Pro kann das auch. Mit Einschränkungen. Ich hab PDFs gefunden, da war das Ergebnis so ein bisschen, mhm. Aber im Wesentlichen hat es funktioniert. Und dann bin ich sehr erstaunt gewesen, ihr habt mich lange nicht mehr näher angeschaut, erstaunt gewesen, wie viele coole Vektor-Elemente da drin sind und wo Graffle halt total überzeugt, dass es halt so dieses Ganze, die Größe richtig treffen, wenn du das Ries heißt und dann diese ganzen, wie bei Kino, diese automatischen Alignment-Linien, die dann so auftauchen und Abstandslinien. Also das ist einfach extrem fluid und du kriegst sehr schnell so Grafiken hin, weißt du, die so passen, die so aneinander passen. Die Rechtecke müssen passen und die Linien müssen passen. Und dann willst du da mal was machen. Du hast aber auch da irgendwie dein Bezierfuh und tralala, es fehlen ein paar Sachen. Du kannst nicht aus einer, was weiß ich, aus einer dicken Linie keine Outline machen und so. Also auch so typische Operationen, die man so braucht, so Pfadoperationen gibt es nicht. Aber dafür ist es halt einfach ein geiles Diagrammtool nach wie vor. Und dann die Pro Variante ist die einzige, die halt PDF konnte. Und dann hab ich mir einfach die Pro Variante mal geschoppt. 200 Tacken. Also schon eine Ausgabe. Aber ich brauchte das. Und ich bin aber wieder erstaunt, was die Omni Group so raushaut. Also die Details, die gibt es schon ewig lang.
Und die machen einfach gute Sachen.
Apple OS X hat.
Next waren die schon unterwegs.
Hat mir jetzt auch der Robert erzählt, dass sie auf dem Next irgendwie überhaupt angefangen haben?
Da kommen die her.
Deswegen war der Omni Web ja auch schon fertig, als Mac OS X kam.
Hat sich eigentlich jemand von euch beasst, den zehn Jahre Mac OS X Public Beta?
Ich bin so rübergeflogen, aber kannte ich ja alles schon. Ich finde nur für Leute interessant, die erst seit Kurzem dabei sind.
War das nicht der gleiche Artikel, den sie vor zehn Jahren schon gebucht hat?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab nicht gelesen.
Das kann ich schon, das ist so alt.
Ich hab sie alle gelesen. Ja, das ist mit Abstand die beste Serie über OS X ever. Gar keine Frage, kann man nur empfehlen. Ja, Twitter für iPad. Wer hat's ausprobiert? Hammer, oder?
Da werden neue User Interfaces designt.
Ja, zum Beispiel die neue Twitter-Homepage.
Das ist krass, die neue Twitter-Homepage sieht exakt aus wie so ein iPad-Ding, oder?
Zeig doch mal her. Genau, und das ist nicht das erste Mal, das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass das passiert. Die Kalender MobileMe Beta bei MobileMe, also die Web-Anwendung für den neuen Kalender, entspricht der iPad-Version. Die sieht genauso aus. So wie der Kalender auf dem iPad aussieht, so sieht Kalender jetzt aus bei MobileMe. Und vorher sah es so aus wie iCal.
Ja, aber das ist noch ein Unterschied.
Ist ja egal. Klar ist das was anderes. Nur was ich damit sagen möchte, ist, dass die iPad-Interaktion und wie man da User-Interface denkt, zieht jetzt ins Web ein. Als vereinfachtes Interface.
Ich glaube, das ist das, weil Twitter fürs iPad...
Ihr sollt das nicht lesen, ihr sollt damit rumspielen.
Wollt ihr meinen Namen ein bisschen rumtwittern hier?
Pen-Status.
Das kennt ihr mit dem Pen-Status? Muss man so ein bisschen im Internet suchen nach Pen-Status. Nein, jetzt weiß ich euch nicht mehr. Wenn Leute ihre Accounts so rumdrehen lassen, dann twittert man den Pen-Status. So was wie Pen-Status down oder so.
Ich hab dir nicht zugehört.
Danke.
Ich hab auch nur dummes Zeug geredet.
Ja, das mach ich jetzt auch wieder. Ein Criderboard. Nee, aber ich find, was ich an diesem iPad-Twitter-App so geil, ist halt dieses, dass man es horizontal sich das in den View schieben kann, was man gerade sehen will. Normalerweise hat man in der Liste immer seine Timeline schon klar. Und wenn man dann irgendwas antippt, dann sieht man dazu dann zum Beispiel zu der Person die entsprechende Information, oder wenn ein Link drin war, dann wird der Link ausgewählt. Und dann kann man das aber alles wieder zurückschieben. Und dieses, dass man ein Informations-View oder so ein Web-View so komplett rüberschieben kann, indem man einfach mit dem Finger drüber zieht, das ist was, wo ich das Gefühl habe, das hat Apple noch, nicht mal Apple ist auf die Idee gekommen, dass man sowas machen könnte.
Du kannst sozusagen im Top-Level was ausgewählt haben, aber trotzdem den Level da drunter rumscrollen.
Jaja, man kommt an alle Elemente noch ran. Und ich hab mal ausprobiert, man kann das ja wirklich ewig weit treiben, also man kann ja immer noch eine Ebene drüber legen und ich hab's nicht geschafft, das irgendwie zum Crashing zu bringen. Es ging immer weiter, dass ich das dann so zurückblättern konnte. Und kennst du das, wenn man hier bei einem Ad-Reply, normalerweise hat man ja öfters mal Probleme, so nachzugucken, worauf bezog sich das jetzt. Jetzt geht man mit zwei Fingern und zieht das ein bisschen runter und dann sieht man den gesamten Dialog dazu, so mal eben als Jalousie, die so rauskommt.
Nein! Nein!
Also, fuck!
Das muss ich ja gleich starten.
Zeig mal her.
Ich will auch sehen.
Also hier und dann...
Der Typ ist wirklich super.
Also man kann größer machen oder wie?
Du kannst sehen, die Konversation sozusagen, die zu diesem Tweet gehört.
Man geht mit zwei Fingern drauf und das ist...
Ach cool, verstehe.
Nicht schlecht. Wer soll mal jetzt eine neue Twitter-Version für OSX-Versionen rausbringen?
Ja, langsam wird es Zeit, oder?
Und ich hab auch genau das, was du gesagt hast. Ich hab diese neue Twitter-Seite gesehen. Hast du die schon? Ich hab sie bisher nur auf Video gesehen.
Ich auch. Für meine Counts gilt es nicht. So wichtig bin ich wohl nicht. Na toll.
Und ich hab auch gedacht, das sieht ja wirklich mal perfekt aus für die iPad-Version von dem App. So mit diesen zwei Hälften. Und das ist dann, was du links machst, anklickst, siehst in der rechten Hälfte das Bildschirm und so. Das ist schon sehr, sehr sexy. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt.
Das ist wirklich sagenhaft. Das Tweety war ja auf dem iPhone auch schon, eigentlich hat so neue User-Interface-Ideen pioniert.
Zum Beispiel mit dem ganz runterziehen, dass man da eine Reload-Funktion hat.
Reload mit dem runterziehen. Das machen jetzt auch ganz viele, weil das einfach mal total mega intuitiv ist.
Das liegt auch daran, weil er das als Open Source veröffentlicht hat. Hat er? Es hat da wohl diese Bibliothek dazu, als Open Source veröffentlicht. Und so konnte man es auch relativ leicht einbauen. Und es hat ja selbst das Facebook-App nutzt, das jetzt, und dann haben sie alle ganz furchtbar gemeckert, weil die ihm keinen Credit gegeben haben dafür, obwohl es offensichtlich seine Funktion war. Und das haben sie dann irgendwann nachgeholt und dann haben sie gesagt, yep.
Wenn es so offensichtlich ist, dann ist der Credit auch egal, dann weiß sowieso jeder, dass es von den Tüten her uns ist.
Ich glaube, Facebook hat schon nochmal ein paar. Und ich finde dieses Hin und Her ziehen, das finde ich ja so geil, dass ich erstmal die letzten paar Abende daran gesessen habe, so eine Dragging-Funktion für Web-Kit nachzubauen, also dass man so eine vernünftige Touch-Funktion mal hat. Könnt ihr euch mal angucken, jQuery-nested-touch heißt das Ganze. Also nested, weil es ineinander verschachtete Touch-Elemente gibt, sodass man das eine horizontal bewegen kann, das andere vertikal. Ja, weil ich so ein bisschen daran rumgebastelt, kann man ja mal so Feature geben. Nested-touch. 3-4-3-mark-slash. Keine Ahnung, muss ich mal raussuchen, die Dürmer hin.
Slash keine Ahnung. Muss ich mal raussuchen, die Dürmer hin.
Ja, genau die.
War die noch frei, ja.
Was mir allerdings fehlt bei diesen ganzen Twitter-Klines, beziehungsweise was mir bei Twitter einfach fehlt, ist der Outline-Mode. Nee, was mir einfach fehlt, ist wieder dieser Sync über verschiedene Twitter-Klines hinweg. Also ich verstehe nicht, warum Twitter-Klines nicht in der Lage sind, irgendwo eine Marke zu setzen. Einfach eine Zeitmarke mit dem Account. Was ist sozusagen der letzte Zeitpunkt, wo ich Tweets gelesen habe?
Du nutzt Twitter einfach falsch.
Wieso ich liest Twitter falsch? Was soll das denn heißen? Komm mir nicht so!
Ja, hast du aber nicht drauf.
Wieso, was mach ich denn falsch?
Nein, mehr liest du eh nicht alles, oder?
Es geht nicht darum, dass ich... Ja, aber ich will auch nicht das, was ich gelesen habe, noch mal lesen.
Das kann man ganz easy lösen. Und zwar machen die einen zweiten Account, der so heißt wie deiner, mit irgendwie anderlei Meter hinten dran und posten da immer als Tweet, welchen Tweet du gerade gelesen hast.
Und dann kann sich das mal...
Großartig.
Aber es stimmt tatsächlich irgendwas in die Richtung. Aber es gibt ja sogar ein Twitter-Klient, der kann das.
Mit git back end.
Der ist aber leider scheiße. Das ist hier dieses Tweetek, kann das.
Ich glaub Echo Phone hat auch sowas, aber das können sie sozusagen nur der Klient untereinander und dann wahrscheinlich auch mit Cloud-Wolke, oder? Oder machen die das irgendwie über Twitter?
Nee, die machen das über ihren eigenen Dienst. Die können dann auch so, wenn du eine Suche abspeicherst, kann das Lidl automatisch auf dem iPhone vorhanden und sowas. Ja, das ist tatsächlich... Das tut not, das stimmt. Also besonders schön, finde ich, dass die zwischen iPad und iPhone nichts hin und her kriegen. Wenn ich das selbe Programm einmal auf dem iPhone installiere und einmal auf dem iPad, dass ich dann beide Male meine Zugangsdaten eingebe.
Aber es sind ja unterschiedliche Programme.
Nein, manchmal sind es auch dieselben Programme. Zum Beispiel Read It Later ist das selbe Programm, das ich auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad installiere.
Dennis langweilt sich.
Z-Tiff heißt Dennis.
Da hab ich bei den anderen was gehört. Bei den anderen? Na, bei dem anderen Podcast.
Es gibt einen anderen Podcast?
Ja, es gibt einen anderen Podcast. Wir haben auch einen Z-Tiff.
Wie du gehst mit anderen Podcasts als uns?
Ein guter Weckentosch Podcast heutzutage hat einen lokalen Z-Tiff. Da kann man die Qualität erklären. Die anderen haben nur einen. Hessi hat erzählt, dass diese Jungs aus dem ZFS-Forum oder was das ist, die haben sich irgendwie den Restcode, den Apple mal veröffentlicht hat, geschnappt und haben den jetzt soweit hin gebogen, dass es jetzt für Snowlapp einen downloadable Tool gibt. Dann machst du da Doppelklick und dann hast du da irgendwie ZFS.
Das haben sie uns vor Monaten schon erzählt, oder? Die haben den Apple-Typen angeschrieben und haben gesagt, gebt doch mal euren letzten Stand und den haben sie auch tatsächlich bekommen. Und was ich damals halt aber noch nicht hatte, ist, dass die es auch irgendwie hinkriegen, da mal eine vernünftige Version draus zu machen.
Es gibt voll was, was weniger Ärger macht, als das ZFS, wie Apple das ausgeliefert hat. Also er sprach von kein Problem, auch wenn es keine Garantien gibt.
Also hier meinen sie ja auch, bei diesem anderen McIntosh-Podcast wird dem ZFS-Nerd der Mund verboten. Was hier, ist das überhaupt nicht so?
Ich hab schon als Podcast-Betrieb gemacht für das ZFS.
Das ist ja wieder ein anderer Podcast.
Das stimmt.
Aber das zeigt ja auch was über unsere Einstellung aus.
Wir haben ja nichts gegen Alternativ-Adversar-Systeme. Fass mal zusammen.
Die Sonne ist ja runtergegangen. Also es war ja irgendwie vorbei. Also weiß nicht, der ist irgendwie der Ausgang. Und Larry hat jetzt übernommen. Open Solaris ist auch irgendwie nicht mehr so open. Ist jetzt irgendwie mehr so closed Solaris. Das Wort wird wahrscheinlich auch noch verschwinden, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls haben die da so ein bisschen Angst, dass irgendwie das ZFS jetzt so ein bisschen, die Source-Codes nicht mehr so veröffentlicht werden. Aber im Zuge dessen haben die bei FreeBSD erstmal ein Statement abgegeben. Und zwar hat der entsprechende Programmierer da Pawel sowieso Davidek irgendwie, aus Pollen, ist jetzt gar nicht so weit weg von hier an Warschau, hat erstmal den kompletten Source-Code, den es für ZFS bisher gibt, hat der irgendwie nach FreeBSD portiert und hat jetzt mal so vor zwei Wochen einen riesen Patch rausgegangen, wo wirklich der allerneueste ZFS-Code irgendwie als FreeBSD-Patch zur Verfügung steht. Also es ist jetzt noch nicht komplett integriert, sondern man muss sich das schon reinpatchen in den neuen Current. Aber dann hast du sozusagen alles von De-Duplication bis zu dem neuesten ZFS-Diff-Feature, wo man zwei Snapshots diffen kann, um zu sehen, hier folgende Files sind verschwunden, neue sind dazugekommen und die haben sich geändert. Also da bist du wirklich up-to-date, ich glaube sogar noch weiter als die bei Open Solaris selbst irgendwie waren, weil die releasen ja immer nur in Source-Cycles. Und da geht's richtig ab und gleichzeitig wurde für 8Stable bei FreeBSD, für Leute, die sich da auskennen, sind jetzt auch gerade gestern irgendwie lauter Patches gekommen, die bis ZFS-Version 15 hochpatchen und tausende Bugfixes, also wirklich weiß nicht, 50 oder 100. Also da ist gerade richtig ein Schwung gekommen und da geht's auch gerade richtig ab. Also FreeBSD sagt, wir sind committed zu ZFS und das bleibt auch so. Also egal, was die da bei Oracle machen.
Und das kommt jetzt auch sozusagen bei Default, also die Entwicklung ist nur einfach alleine weiter.
Na, das alleine bringt's ja nicht so viel, weil du willst ja kompatibel bleiben, weil jetzt gibt's ja ZFS auch auf Linux jetzt mit...
Aber wird denn bei Oracle ZFS noch... Also ich meine...
Wir entwickeln es schon weiter, aber ich glaube, es ist jetzt nicht mehr so offen, sondern man muss jetzt immer warten, bis sie dann irgendwann mal den Source releasen, was jetzt nicht mehr an Dauern machen, sondern immer so in Pakete.
So wie er das gemacht hat, ja.
Also es ist schon ein bisschen anders. Aber sie wollen da dabei bleiben. Also was ich gerne hätte, wäre ein Open ZFS. Nee, aber dass die das mal irgendwie so raustun und alle zusammen da irgendwie dran weitermachen. Weil bei einem Fallsystem finde ich macht das schon Sinn. Weil da muss man einfach mal zusammenspielen. Da bringt es irgendwie dieses, irgendwie diesen Singleplayer ist da nicht so toll. Ja, das stimmt. Und ich meine der Pavel hier von Freebies, der hat ja wirklich auch eine Menge Fehler gefunden. Und denen haben wir gesagt, guck mal hier habt ihr folgendes Problem, da habe ich das gefunden. Und sie haben gesagt, ja stimmt eigentlich, müssen wir fixen und so. Es waren so Fehler, die die jetzt nicht so direkt betroffen haben, weil die bei Solaris ja auch bestimmte Sachen anders machen. Da ist es dann halt nicht aufgefallen, aber so im Großen und Ganzen war es schon irgendwie ein Fehlerpotential für die Zukunft und dann haben die das auch mal gefixt.
Das heißt, was ist das aktuelle Freemail? 8.1 Und das kommt jetzt schon serienmäßig mit einem Installer, der einem gleich ZFS installiert, richtig?
Na nicht so, dass man direkt auch vom ZFS booten kann, aber wenn du jetzt einen 8.1 installierst, ist das ZFS schon mit dabei. Das heißt, du kannst da eine Platte reinstecken, kannst sagen, hier mach mir mal einen Z-Pool drauf und dann geht's los. Das ist schon so, ja.
Aber man kann auch davon booten.
Man kann auch davon booten, aber der Installer unterstützt das nicht so ganz direkt.
Okay, und das Neune?
Das Neune hat das ZFS auch mit dabei. Und da der Installer unterstützt, aber auch nicht, dass direkt, der ist zwar gleich auf einen ZFS installiert. Aber da gibt's so Skripte im Netz, welche Krüxen hat ja irgendwie eins, ne? Das startet man einfach und der macht das.
Dann irgendwie alles und dann läuft das alles so durch. Die bauen ja auch einen neuen Installer, die haben ja immer noch dieses Swiss-Installer und so. Das ist ja auch ein bisschen alt.
Aber es sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus. Und wenn du jetzt sagst, hier für Mac, sind die Jungs da auch ein bisschen dranne. Das ist doch schon gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so viel Zukunft hat, ehrlich gesagt, auf dem Mac.
Mir würde es schon helfen, wenn ich vielleicht dann doch mal eine Platte habe, wo ein ZFS drauf ist, dass ich sie wenigstens auch irgendwie an Mac von MioStreetOnly wenigstens mal ranstecken kann. Das wär ja schonmal was.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Versionen die unterstützen.
Die waren schon ziemlich hinterher da auf dem Mac.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab das jetzt auch nur so weitergetragen. Ja, ich hab jetzt nur keine richtigen Reißer-Themen mehr auf der Liste. Nur noch so Sachen, die man auch mal besser verschieben könnte, weil wir jetzt eh schon seit drei Stunden reden hier.
Rat da mal runter, was haben wir denn noch auf der Woche?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Wollen wir jetzt hier wirklich noch mit Markt anfangen?
Oder wollen wir noch mal die schönsten, wenn wir aus 50 Folgen Mobile-Macs nachstellen?
Haben wir das nicht schon gemacht?
Wir sind schon mehrfach ins Wort gefallen, haben irgendwie Ficken gesagt.
Es gab noch nicht das Max-Tim-Android-Streitgespräch. Dass wir das iPhone so hinter sich lassen, das glaubst du gar nicht.
Das ist aber tatsächlich ganz lustig, weil HTC greift Apple an dem Punkt an, an dem Apple mit Abstand am schlechtesten ist, nämlich bei Mobile Me. Was? Na, die bringen jetzt einfach so einen Dienst raus demnächst, mit dem du dann deine HTC-Handys, mit denen du die in die Cloud sinken kannst, also so Backupen, was ja mit dem iPhone nicht geht, und mit dem du es locaten kannst, so Find my HTC, aber das für lau, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Okay, na, da werden sie natürlich total mit abräumen.
Ja, das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Ich hab ja immer noch keinen Typen gesehen, der irgendwie mehr als 10 Minuten sich mit seinem Telefon beschäftigt hat. Die anderen Jungs, die haben das Ding in meiner Tasche, machen nichts damit.
Naja, so kann man das nun auch nicht sagen.
Doch.
Ich kenne schon Leute, die sich damit länger beschäftigen.
Ich schon.
Gibt's? Also da im Büro beschäftigen sich da so Leute bezahlt mit, aber man muss, ich muss echt mit Erstaunen feststellen, dass die Euphorie der Android-Entwicklung und so weiter, dass die bei den Entwicklern schon echt gewichen ist. Die haben da gar keinen Bock mehr drauf. Weil jetzt einer nach dem anderen ist immer mal so ein iPhone-Projekt durch Pairing drin gewesen und die wollen jetzt immer iOS entwickeln. Die haben keinen Bock mehr auf Android. Das ist echt krass. Die haben am Anfang immer so Android-Yeah und Google-Yeah und Offline-Yeah und alles ist yeah. Und jetzt so irgendwie, ja wir haben da so ein Bug im Android und so weiter. Und haben dann so heimlich so oder irgendwie in ihren Freizeitprojekten schon irgendwelche iOS. Warum?
Ich meine warum?
Na ich mein halt, es macht mehr Spaß da ihr SDK zu benutzen. Das Android-SDK, das scheinen wohl einfach irgendwie bestimmte Sachen. Und mit Java, keine Ahnung, extrem umständlich, extrem panne zu sein. Dann hast du halt dieses Problem, es gibt halt eine Milliarde Devices da draußen. Also das Problem haben wir ganz akut. Und dann kriegst du halt so User Reports, ja auf dem neuesten Motorola X-Bla-Y-Psylon geht's nicht, wird nichts gerendert.
So ok, dann musst du dir erstmal dieses Device besorgen, bevor du das überhaupt nachvollziehen.
Das dauert halt. Dann gibt's halt irgendwie so ganz komische Issues. Du kannst halt, wenn du Views animierst, da geht eigentlich fast alles. Aber nur der eine Fall, der aber eigentlich ausnahmsweise der üblichste ist, um jetzt irgendwelche Quadrate hin und her zu bewegen, ist halt total kompliziert. Musst du dir alles selber aushängen und irgendwie dann sitzen sie am IOS SDK und freuen sich die ganze Zeit. Ha! Es geht! Also das ist meine Beobachtung. Ich mach ja beides nicht und ich find ja Objective-C auch nicht so wahnsinnig toll, aber das ist so meine Beobachtung aus dem Arbeitsalltag.
Ja.
Das war jetzt so das Trollfutter für die Kommentare.
Weil der Mobile-Wechsel hat so... Das war ja wieder so klar! Dieses unfundierte Android-Fashing!
Na und?
Ja, also was ich so ein bisschen bemerkenswert finde, ist so dieses... diese Tabletten.
Fürs Soundboard.
Diskussionen gerade.
Die Tablette.
Failpad von... ne, V-Pad. V-Fail.
V-Fail.
Das war auch geil bei dem Spiegelartikel. Da haben sie geschrieben, ja, wir haben jetzt hier die Vorab-Version und es soll sich natürlich noch wesentlich verbessern, bis es ausgeliefert wird nächste Woche.
Es ist ja immerhin noch eine Woche Zeit.
Und sie hatten für jeden Anwendungsfall ein unterschiedliches Gerät. Ein Gerät eins, weil das Video abspielen konnte, und das andere, was weiß ich.
Ach du Scheiße.
Und die GUI sieht halt aus, wie vom Praktikanten gemacht.
Und wie ist das jetzt eigentlich mit diesen Updates? Du hast ein Android, oder Max?
Ich hatte noch ein HTC Magic, ja.
Mit welcher Version?
1.6.
Und warum update es denn nicht?
Weil es meine Freundin hat. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das Gerät das update überlebt. Weil es gibt kein offizielles Update von HTC für das Ding. Sondern man müsste halt diesen Synanon-Mod installieren, der aber auch ganz hervorragend funktionieren soll.
Aber trau's dich nicht.
Ich hab halt keinen Bock da jetzt an ihrem Leben an den GDL-Complot zu schwimmen.
Diese Software-Update-Situation, das ist doch wie Autoteile in der DDR. Also da hast du deinen neuen Trabi, ja. Aber neuen Auspuff haben wir nicht. Du kennst einen Freund, der das vielleicht hat. Der könnte dir eins rüberkriegen, der hat West-Kontakte.
Ist so wie iOS 4 auf dem 3G.
Das war halt mal langsam. Aber zumindest kriegst du einfach mal die Updates. Kriegste halt einfach mal.
Aber es gibt keinen Multitasking. Wenn es ein Update gibt für Android, dann geht es wesentlich besser als auf dem iPhone.
Über Luft.
Das ist ja wirklich mal wesentlich entspannter als hier irgendwie ein iTunes anschließen. Ja komm, das ist schon.
Was ist daran besser? Das ist anders.
Hallo, wenn du dein Telefon hier hast, dann steht plötzlich ein Dialog, hey, ich hab ein neues OS für dich, möchtest du das jetzt installieren? Und du brauchst nur noch OK zu drücken und alles ist gut. Das ist schon geiler, als wenn du irgendwie zu iTunes rüber rennen musst und dann irgendwie...
Das hat aber auch so ein Sicherheitsgefühl, so ein Kabel so anschließen mit Strom.
Das fühlt sich einfach viel wertiger an.
Aber in der Dimension, dass die Frage auch im Raum steht, gibt es überhaupt Updates oder nicht? Krieg ich überhaupt jemals irgendein Update?
Das hat ein Magne-Google ganz krass gemacht.
Da ist mir dann ehrlich gesagt, diese USB oder WLAN, ich meine, okay, dann ist es halt over the air. Und weißt du, warum es da over the air ist? Weil sie gar keine andere Chance haben.
Weil sie gar keine Updates auf dem Internet haben.
Weil sie gar keine Software haben.
Weil sie so eine geile Software wie iTunes haben.
Ja, ich meine, guck mal, wenn man sich jetzt auch gerade die Verkostung. Und überhaupt so Halbwegs-Kompatibilität der Applikationen unter den Telefonen zu bekommen.
Ja, das klingt auch ganz furchtbar.
Es gibt ja diese Diskussion, warum gibt es eigentlich keine Konkurrenz zum iPod Touch? Es gibt ja nichts.
Na doch, mittlerweile gibt es so ein bisschen was. So Dinger mit hier, also ich glaube nicht, dass der toll ist, aber dieser Arcos, Archos, Mini, irgendwas, Tablet. Also was ist das? Als Tablet mit 3 Zoll Display verkaufen?
Ja, aber das ist keine Konkurrenz zu dem iPod Touch.
Also nicht so richtig ernsthaft.
Das ist ein bisschen anderes, ein bisschen andere Idee. Für manche Leute ist das besser gedacht, aber dass dieses Ding in Konkurrenz steht zum iPod Touch, das würdest du auch nicht ernsthaft behaupten. Und vor allem ist die ganze Android-Welt nicht da. Da kann man sich jetzt auch fragen, warum eigentlich? Sie haben doch eigentlich alles. Sie haben Touch, sie können die Geräte bauen, sie müssen eigentlich nur das Telefon weglassen. Das Ding ist, wenn du beim Android-Telefon das Telefon weglässt, dann bleibt nichts übrig. Weil du hast da irgendwie keine Games, du hast da irgendwie keine Musikinfrastruktur, da gibt es keinen iTunes irgendwie.
Da gibt es Amazon. Amazon? Und dann? Dann lädt sie über Amazon deine Musik.
Ja, aber irgendwie scheint das ja nicht gerade jetzt die Infrastruktur zu sein, auf der du einen erfolgreichen Musikplayer auf den Markt bringen kannst, der mit dem iPod Touch irgendwie auf einem Level steht. Also, worauf ich ihn... Ich will jetzt gar nicht sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie besser oder so, das ist nur so... Der iPod Touch ist auch ohne Telefon immer noch wunderbar positioniert und hat irgendwie seine Infrastruktur. Und das ist das, was halt die Stärke dieser iOS-Plattform derzeit auch ausmacht, dass sie eben auch jenseits der Telefonwelt einfach brillieren. Nächste Geschichte ist die Sache mit den Tablets. Ich meine, jetzt gibt es so die ersten Ankündigungen. Es gibt dieses Samsung Galaxy.
Das ist übrigens auch krass, weil die ja so ein höher aufgelöstes Display haben. Und da gibt es halt auch so diesen Issue mit den Screen-Sizes. Also du hast ja irgendwie...
Dass es langsamer wird, wenn das Display größer wird.
Sie setzen, also die haben mehr Auflösungen als... Das ist irgendwie auch so ein ganz komplizierter Android-Sachverhalt wieder gewesen, wo die Entwickler gegrübelt haben, aber es ist irgendwie... Ja genau, und sie setzen dann im User-Interface das High-Resolution-Flag und dann nehmen sie die größeren Icons, scallen sie aber trotzdem noch und du weißt halt nicht genau so als Entwickler, ne? Wie sieht das denn jetzt da aus? Musste halt, also dieses... Ja, ohne diese, also diese unterschiedlichen Screens, Heißes und Resolutions und keine Ahnung, das haben die irgendwie scheinbar auch nicht, alles so richtig in den Griff. Da macht auch jeder, was er will.
Für mich wäre da noch eine andere Sache nämlich interessant. Also erstens gibt es die Aussage von Google, ich weiß nicht, ob die mittlerweile schon wieder zurückgezogen wurde, aber sie meinten irgendwie, Android ist auch nicht für Tablets.
Die Version ist nicht für Tablets.
Ne, Android ist ja, was auch immer. Ja, ne, die Aussage ist jetzt halt nicht so. Und ein Hauptproblem ist natürlich diese Tasten. Naja, du hast doch bei diesem Android diese fest in das Gerät eingebrannten Tasten.
Die aber manchmal auch jetzt schon so soft.
Ja, aber die müssen da sein.
Also wenn du einen Market haben willst, dann müssen diese Tasten da sein, genau.
Das nächste, was man hat, diese Tasten, die leuchten auch immer. Was ich auch immer total absurd finde, da leuchten mich Tasten an, die ich unter Umständen überhaupt nicht brauche in dem Programm. Und wenn du jetzt das Ganze halt auf Formfaktor Tablet, also so ein Ding, was du beliebig hältst, wo willst du dann diese Tasten machen?
Dann müssen sie sich halt was ausdenken. Also ich meine, das ist ja nun kein Drama.
Doch, das ist wie ein Drama. Also ganz ehrlich, ich finde, diese Tasten sind für mich der Hauptgrund, dass dieses ganze UI-Konzept von Android einfach ein Fail ist. Also das ist einfach mit diesem Menü und Back usw. Das forciert einfach eine Struktur auf jedes Programm. Und du hast immer die Wahl, entweder du versuchst daraus, irgendwas Sinnvolles zu machen und übersetzt es irgendwie in dein Programm zurück, auch wenn es gar nicht passt. Das mag ja bei manchen passen. Oder du ignorierst die alle, sonst hast du Tasten ohne Funktion, die aber immer da sind. Oder du machst irgendwas ganz was anderes, womit du eben keine homogene Verhalt mehr hast. Das finde ich einfach störend. Also es gibt da diese Idee, dass man ein Default-User-Interface platziert. Was bei iOS der Homebutton ist. Denen sie ja jetzt sogar bei dem, gut es ist nicht iOS, aber bei dem Nano haben sie sogar den weggelassen. Das ist nicht für eine gute Idee im Übrigen.
Man muss deutlich sagen, es gibt ja mehr Tasten, die dürfen aber ja nicht anders verwendet werden. Das hatten wir bei diesem Camera-App da, wo das ja der Auslösebutton war, hier lauter leiser.
Das ist ja nichts, was im User-Interface landet. Das ist ja nichts, worauf du draufguckst. Das ist ja nicht das, womit du deine Programme liest.
Ich weiß, was du meinst.
Ich hab tatsächlich auch mit diesem Tim-Max-Streit-Gespräch.
Das gibt alles jetzt.
Beim 50. Jubiläum das ganze Programm.
Mir wird sich auch schon im Chat so ein bisschen beschwert, aber ich hab grad schon geschrieben, das gehört einfach dazu.
Ich weiß genau, was du mit diesen Tastenproblemen meinst, weil das eigentliche Problem halt ich gar nicht, dass die Tasten da sind, sondern dass man sie nicht bemerkt, dass man beim Anfang hat einen Vorteil, dass man sich sehr stark aufs Display konzentrieren kann und damit hat sich der Salat. Und was man nicht auf dem Display sieht, ist eigentlich auch nicht da. Und außer dieser Shake-Funktion, die dann irgendwie Ando macht, die ja auch extrem gewöhnungsbedürftig ist.
Das ist eine Scheißidee mit dem Shake.
Also man gewöhnt sich dran im Laufe der Zeit, dass man da Salat in der Funktion hat.
Vor allem, wenn ich Musik hör und dann irgendwie die Hosentasche zu doll wackelt und ich dieses Shuffle-Dings da nicht ausgeschaltet hab und dann immer die Tracks skippt, so, oh, da bin ich ja einmal schon richtig fuchsig geworden, ja. Ja, das geht gar nicht.
Wie, das kann man nicht abschalten?
Doch, doch, das ging irgendwie. Aber es war irgendwie erst default an oder so.
Keine Ahnung. Also auf jeden Fall, das ist definitiv ein Nachteil von Android, sehe ich tatsächlich genau so, aber What the fuck?
Sie werden einfach extrem kämpfen müssen, um da mithalten zu können.
Ich glaube, sie haben komplett andere Probleme. Also ich glaube, die Hardware-Buttons, die sind tatsächlich ein tendenziell kleines Problem. Also sie waren extrem dämlich, dass sie auf diese Hardware-Button zu viel Wert gelegt haben. Das ist ja, man darf ja diese ganzen Google-Apps nur installieren und den Market, wenn man diese Buttons da drin hat, anstatt wirklich, und das halte ich, anstatt wirklich mal reinzuschreiben, so, und wenn du das Gerät auf den Markt gebracht hast, dann musst du für zwei Jahre sicherstellen, dass da auch Updates für kommen und dass du immer die aktuelle Version von dem Betriebssystem drauf hast. Was ich insbesondere bei Sicherheitsproblemen für ein ganz spaßiges Ding halte, also wenn jetzt der erste große Sicherheits-Bug noch mal kommt für Android, dann können wir mal alle darauf warten, wie lange es dauert, bis dann eine neue Version rauskommt, 1.6.1. rauskommt, die das dann auch für das uralte HTC-Magic fixt.
Das macht der Fehler ja auch schon nicht. Diese Bugs hier, wo eigentlich im PDF-Dings da vom iPhone wurden ja bei dem 3.1 irgendwas fürs ganz erste iPhone auch nicht gefixt.
Genau. Aber das ist dann so richtig, also dass jetzt so die Hälfte der verfügbaren Android-Geräte dann wahrscheinlich ungefixt rumrennen, das ist, finde ich dann nochmal zacken, schlimmer als, also ich finde es schon schlimm genug bei diesem 3.1 irgendwas. Ja, aber es erinnert nichts daran, dass dieses HTC Sense, also dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass HTC so der Konkurrenz für Apple wird. Und weil die bauen nämlich schöne Geräte, die sind jetzt gerade so ein bisschen dabei, sich von Google zu etablieren, mit diesem HTC sense.com und eigene Service anzubieten. Wer hat jetzt hier sein...
Ich schwör's nicht.
Ich auch nicht.
Wer hat hier sein drittes iPhone jetzt gerade nicht ausgeschaltet?
Das ist nämlich das Ritual bei Mobile Max, wenn wir ins Studio kommen, dann müssen wir erstmal alle unsere Devices auf den Tisch legen. Wie, du hast hier noch was in der Socke stecken?
So wilden Westen im Salon, Waffen auf den Tisch.
Wir haben mehr iPhones im Raum als anwesend auf jeden Fall. Seid da durch, ich hab noch eine wichtige Frage.
Und was ich noch ganz spannend finde, das hat dieser Tech-Crunch-Typ angebracht, dass Android, die haben zwar nicht dieses Problem, dass da irgendwie...
Du hast gerade gesagt, Android HTC ist ja eine Konkurrenz für Apple. Ich widerspreche dir. Ich denke da gar nicht, dass Android derzeit wirklich die Konkurrenz ist für Apple.
Sondern?
Windows Phone 7.
Android ist einfach die Konkurrenz für alle anderen außer Apple.
Naja, es ist auch in Amerika, sie kennen den zweiten Teil.
Mit wenigen Ausnahmen ist, also wie zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, diesen Reisenmarkt in den USA, wo Apple sozusagen nichts bedienen kann, weil sie da einfach nicht dran teilnehmen.
Mit dem CDMA.
Genau.
Wurde ja gemunkelt, dass da was kommt. Ich halte das ja auch für ein Gerücht und blieb ja auch eins.
Können wir auch gleich nochmal drüber reden, aber Android ist vor allem ein Konkurrent für Microsoft. Microsoft. Ich denke nicht, dass Microsoft sich wieder aufrappeln wird. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie eine Chance haben mitzuhalten.
Ich bin mir da nicht ganz so sicher.
Aus markttechnischen Gründen. Es mag toll sein, was sie da jetzt gerade gemacht haben, aber diese Begrübnis-Zeremonien, diese Apple-Microsoft, die müssen alle für ihren schlechten Geschmack für immer in der Hölle schmoren.
Also ich finde meinen Kinn toll.
Du hast einen von den 50 Kinn? So, weil das Android-Marktmodell ist einfach strange, weil das ist basiert im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur darauf, dass Google mehr Zugang zu ihrem Markt oder das andere mehr Zugang zu ihrem Markt bekommen. Dass Google mehr Werbemarkt hat. Das ist sozusagen das Business-Modell von Android. Da zahlt Google Geld für in Form von Development und teilweise glaube ich sogar auch an die Gerätehersteller, wenn die Android machen sozusagen, wenn da eher Google-Kram drauf ist, dann wird da eben auch Kohle bezahlt, sowie sie auch Kohle an Apple zahlen dafür, dass der Google suchbar im Safari drin ist etc. und so wie Firefox Mozilla von Google Geld bekommt und damit ihr ganzes Development finanziert. Also Google gibt Geld dafür aus, dass Android installiert wird, während Apple Geld einnimmt dafür, dass iOS installiert ist. Und Apple verkauft Geräte und Google verkauft keine Geräte. Wenn sie mal ein Gerät haben, wie dieses Nexus One, dann verschenken sie sie. Und das heißt, diese Business-Modelle haben irgendwie gar nichts miteinander zu tun. Das einzige Ding ist, dass Android deswegen aber natürlich sehr erfolgreich ist in diesem Lizenzmodell. Viele springen jetzt auf und sagen, ah super, Betriebssystem, kann ich hier irgendwie anpassen, kann ich meinen eigenen Scheiß drauf packen, mach ich mit einem halben Jahr Software-Update-Support und dann kommst du in die nächste Generation und scheiß auf die Customer. Das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen das, was in diesem Markt gerade stattfindet. Niemanden, der da wirklich den Eindruck macht, dass er jetzt an seinen Kunden irgendein Interesse hätte. Weil die wollen nur Geräte verkaufen, aber haben an so einer Kundenbindung im einigen Sinne wenig Interesse. Die wollen immer neu verkaufen und für die ist das sozusagen nur ein Kostenpunkt, den Kunden zu supporten. So stellt sich mir das da. Ich meine, warum gibt es da nicht Updates? Warum ist das nicht Teil der Strategie, einen Gesamtmarkt Android zu haben, wo Software Updates, wo das einfach Teil der Idee ist? Warum ist das nicht sozusagen eine Grundanforderung der Lizenzierung?
Dass es keine Grundanforderung ist, wie gesagt, hätte ich schon gerichtet.
Hätte ich für genau so ein großes Problem wie du.
Was ist mit eurer Reusbandtaste hier?
Wir blenden die einfach aus.
Ich glaube, ihr könnt ja gehen, wenn ihr so ein Paar habt.
Wir machen einfach die Sendung ohne euch weiter.
Wir machen doch gerade gute Sendung.
Wir können ja auch einen Stereo haben, als Blitten irgendwie.
Genau, ist ja ein Pad.
Ja, aber nicht von meinem Twitter-Account twittern.
Mal gucken, ob iPhone 4 Apps jetzt beim Hochskalieren in Native kommen oder in Northpixelig sind.
Na ja, so. Und Microsofts Modell war bisher, Software zu lizenzieren für andere Hardware. Das heißt, genau das, was Google jetzt macht, nur dass Google die Firmen halt dafür bezahlt.
Ich weiß nicht, zahlen sie tatsächlich dafür?
Also ich glaube, sie zahlen nicht wirklich dafür.
Mindestens kriegen sie kein Geld, aber ich hab auch gehört, dass sie auch Geld dafür, in dem Moment, wo sozusagen so eine Firma alles with Google aus...
Dass sie dafür dann Geld kriegt. Dafür wundert es mich, warum sie es so extrem kurz gemacht haben. Also HTC hat ja am Anfang diese Geräte mit Google ausgeliefert und hat dann relativ schnell auf diese eigene Oberfläche gesetzt.
Du hast ja auch diesen schönen Artikel gelesen, bei Techcrunch hast du den nicht schon eben zitiert.
Ich hab ihn erwähnt, ich hab ihn ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal gelesen.
Vor einer halben Stunde. Ich hab ihn gelesen und das ist eine interessante Geschichte, nämlich Google ist eigentlich komplett gescheitert, wenn man jetzt denen Ausführungen in diesem Artikel Glauben schenken darf. Das klingt ja recht plausibel mit konkreten Belegen. Und sie wollten halt dieses Nexus One eigentlich als WLAN-Phone rausbringen. Und ihre Idee war eigentlich Scheiß auf die Carrier. Wir machen jetzt hier WLAN, Telefonie und so weiter. Aber sie sind in diesem Streit unterlegen. Die Carrier haben sich sozusagen nicht vollständig über den Tisch ziehen lassen. Und deswegen dominieren halt jetzt die Carrier. Guck dir an, was da bei Verizon passiert. Jetzt machen die ihren eigenen Market auf. Dann gibt es irgendwie so Regeln. Dann gibt es diese Skype, was zwar irgendwie WLANen kann, aber nur, wenn du irgendwie auch 3G hast.
Skype ist ja noch das ganz große Problem, dass Skype exklusiv für Verizon Android Telefonen ist.
Du bist in dieser Welt immer noch der Büttel der Telcos. Während Apple es geschafft hat, mit dem iPhone, mit den geringen Einschränkungen dieser NetLog-Sache, die ja nun hoffentlich bald auch vorbei ist, jetzt den Mute-Button, siehst du mal. Apple ist sozusagen mehr als je ein anderer Softwareanbieter in diesem Mobilfunkmarkt und Hardware-Anbieter in der Lage, den Providern quasi zu diktieren, was Sache ist, bzw. sich nicht reinreden zu lassen. Da gibt es halt keinen Vodafone-Button auf dem iPhone, wenn du es bei Vodafone kaufst, wenn es denn hier mal bei Vodafone kommt.
Wenn es immer bei Vodafone kommt.
Es gibt auch keinen Telekom-Button auf dem Telekom-Phone.
Ja, aber es gibt einen Haufen Apps, die explizit nur für Telekom-Verträge sind, ansonsten kannst du sie nicht nutzen.
Die sind da nicht darauf vorinstalliert oder so drauf, dass du sie nicht löschen kannst, oder dieser ganze Scheiß, den du halt sonst irgendwie bei anderen Telefonen hast. Also das ist das, wie sich mir das darstellt. Ich meine, ich hab ja überhaupt nichts gegen diese Euphorie mit Open Source und das ist alles wunderbar. Und Android hat auch ein interessantes, ich hab auch hier ein Podcast drüber gemacht, das ist auch ein interessantes Development-Modell und man für bestimmte Anwendungen taugt Android, wo das iPhone derzeit nicht oder vielleicht auch in Zukunft niemals geeignet ist. Aber diesen Open-Kram kaufe ich Google nicht uneingeschränkt ab.
Das ist doch geschenkt.
Das ist Brühnebel, was da irgendwie durch die Gegend fliegt und ich kauf das einfach nicht. Ich bestraue dem.
Google nehme ich das Open sofort ab. Die haben ja überhaupt kein Interesse daran, das ganze Ding nicht offen zu machen. Warum sollten sie? Das Problem sind in dem Fall tatsächlich dann die Carrier, dass die einfach diese offene Lücke für sich besetzen.
Open ist das aber nur so lange, wie es Google nutzt. Dann ist es halt auch nicht...
Ja natürlich ist es nur so lange, Open wie es Google nutzt. Das ist bei jeder offenen Lizenzicherung so. Das ist...
Wenn Konzerl und das Unternehmen dahintersteht.
Open ist einfach ein Scheißwort. Open war schon immer ein Scheißwort. Seit sie irgendwie mit Open-Unix-Initiativen angefangen haben, Open...
Mir geht es jetzt auch gar nicht um hier irgendwelche Offenheit oder nicht Offenheit. Ich finde es einfach ganz interessant, dass HTC baut gute Telefone. Und ich glaube, insofern sind sie selbstverständlich ein Konkurrent für Apple, selbst wenn das nicht die Philosophie von Open sein mag. Sie bauen Geräte, die halbwegs gut aussehen. Sie bauen Geräte, die...
Ja, sie sind natürlich ein Mitbewerber. Aber ich meine nur, ich glaube nicht, dass derzeit das, wo Android exportiert, das ist nicht der Teil des Marktes, in dem der Apple nennenswert etwas wegnimmt.
Nicht in erster Linie, aber...
Jeder, der noch ein Android kauft, kauft kein iPhone mehr. Das ist schon ein Problem.
Ja, ich glaube aber eher, wer ein Android kauft, der hat dann kein Nokia-Telefon mehr gekauft.
Nö, es gibt definitiv auch Leute, die vom iPhone auf ein Android-Gerät umsteigen. Ich kenne sogar welche. Ich kenne niemanden, der es nicht bereut hat, aber ich kenne Leute, die das gemacht haben. Und ich kenne Leute, die es gemacht haben. MS-Pro zum Beispiel war dazu gezwungen. Der hat kein iPhone und ein Anlock gekriegt in Amerika und hat sich da auf einen HTC Desire gekauft, mit dem er tot unglücklich ist.
Da soll der Typ immer was machen. Da können die nochmal richtig was tun.
Ich denke, das wird sich in zwei Jahren gelegt haben.
In zwei Jahren?
In diesem Jahr in Deutschland. Das ist ja schon fast das letzte Land außer USA und Japan.
Es gibt ja diese Gerüchte, dass es jetzt...
Und China hat auch nur einen Provider. Aber da gibt es auch nur einen, der in Frage kommt.
Ja, und Amerika gibt es ja nicht so wahnsinnig viele andere.
Die amerikanische Situation ist insofern interessant, als dass es nicht so ist, dass du die einfach austauschen könntest. Es gibt ja nur... Ja, T-Mobile ist aber deutlich schlechter ausgebaut, was 3G betrifft als AT&T. Und von daher können die halt nur in Ballungsräumen wirklich...
Ja, aber umso leichter könnte Apple es machen, dass sie einfach sagen, kommt AT&T, jetzt muss doch dieser scheiß Sim-Log sein, ihr habt doch eh keine Konkurrenz, es ist doch egal, ob mit Sim-Log oder ohneher. Oder NetLog, ihr habt doch, ist doch keine Konkurrenz da. Dann lasst die dreieinhalb Hanzeln das Team Mobile Netz lahm legen und dann seid ihr die Einzigen, für die es überhaupt in Frage kommt. Und ihr habt mal unter Beweis gestellt, dass nicht euer Netz so shitty ist.
Na ja, Apple braucht das, na gut, aber Apple kann, also sie gehen diese Konzession ein, ja, und kriegen dafür wahrscheinlich auch eine Menge. Sie haben dadurch wahrscheinlich eine Menge, ja, eine Menge Geld, aber auch vor allem eine Menge Sachen, die AT&T dann halt nicht hat durchsetzen können. Ich meine, das waren bestimmt irgendwie totale Auspeitsch-Szenarien da, wenn die Steve Jobs und der Singular Chef da zusammengesetzt haben.
Da gab es doch bei...
Hey Timmy, du bist ja gar nicht so schlecht hier bei Doodle Jump, wie ich sehe.
Da gab es doch bei... Bei Wayhat gab es noch mal so einen schönen Artikel darüber, wie... wie AT&T und Apple verhandeln und wie überhaupt gar nicht das zusammengeht. Das ist ein echt spannender Artikel. Nie gelesen?
Ich hab da so das eine oder andere gelesen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, was du meinst.
Ups, ich hab dir eine neue Highscore gemacht.
Passend.
War aber nicht so viel besser als ein alter. Ich hab dich da gerade noch gesehen, dass du am Rand mit deiner Score standst. Das war dann wahrscheinlich die Beste. Also, Jungs, Apple quatscht, Tim ist Highscores nächstes in der echten.
Was, ernsthaft? Du hast jetzt irgendwie meinen Highscore? Nein, hast du nicht. Doch. Dieser Highscore da, da steht doch mein Name drauf.
Ja, da steht aktuell, also das gerade letzte Spiel ist gleichzeitig auch der Highscore. Also, wo ist dieses Spiel gerade?
Okay, Tim, du bist wirklich schlecht in seinen Spielen.
Ich bin ein ganz schlechter Spieler.
Ach, 40.000 ist schon okay, oder? Mein Rekord ist bei 81.000 oder so.
Um das zu Ende zu bringen. Na ja, dann haben wir es auch mal von der Liste.
Für heute. Ihr habt jetzt nur noch eine Stunde, ne?
Und dann? Mögt ihr nicht mehr?
Na ja, also das LTE Zukunft iPhone 5?
Oder wollen wir die Hörer entscheiden lassen? Doch, los, wir machen die Demokratie jetzt hier. Was denn, wenn das denn?
Was rollt du denn jetzt an?
Ich dachte, das ist ja eine Apple-Podcast.
Da gibt es keine Demokratie.
Stimmt. Hallo? Hier gibt es Demokratie.
iPhone 5 wird dann wahrscheinlich nicht mehr für das 3G kommen, ne?
Bitte?
Das iPhone OS 5, also iOS 5, wird nicht mehr fürs 3G kommen, sondern es wird das letzte Update fürs 3GS sein.
Ja, vorstellbar.
Was ich übrigens gerade getestet hab, ich war ja am Forschen, während ich hier gezockt hab, als ihr euer Streitgespräch hattet. Ich hab gerade Doodle Jump auf dem iPad gespielt, und das wird doch zweifach hochskaliert. Und Doodle Jump unterstützt doch schon Retina Display Icons. Aber die werden anscheinend beim Hochskalieren irgendwie nicht benutzt. Das ist ein bisschen blöd. Eigentlich könnten die das ja mal einführen, oder?
Dass sie die native Auflösung unterstützen, auch auf dem iPhone?
Ja, weil das ist doch dann wie iPhone 4. Könnten sie doch einfach, dass die große...
Soweit ich weiß, wissen die Programme gar nicht, dass sie in doppelter Auflösung laufen.
Du kannst da den Skalierungsfaktor abfragen.
Ja, aber wenn du Faktor 2 machst, dann kriegst du keine andere Information. Du meinst auch, wenn ich diesen 2X-Button drücke, und das vergrößere, dann müsste ja das Programm zur Laufzeit ein Event kriegen, das jetzt die Auflösung größer ist.
Ach so, meinst du das?
Und das wird meines Wissens, so wie ich es gehört habe, nicht getan. Und die Programme müssten ja, wenn, dann auch für diesen Fall speziell angepasst sein, weil sonst wäre das ja sozusagen on launch.
Na ja, ich verstehe, verstehe. Es kann natürlich sein, dass jetzt auch, dass ich vielleicht mein App und DoodleJump vielleicht auch das Falschpunkt habe, dass man das immer wieder abfragen müsste. Müssen wir mal testen. Eigentlich aber wär das doch cool, wenn jetzt die Retina-Eigens, also Retina-Auflösung bei dem Hochskalieren benutzt werden, weil dann würde es nicht so pingslich aussehen.
Da haben sie auch ein Wort in die Welt gesetzt.
Erstmal wegen dieser Dynamik machen sie es nicht, weil es wirklich eine programmatische Änderung wäre. Wahrscheinlich machen sie es deshalb nicht, weil sie gar nicht wollen, dass das cool aussieht, sondern sie wollen nur, dass es irgendwie geht. Und wenn es toll aussieht, sollen sie eine iPad-App draus machen.
Diese iPhone-Mode hat doch seine Schuldigkeit getan. Der war doch nur für die ersten 10 Minuten da, damit man auch was unterlebt.
Ich benutze hier noch einige Programme in diesem Doppelmodus.
Ja, Doodle Jump zum Beispiel.
Doodle Jump zum Beispiel.
Was ist denn so schlecht auf dem iPad?
Ich nutze tatsächlich gar nichts.
Es war nicht alles schlecht auf dem iPhone.
Damals.
Leute, was? Wisst ihr überhaupt, wie spät ist es? Wir haben fast 4 Stunden durchgepodcastet. Quatsch.
Doch?
Wir haben ja erst um halb acht angefangen.
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt der 50-Stunden-Marathon zum Jubiläum.
Die vier Stunden machen wir jetzt auch noch voll.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein paar.
Weil es langweilig ist.
Ihr redet so laut, da kann man nicht schlafen.
Lass doch über Batterien reden, haben wir wenigstens was zu sagen.
Im Chat ist gerade einer eingeschlafen.
Und einer von tausenden.
Jetzt wieder Zugabe haben.
Was ist jetzt? Du hast ja Sanjo-Ela-Lupko gekauft, habe ich gehört.
Boah, ich dachte ja eigentlich, ich kaufe mir diese App.
Jetzt reden wir tatsächlich über Akkus?
Ich wollte über die Zukunft des Mobilfunks reden.
Und er über Batterien.
Hast du vorhin vorgelesen?
Also der eine Beitrag letztens war ja okay.
Hatte jemand mal so ein Billesbuch der Rekordereintrag, wie viel bisher der längste Podcast ist? Ich meine, wir mussten ja ein Ziel haben auf das Weiterarbeiten.
Wenn während der Sendung 200 Fletters zusammenkommen werden, dann hören wir auf.
Das ist gut. Aber wir haben noch gar keinen Eintrag für die Sendung. Das hätte man früher machen sollen.
Ich würde das ja anders machen. Ich würde ja sagen, pro 100 Fletters machen wir eine Stunde.
Der letzte Art 135.
Die Vorgonen, wer auch immer das ist, haben 5 bis 5,5 Stunden. Es gibt schon einen 24-Stunden-Podcast.
Ja, die Vorgonen sind auch die, die mit Gesang getötet haben, oder?
Nee, die Vorgonen sind auch so richtig Dauer-Podcaster-Typen. Die sind richtig hardcore.
Die schlafen mit Mikrofon.
Ja, da haben wir gar keine Chance.
Körpererfnung? Das ist deine Fantasie überlassen.
Man könnte auch überlegen, ob es wirklich angemessen ist. Und wenn nicht doch, vielleicht die Sendung beenden sollten. Irgendjemand wollte ja noch über Nokia reden.
Nee.
Echt?
Ja, die sind mir immer ein bisschen zu... Die drücken dann irgendwann so auf dem Ohren.
Na gut, nach drei Stunden musst du ein bisschen wuscheln.
Komm, hier, drück.
Aber ist der Gold Standard. Der Gold Standard?
Dann ist mein Schädel wohl nicht der Gold Standard.
Ja, ich hab jetzt nur noch so Langweiler-Themen hier auf meiner Liste.
Lies mal ganz schnell vor.
Genau, da muss doch noch was sein.
Kurz nochmal rüberfliegen.
Man soll sich Langweiler-Themen vorlesen.
Nur mal kurz, ich bin aus Neugier. Ich bin neugierig.
Das sind nur so Kortizen, die ich mir mache, falls es passt, dass man darüber auch noch redet. Was weiß ich, es gibt jetzt eine Macworld Mobile in Barcelona.
Skip it.
Skip, skip, skip.
MacCore können wir hier nochmal kurz erwähnen.
Nein, liest doch mal vorhin, wir sagen Skip, wenn es langweilig ist.
Aber wir müssen noch die Implikationen davon auch diskutieren. Warum ist es, dass es eine Macworld Mobile gibt? In Barcelona.
Skip haben wir doch gesagt.
Was ist in Barcelona jedes Jahr? Was war bisher jedes Jahr in Barcelona?
Diese GSM-Conference da. Aber die ist doch jetzt da gar nicht mehr, oder?
Und jetzt kommt nämlich die Macworld. Also die, die diese Macworld-Conference macht, geht nach Barcelona und macht zeitgleich die Macworld Mobile. Das heißt, sie machen direkt neben der GSM-Konferenz sozusagen iPhone. Da hast du sozusagen zwei Konferenzen nebeneinander zum gleichen Thema. Und auf der einen Seite gibt es nur iPhone. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es alle andere Telefone. Huckel, warum bringst du nicht mal ein Thema auf?
Re-Call!
Ich hab ja auch noch ein paar Huckel-Notizen.
Gibt's keine MacRuby-Neuigkeiten?
Hier, Viscosity hab ich hier irgendwie noch von dir.
Ist geil, kauf ich mir jetzt.
Was ist denn das?
Was hab ich schon lange gekauft? Ich hab's noch in der Tri-Version. Da ist halt hier ein Tunnelblick-Ersatz. Also so OpenVPN kleint und der funktioniert einfach. Also das so aus der Sektion funktioniert einfach. Das ist eine schöne Kategorie für unsere Sendung. Ja, da passt die Sendung selber nicht rein. Hab ich installiert, weißt du, hab ich kopiert und hat gleich die OpenVPN Connections importiert. Hab ich einfach gesagt, connect, hab ich Passwort eingegeben, hat alles gemacht. War krass.
Und wo klingt der sich ein?
Na, der bringt sein eigenes Tunntapp halt auch mit, wie so üblich.
Tunntapp.
Aber ist cool, also wirklich, das war bis jetzt die schmerzloseste OpenVPN Connectivity, die ich bisher so auf dem Mac hatte. Das händert auch als einziger Kleiner, oder zumindest als Einziger, den ich probiert hab, das mit den Nameservern so ordentlich. Ich weiß ja, da hat der Tunnelblick immer so Probleme, dass er dann irgendwie die Nameserver doch nochmal manuell setzen muss bei manchen und bei manchen dann doch wieder nicht und so. Also Viscosity, richtig geil.
Ähm, ich guck grad mal.
Sieht auch schick aus.
Die Webseite reagiert gerade nicht für mich hier. Oder reagieren die Webseiten hier gerade generell nicht.
Viscosity, OpenVPN, Klein4Mac. Nee, die Seite ist einfach langsam. Wahrscheinlich klicken gerade schon alle.
Achso.
Du hast die Seite getimmt.
Gemobile Maxed.
Nee, das find ich gut. Kann ich empfehlen. Funktioniert einfach. So, was hab ich noch für Huckelthemen?
Mich würde ja wirklich noch interessieren, wie dieses Ding sich einklinkt. Weil was ich immer für Probleme hatte mit diesem ganzen OpenVPN Kram, ist, dass die sich an einer Stelle irgendwo einklinken und quasi... Worauf geh ich hinaus? Das fragen wir uns auch. Wenn du dir diese Netzwerkkonfiguration anschaust, im Netzwerk-Control Panel, das tollste Feature daran finde ich, dass du diese Order setzen kannst. Wissen schon. Ich hab z.B. immer SwissVPN benutzt, als VPN-Lösung, weil es erstmal ein Service ist, muss mir keinen eigenen Server betreiben. Vor allem geht es über PPTP, nicht weil ich PPTP toll finde, sondern weil es einfach drin ist. Und weil es da integriert ist. Das hat den Vorteil, dass ich das einfach in dieser Service-Order an die richtige Stelle schiebe und sagen kann, wenn nicht, aber mit meinem iPhone und dann ist das auch nochmal der Default. Und Tunnelblick hat das halt nicht getan. Sich da integriert. Und ich würde eigentlich von so einem OpenVPN-Client erwarten, dass der sich eben auch als so Netzwerkinterface, so wie das jede USB, Bluetooth, Anbindungskarte auch macht.
Aber da muss ich sagen, ist mein Use-Case einfach auch ein ganz anderer. Weil ich brauch das OpenVPN immer, um mich ins Firmenetzwerk einzulehnen, um da an die Server und Shares ranzukommen oder beim Kunden ins VPN und so weiter und so fort. Also ich brauch das einfach, um mobil entwickeln zu können und immer Zugriff auf die fremden Systeme zu haben und nicht um so jetzt irgendwie meinen Traffic zu verschlüsseln oder über meinen eigenen Router zu Hause oder sonst was. Und da ist das Cosety halt einfach cool, weil ich klick einfach connect und kann, muss mich um nichts weiter kümmern und kann halt auf die Server und so weiter zugreifen. In dem Fall ist mir einfach auch total egal, welche Order oder was auch immer das hat. Ich will einfach Internet und ich will, dass die Server von dahinten auch hier sind und das hat halt funktioniert. Also das ist jetzt so ein anderer Use-Case herangehensweise. Ich kann auf jeden Fall den anderen Use-Case auch verstehen und da ist natürlich auch cool, dass man sagen will oder sagen können will, dass all der Traffic über dieses Device gehen soll oder primär über das Device, aber für mein Use-Case ist das halt eigentlich egal. Ich will einfach nur, dass es geht, dass ich andere Server aus anderen Netzen mounten kann und so.
Ich würde das gerne mal hier sehen, die Webseite. Hat die hier schon mal geladen bekommen?
Ach so, heute hier noch nicht.
Ist das wieder so eine, die über IPv6 nicht funktioniert?
Das äh, das äh, nee, oder? Meinst du?
Sowas soll's geben. Gucken, andere Computer.
Also der Google-Cache kommt damit auch gerade nicht zurecht. Morgen nochmal klicken. Aber die Webseite ist auch ganz hübsch.
Hätte schön sein können.
Okay, das war jetzt ein In-Sendung-Fail.
Das ist bestimmt nur so eine Phishing-Site, die du jetzt ja irgendwie untergedrückt hast. Genau.
Die jetzt extra abgeschaltet worden ist.
Da ist eigentlich Werbung für Hocker drauf.
Hocker ist ja jetzt scheiße, das will jetzt keiner.
Ja, nee und dann... Was hab ich noch für Huckel-Themen? Das war geil. Weil ich ja meine Oma soll... Ich versuche ja meine Oma ein iPad aufzuquatschen, Anführungsstrichen, die soll ans Internet und so. Dann war ich letztes Wochen, nee, vorletztes Wochen in der Dame mit einem iPad von der Firma und das hatte halt nur WLAN und meine Oma hat ja kein Internet, also whatsoever. Und, ähm, tja, dann hab ich überlegt, tja, wenn ich jetzt ein iPad mitnehme und es hat kein Internet, ist ja ein bisschen öde, ne? Was ich dann gemacht hatte, ich hab mein Notebook mit, mein iPhone, das iPad und zwei iPod-Kabel. Dann hab ich irgendwie Ipoxie auf dem iPhone gestartet, ein Ad-hoc-Netzwerk auf meinem Mac.
Was macht Ipoxie?
Moment, komm gleich. Also, okay, die prinzipielle Funktionsweise ist die. Du machst ein Ad-hoc-Netzwerk auf deinem Mac. Buchst das iPhone darauf ein. Und dann stellst du in deinem Mac ein, dass du ein Socks-Proxy für deinen Traffic benutzt und pointest ihn auf die IP von dem iPhone in deinem Ad-hoc-Netzwerk. Und in dem Moment kannst du halt sozusagen über das iPhone, über das WLAN, das Socks-Proxy browsen.
Aber du musst dann auf dem iPhone sozusagen noch ein Socks-Proxy konfigurieren.
Das macht dieses iProxy für dich.
Das Programm gibt es aber nicht im App Store, sondern das musst du als Developer da irgendwie mit Ad-hoc oder Developer-Kabel irgendwie überspielen.
Du musstest hier halt von GitHub den Code holen, das mit Xcode bauen und du brauchst eine Developer-Lizenz oder jemand mit einer Developer-Lizenz, der ist dir deployed.
Oder jailbreaken.
Wahrscheinlich auch das, ja. So und da ich halt genug Leute kenne und selber durch die Firma auch so einen Account hab, halt raufgefluppt und so weiter. Und dann bei Oma Ad-hoc-Netzwerk auf meinem Rechner gemacht, Socks-Proxy auf dem iPhone anstatt und dann konnte ich mit dem iPad über das Ad-hoc-Netzwerk von meinem Laptop den Socks-Proxy von meinem iPhone nutzen und konnte mit meiner Oma da schön am iPad Internet in der totalen Wüste klicken, jawoll.
Und kauft sich jetzt so eins?
Es sieht sehr dann aus, ja.
Und muss sich das MacBook Pro denn auch dazu kaufen?
Der Junge hat sich so viel Mühe gegeben, jetzt muss er sich auch lassen.
Ist meine Oma kriegt dann die 3G-Mach-Hand oder musst du die ganze Zeit mit deinem Laptop daneben sitzen?
Meine Oma kriegt 3G-Laptop.
Oma, geh jetzt mal nicht in die Show, ne? Ich will doch ein bisschen hier bleiben.
Nee, aber es hat halt funktioniert. Also es ging nicht alles. Man muss sagen, bestimmte Protokolle oder HTTPS oder irgendwie sowas ging halt.
Ganz exotisch, das haben wir.
Zum Beispiel YouTube-Videos gingen nicht. Keine Ahnung warum. Aber prinzipiell wir konnten halt brausen, Wikipedia recherchieren, Apps runterladen, the whole shebang. Und dafür, dass es halt jetzt kostenlos ist und so. Also für mich war das jetzt nicht viel Aufwand. Für Leute, die jetzt da noch nicht mit Xcode und so weiter rumgespielt haben, ist das natürlich nichts. Die bezahlen dann eher bei der Telekom oder?
Ich muss zugeben, es wäre leichter gewesen, einfach einen Jailbreak zu machen und hier My3G zu installieren.
Ich will aber nicht jailbreaken. Ich hab das jetzt schon mal gemacht.
Also ein Kumpel von mir hat ja eine Telefonkarte von einer Firma, also hier eine SIM von einer Firma und hat so ein uraltes iPhone bekommen und hat die da reingesteckt und hat schon ab und zu mal Netz benutzt, also so 66 MB wohl nur, es wäre echt nicht viel, kam eine Rechnung von 800 Euro. Irgend so ein Firmen-Sammel-Things. Wollt ihr mal gesagt haben, also Jungs, wenn ihr zum ersten Mal ein iPhone kriegt, denkt über eure Rate nach.
Mein erstes Mal.
Pass auf, mein erstes Mal war teurer. Ja klar. Pass auf, das ist jetzt nicht dein R.
So, nächste Thema.
Immer ich.
Du hast die Liste.
Du hast die Liste?
Ja, ich hab die Liste.
Dein Scheiß.
Hat dann jemand von euch das V2 auch schon aus seinem iPhone installiert?
Nee, das kann man meines Wissens noch gar nicht. Doch, das kann man.
Ja klar, das ist für alle Geräte.
Du wusstest aber, dass 10, 6, 5 Beta installieren dafür.
Ja, die hab ich sogar installiert, weil ich das drucken wollte.
Keine Ahnung wieso.
Ich dachte, das ist nur, wenn man halt diesen Druck-Support braucht.
Du musst für das iPhone 4, 2 SDK auch die Beta installieren.
Das SDK ist ja was anderes als das iPhone 2.
Aber ich glaube, mein Kollege, der Robert, der ganz ausgeschlafen ist, der meinte, wollte eigentlich erst, hat schon runtergeladen, aber dann hat er gesehen, dass man...
Aber das kann man auch da runterladen.
Ja, aber dann musst du dir halt so eine 1065 Beta installieren und dann weißt du ja, wie das ist, kannst du da nicht drüber installieren und so.
Aber die 1065 Beta braucht man nur fürs Drucken.
Er erzählt ja gerade, dass es nicht so ist. Aber gut, ich dachte auch, dass man...
Da können wir erstmal den Robert vertrauen. Vielleicht hat Robert auch Mist erzählt.
Ist Robert denn vertrauenswürdig, oder ist er einer von den Android-Wickern?
Nee, Robert ist unser primärer iOS-Developer.
Verstehe.
Und der hat auch gar keinen Bock auf Android gerade. Der macht dann immer ein ganz wehleidiges Gesicht, wenn er Android coden muss. Dann sitzt er so da...
Und weint.
Nee, sitzt so da zurückgelehnt und die Hände möglichst weit vom Keyboard entfernt und startet so auf diese Eklipse und...
Das ist nicht nur der Ort, wo man das alles per Gedanken programmieren kann.
Sein Körper wehrt sich dagegen, ja. Wir fragen mal.
Hallo, VigKal hier, das Programm.
Super Kalender.
VigKalender. Super Duftakalender fürs iPhone. Viel besser als der eingebaute, weil er kann nämlich das eine Feature, was man unbedingt braucht und was der eigentlich kann.
Ferngeräuspert.
Ja, ich wollte nur mal ein bisschen stinkern.
Er hat recht, die Kalender ist hilfreich. Das ist super. Warum es kein Wochenview gibt?
Man hat eine Wochenübersicht. Das ist alles, was das App kann. Man kann eine Wochenübersicht haben.
Ich als Kalender-Aussitzer.
Was ich ja noch schlimmer finde. Also wenn ich ein Kalenderprogramm schreiben würde, jetzt kommt wieder diese Lampe, Development Opportunity, alle iPhone-Entwickler, die irgendwie zuhören.
Es gibt einen Kunden für euer Produkt auf diesem Planeten.
Nehme mal ehrlich, ich meine, wie planst du deine Tage? Manchmal, okay, Woche ist für mich eine interessante Einheit. Ich schau gern mal auf eine Woche, aber ich will nicht immer nur von Montag bis Sonntag gucken, sondern ich will sowas wie zwei Tage nach hinten und drei Tage nach vorn. Und heute. Genau. Ich möchte, dass der aktuelle Tag immer in der Mitte ist und dass ich definieren und mit Plus und Minus sozusagen sagen kann, wie viele weitere Tage vorher und nachher noch sichtbar sein sollen. Die vergangenen, damit man so ein bisschen den Kontext behält, weißt ja, wie das heutzutage ist, sowas hab ich ja nicht gestern gemacht. Ist ja manchmal ganz hilfreich. Man wird ja auch mal gefragt.
Okay, man braucht doch keinen 1665.
Genau, seh ich nämlich auch gerade hier. Robert hat Kacke erzählt.
Robert hat Kacke erzählt.
Das kommt davon, war er bei Android niemals.
Genau, sein Hirn schon verloren.
Ich weiß, wenn ich über Kalender rede, ist das jetzt nicht so sexy, aber deswegen muss er mich ja nicht gleich dissen.
Nee, das stimmt.
Aber wir wissen schon, was deine Lieblingszene war. Kalender und Syncing.
Weißt du warum? Weil das wirklich ungelöste Probleme sind.
Aber C-Punkt hat ja immer...
Nicht so wie kalte Fusion oder wie war das?
Seedless Watermelon. Jetzt wo Seedless Watermelon gelöst ist, kann man sich auch mal wieder mit Syncing und Kalender beschäftigen.
Seit wann?
What do they plant in order to grow the Seedless Watermelon? Ja natürlich gibt es Seedless Watermelon.
Und sie sind auch kleiner, weil die haben festgestellt, dass niemand so eine riesen Melone kaufen will, sondern sie sind jetzt alle mehr so Kokosnuss groß.
Und sie haben die Oberfläche getunet, dass wenn sie nass sind, nicht so rutschig sind.
Und sie sind so Würfelförmig, damit man sie besser stapeln kann.
Warum nicht gleich noch so ein Griff dran?
Aber so stapelbare Melone gibt's wirklich, hab ich irgendwo gesehen.
Aber zielpunkt hat ja die Herangehensweise bei Termin, alles was nicht wichtig genug ist, als dass er sich das merkt, ist halt nicht wichtig genug.
So mach ich's auch.
Also er verabredet sich nur so weit, wie sein Erinnerungshorizont.
Ja, aber darum bist du ja auch nicht hier.
Das ist ein Urlaub, Mann.
Gut, komm, wir machen meinen Schluss jetzt, oder?
Wisst ihr übrigens, was cool war? Ich saß bei meiner Oma und konnte mit meinem iPhone per 3G den Livestream von Apple gucken.
Wo saß du?
Bei meiner Oma. Auf dem Land.
Wir haben schon so viele potenzielle Titel für diese Sendung.
Naja, aber es gab doch jahrelang keine Livestreams von den Keynotes. Und ich konnte die Keynote sogar per Livestream auf meinem iPhone über 3G gucken. Also nicht mal per WLAN, sondern per...
Per Browser geklickt.
Also das war schon nicht schlecht. Finde ich gut, dass sie da wieder eingestiegen sind.
Ich hab schon das erste Sound-File für unser Soundboard bekommen. Soll ich mal abspielen?
Das hat der Nokia-Chef auch gesagt, als er von der Bühne gegangen ist.
Ist nicht dein Ernst.
Ich hab's nur gelesen, aber es ist das Ende der Diwala Park-Konferenz.
Ich bin auch total brainwashed.
Ich dachte, die wollten den mal loswerden langsam, oder? Kann uns nicht passieren, Meinze.
Hier wird immer die Wahrheit gerichtet.
Ich bin wirklich furchtbar müde jetzt. Ich hab wirklich jetzt seit 20 Stunden nicht gepennt.
Wie lange ist denn die Sendung jetzt?
Lassen Sie mich frei, ich bin durch.
Bitte was?
Wie lange haben wir denn jetzt unsere Sendung?
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wo wir angefangen haben, aber ich hab jetzt hier schon... Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wo ich angefangen hab.
Dann drück doch mal Stopp.
Ich muss hier mal vor scrollen.
Scroll doch mal ne Runde.
Ich scroll mal vor hier, das scrollt aber schön lange meine Herren. Gott, so viel Gefasel. Es scrollt immer noch. Scroll schneller. Scroll more.
Faster, harder.
Hier war noch nix, hier ging es irgendwo los. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo es ernst war. Hier, okay 20 Minuten, dann haben wir 200. 30 Minuten oder so was.
Es war noch nicht so viele.
Das sind fast 4 Stunden.
3 Stunden und 40 ist echt ein Unterschied. So.
Bist du eigentlich in einer Dorfdisco, wo irgendwie die Länge entscheidet?
Du hast eh nicht eine Disco-Kugel. Bitte dich.
Disco-Kugel fehlt hier noch.
Der ist scheiße.
Ich lösche den mal, damit du den nicht nochmal benutzt. Bitte drücken sie diese Taste nicht noch einmal. Genau.
So, liebe Zuhörer, es war wieder mal schön mit euch.
Ja, es war total toll.
Und... Was das Beste ist, wir haben es geschafft, einen Zwei-Wochen-Rhythmus einzuhalten.
Beim letzten Mal hat es auch ganz schön verkackt. Da hast du bei der Vorletzten-Seitung groß erzählt, dass es irgendwie an einem Donnerstag stattfinden wird. Und dann hast du beim nächsten Mal gleich wieder alles irgendwo anders hingeschoben.
Ja, ich bin schuld.
Wie viele Leute sind denn noch im Stream jetzt eigentlich?
Wahrscheinlich keine.
Nach dieser Android-Odyssee auch.
Ich glaube deine Oma, die hat irgendwie alles rausgedienst.
Genau, beim nächsten Mal dann mit Huckels Oma.
Kinder, ihr seid wahnsinnig. Da sind ja immer noch fast alle online.
Was ist denn fast alle?
Habe ich das jetzt wirklich gesagt? 300. Die sitzen alle hier im Raum.
Und die schicken dir alle gleich an Bad Pritt Game Center Invites.
Wie viele habe ich denn jetzt schon?
Cool, und bei Saplr kann man auch die Tracks gleich auswählen, die man haben will.
Also der Coolste von uns ist doch derjenige, der die meisten Friends einen Fail Center hat, oder?
Komm, wie viele hast du? Du hast da auf Auto Accept geklickt, oder? Ich glaube ja.
Ich hab hier 39 Fremdrequests.
Ich hätte mal meinen Namen sagen sollen.
Vorhin hatte ich noch 42. Hab ich schon ein paar bestätigt.
Keine Kontaktanfragen. 27 Freunde.
Ich hab, wie sich gehört, 23. Du hast nur mehr.
Ja, würde ich nicht.
Na dann bin ich ja hier wohl der Winner, oder? Aber nur weil ich der Loser bin.
Ich dachte bei dir ging es erst nicht. Du hast die ganze Zeit gesessen und geklickt, oder was? Und warum hab ich dich immer noch nicht?
Ich hab das noch gar nicht geklickt. Das sind Requests, da muss man irgendwie Ja sagen. Hier kann man auch mal Ja sagen, das ist ja nicht so viel Facebook.
Jetzt sind wir schon wieder von der Verabschiedung abgekommen hier.
Wollt man auf vier Stunden strecken?
Jetzt müssen wir noch Raum für Steigerungen lassen.
50x Mobile Max.
Yippie, aie.
Und jetzt ist erstmal Schluss, aber heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wollte ich schonmal mal sagen. Wir kommen wieder, keine Frage.
Hoffentlich.
Immer wieder besser.
Smarter and smarter and smarter.
Da hab ich noch ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Ist das jetzt offiziell in den Duden aufgetaucht?
Was?
In den Fail Center?
Entfreunden.
Wirklich?
Das steht da? Entfreunden.
Das ist ja eine Schwänerei.
Dann kann man jetzt die Leute entfreunden.
Man kann jemanden entfreunden.
So, und wir entsenden jetzt gleich?
Ich steh auf, depublizieren, entsenden, entfreunden.
Ich lege jetzt den Kopfhörer ab, drücke von allen die Reusbar-Taste.
Haben wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges mitzuteilen eigentlich? Gibt es noch irgendwelche... Ach so, hier, Dennis, du wolltest ein Hörer-Treffen machen.
Ich geh jetzt mit Hucke, wir gehen jetzt McDonalds essen, da können wir ja auch hinkommen. Nee, könnt da voll knicken, da gehen wir nicht essen.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir ein Hörer-Treffen machen.
Wann war denn das letzte?
Schon eine Weile her.
Nein. So lang ist das nicht. Wann war das letzte Hörer-Treffen?
Letztes Jahr war das auf jeden Fall nicht.
Wann war denn überhaupt die erste denn? Das wollte ich doch vorhin schon mal nachschlagen.
Ich rauche jetzt hier drin.
Du bist die ganze Zeit nur auf dem Zettel.
Hast du keine Pflaster oder was?
Mal hier raus. An die frische Luft. April?
Ja, welcher?
April 2008.
Am Anfang.
Ja.
Ja, und ein halbes Jahr später war schon ein Hörertreffen, glaube ich.
Erster April 2008, was für ein Witz. Wir sind schon über zwei Jahre online? Ich hab gefühlt, war das für mich jetzt weniger.
Ich hab acht, nee, 26.
Hammer. 30 Monate, 50 Sendungen. Naja, da haben andere mehr Output.
Aber die sind nicht so lang. Und die haben nicht so viel Spaß.
Also rein minutemäßig sind die, glaube ich, gar nicht so schlecht.
Genau.
Und die anderen dissen auch nicht so viel Android.
Und keiner, genau.
Wir essen ja beide auf dem zweiten Platz hier.
Keiner ist so verpeilt hier.
Den hab ich nicht bei mir. Wir müssen uns mal ordentlich punkten, der Typ.
So, wollen wir jetzt mal tschüss sagen, ordentlich hier? Das ist doch wirklich ein Elend mittlerweile.
Irgendwann müssten wir hier so um den 12. Mai...
Das Intro-Gelaber und jetzt gibt es das Outro-Gelaber.
12. Mai? Ach so, wann das Hörer-Treffen war? 2009.
2009? Genau. Also Mai 2009.
Wenn er wollt, dann machen wir das mal.
Können wir mal nicht glauben. Das ist sicher.
Wir haben eine Sea-Base oder so.
Die haben wir irgendwo ordentlich hin.
Letztes Mal? Nee, irgendwo wollen wir mal was essen.
Ich meinte ja eine Sea-Base.
Wo Platz ist.
Essen kann man nicht essen.
Jetzt sollen die Leute Feuer essen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Mal gucken.
Wir lassen uns etwas einfallen. Und bis dahin bleibt uns gewogen. Und lasst euch nicht nerven von unseren Allüren. Und sonstigen Wahnsinn.
Röps und Furzgeräusche.
Am Ende muss man das auch alles gar nicht so ernst nehmen.
Genau, und spielt alle ordentlich Baxen.
Jetzt haben wir gar nicht über Symbian hoch drei gesprochen.
Oder S3, oder wie heißt das?
Wir könnten möglicherweise 24 Stunden voll machen.